ALL MEMBERS OF THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE PAGING.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE ELECTION
COULD ELECTIONS COMMITTEE.
HE'S COME TO THE ELECTIONS
HEARING THANKS
.
YEAH YOU MORNING EVERYONE WE'RE
GONNA GET STARTED.
WITH THE APRIL TENTH.
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE HEARING BEFORE WE
BEGIN HAVE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE.
FIRST WOULD EVERYONE PLEASE
SILENCER CELLPHONES.
SECOND WE HAVE AN UPDATE TO THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA FOR TODAY'S
HEARING ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FOUR BY SOME
NUMBER SALAS.
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE AGENDA
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
THIRD WHEN WE GET TO ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE ON THE AGENDA AB EIGHT
FORTY NINE BY SOMEONE OR BONTA.
THE ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE
RECENTLY REVISED THE COMMITTEE
REFERRAL ON THAT BILL AS A
RESULT IF THAT BILLS APPROVED BY
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY IT WILL BE
RE REFER TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE.
FINALLY GIVEN THE LENGTH OF THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA TODAY WE WILL
NEED TO ADHERE STRICTLY TO THE
COMMITTEES LIMIT ON TESTIMONY.
AS A REMINDER TESTIMONY IS
LIMITED TO THREE WITNESSES PER
SIDE IN TWO MINUTES PER WITNESS
BUT DON'T FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE TO
TAKE ALL THE TIME.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL BE
ASKED TO PROVIDE THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY -- WITH THAT WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
[inaudible]
WITH [inaudible]
WHICH AB THIRTY NO SIX ON NUMBER
.
FIFTEEN GOOD MORNING I'D CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MEMBER.
BEFORE I BEGIN I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL I IN THAT THERE ARE
SOME WRINKLES TO IRON OUT AND I
COMMIT TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS.
THE ISSUES AS THE BILL MORE
MOVES FORWARD.
I'M HERE 2% AB THIRTEEN OH SIX
MY BILL TO GIVE THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMITTEE.
THE AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE OR CIVIL PENALTY
AGAINST A PERSON FOR MISUSE OF
PUBLIC RESOURCES. FOR CAMPAIGN
ACTIVITY.
I'M SURE EVERYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE IS FAMILIAR WITH THE
RECENT ARTICLES REGARDING THE
USE OF FUNDS BY BAR IN SUPPORT
OF BALLOT MEASURES.
HOWEVER WE KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN
OTHER INTO INSTANT SAYS THAT
PART WHICH IS THE MOST EGREGIOUS.
I INTO THIS THIS BILL BECAUSE
SOME OF FOUR O'CLOCK
CLARIFICATION ABOUT HOW
OFFICIALS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE EXPECTED TO BEHAVE.
Là MEASURES ARE PUT ON THE
BALLOT IF NEEDED.
THE ABILITY TO IMPOSE HAVE
IMPLICATIONS FOR WHEN THOSE
RULES ARE BROKEN IS ALSO NEEDED.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT UNLESS
THERE ARE REAL DETERRENCE WHAT
WHAT PENALTIES THAT BBC CAN
IMPOSE IN THESE INSTANCES I
SIMPLY CHEST THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS.
ULTIMATELY WHAT I'M ASKING FOR
IS THAT ANYTHING THAT EACH OF US
OR OUR STAFF HAVE TO ABIDE BY.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS.
HI PHILLIP ON ON BEHALF OF THE
F. A. B. C. AS WELL AS DAVID
BAINBRIDGE AT B. B. C.'S COUNCIL
TO HELP ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU -- MISS OR MISTER CRT
INTRODUCED US YES.
NO.
IS IT EASY ENOUGH.
ANY ADDITIONAL INNOCENT SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND ITS WINNERS.
BRING IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
YEAH THIS REALLY QUICKLY I WANNA
SAYS SUPPORT THIS BILL -- THE I
THINK THERE'S A VERY MUCH.
I MEAN IT'S ALREADY LAW BUT THE
THE NEED TO HAVE THIS SEPARATION
THIS VERY CLEAR SEPARATION
BETWEEN.
YOU KNOW GOVERNMENT BODIES THERE
I'VE SEE DOING THEIR WORK BUT
THEN WHEN.
YOU KNOW MAYBE THEY WANT TO SEE
A MEASURE PASS.
THEY CAN'T BEGINNING INVOLVED ON
THAT CAMPAIGN SIDE THEY CAN'T BE
USING PUBLIC RESOURCES IN PUBLIC.
AND WE'VE SEEN THAT THAT ONE IS
GOTTEN VERY BLURRED IN MANY
DIFFERENT CASES SO I THINK
HAVING THIS ADDITIONAL TOOL.
IN PLACE THAT GIVES THAT THE PC
THAT.
HE HAS SOME TEETH TO REALLY
ENFORCE THAT IS A MUCH NEEDED
THINGS ALL THE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY THANK YOU GREAT.
WHICH ARTICLES.
YES BEFORE -- I WANTED NICK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MELENDEZ TO
INTRODUCE A SIMILAR MEASURE BUT
HAS AGREED TO JOIN AUTHOR THIS --
INSTEAD AND SO WE HAVE A
BIPARTISAN ISSUE I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND WE HAVE SOME STUFF TO WORK
ON IT YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO
FIND A GOOD PLACE TO LAND.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I. BUT
WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM PERFECT I
APPRECIATE IT AS SOON AS WE GET
TO A QUORUM -- I WILL BE
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE AS
DETAILED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSISTHEIR NUMBER OF STATE
LAWS THAT PROHIBIT THE USE OF
PUBLIC RESOURCES FOR CAMPAIGN
ACTIVITIES.
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN RELATIVELY
FEW PROSECUTIONS FOR VIOLATIONS
OF THOSE LAWS.
AS THE AUTHORS MENTION THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS LAYS OUT A
COUPLE OF CONCERNS WITH THE
APPROACH THAT THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THE BILL TAKES.
IN TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
ADDITIONALLY THE LACK OF CLEAR
STANDARDS ABOUT WHAT CONSTITUTES
A PROHIBITED CAMPAIGN ACTIVITY
BY GOVERNMENT AGENCIES PRESENTS
CHALLENGES TO COMPLIANCE WITH
THE LAW.
BUT I KNOW THAT THIS BILL WILL
BENEFIT FROM FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT HOW -- IT CAN BE REFINED --
AND IN WITH THE OTHERS
COMMITMENT THAT SHE'S GRISLY
GIVEN WILL CONTINUE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND I'M PREPARED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AS SOON AS WE
GET A QUORUM THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
OKAY MOVING ON I THINK WE'VE GOT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
WITH -- AB SIX TWENTY SIX ITEM
NUMBER.
SEVEN NUMBER A GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND I
AND THANK YOU THE EARLY BIRD
GETS THE WORM THIS MORNING HANG
TIME HERE EARLY SO I GET TO
PRESENT THE HEAD.
ANY HOW.
I AM GOING TO BE PRESENTING AB
SIX TWENTY SIX I'D LIKE.
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT MY
TESTIMONY IS A LITTLE BIT LONGER
THAN USUAL BECAUSE WE'RE REALLY
TRYING.
TO MAKE SURE THE NUANCES OF THIS
BILL ARE TOLD.
AB SIX TWENTY SIX WOULD CLARIFY
IN EXISTING CONFLICT OF IN
INTERESTS A STATUE GOVERNMENT
CODE. TEN NINETY THAT A DESIGN
PROFESSIONAL PERFORM PERFORMING
WORK ON ONE PORTION OUR FATE
PHASE OF A PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT
DOES NOT AUTOMATICALLY
DISQUALIFY THAT SAME DESIGN
PROFESSIONAL FROM PERFORMING
WORK ON IT LATER PORTION OR
PHASE OF THAT SAME.
PROJECT AND I'LL JUST JUMP IN
HERE THAT COMING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT -- AND ALSO ON SOME
OF OUR MAJOR -- BOARDS FROM
SANITATION TO SKAGGS -- THIS
REALLY PERTAINS TO SOME OF THESE
BIG PROJECTS WERE TALKING ABOUT
BECAUSE OF AMBIGUITY IN THE LAW
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT IS TAKING
PLACE TODAY.
NUMBER ONE PUBLIC AGENCY CITIES
COUNTY SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE
BEING PRECLUDED FROM CONTRACTING
WITH THE DESIGN PROFESSIONALS ON
MORE THAN ONE PORTION OF THE
PROJECT.
EVEN IF THAT ENGINEER OR
ARCHITECT OR LAND SURVEYOR IS
THE BEST MOST QUALIFIED
PROFESSIONAL FOR THE PART OF THE
PROJECT AS WELL.
NUMBER TWO PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE
ALREADY REQUIRED UNDER STATE AND
FEDERAL STATUE TO CONTRACT WITH
THESE DESIGN PROFESSIONALS ON
THE BASIS OF QUALIFICATIONS.
BASED TO SELECTIONS QB US
MEANING THAT THE ENGINEERS OR
ARCHITECTS ARE COMPETITIVELY
SELECTED ACCORDING TO HOMEOWNERS
EVER IS MOST QUALIFIED FOR THE
JOB AT HAND.
LEGISLATION WAS PASSED THROUGH
THIS COMMITTEE IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND TWENTY FOURTEEN
WHICH COLLECTIVELY SET THE STAGE
FOR THE SITUATION THAT WE ARE IN
TWO DAY ESTABLISHING THAT THE F.
P. C. C. WITH AUTHORIZED TO
ISSUE OPINIONS ON WHETHER OR NOT
A CONFLICT EXISTED.
AND A CONTRACT WITH A LOCAL
AGENCY.
NUMBER TO ANYONE WHO AIDS OR A
BET OR CAUSES A CONFLICT TO
OCCUR CAN BE HELD PERSONAL UP
PERSONALLY LIABLE TO SUBJECT TO
F. PCC.
ADMIN ACTION CIVIL FINES AND
POTENTIALLY JAIL TIME.
GOVERNMENT CODE TEN NINETY WAS
WRITTEN AND INTENDED FOR THE
SITUATION OF CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS ARE PUBLIC OFFICIALS OR
THE LIKE WHO HOLD A FINANCIAL
INTEREST.
IN ANY ENTITY ATTEMPTING TO
CONTRACT WITH THE CITY OR PUBLIC
AGENCY FOR WHICH THE PUBLIC
OFFICIAL IS THE DECISION MAKER.
WITH THE LEGISLATOR WHICH WITH
THE WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
COULDN'T HAVE KNOWN AT THAT TIME
IS THAT A LATER COURT CASE WOULD
EXTEND THOSE PROVISIONS THAT A
CONTRACTOR OR DESIGN
PROFESSIONAL COULD BE SUBJECT.
TO TEN NINETY ESSENTIALLY WHAT
THE SERIES OF THE EVENTS HAVE
DONE IS TURN THE F. T. C. C.
INTO A DE FACTO ARBITER.
ON POTENTIALLY EVERY LOCAL
AGENCY PUBLIC WORKS CONTRACTS A
ROLE THEY ARE NOT [inaudible]
FIT.
FOR LACKING CLARITY IN THE LOT
MANY PUBLIC AGENCIES HAVE SIMPLY
ELECTED TO DOES THE LAW DOES
ALLOW FOLLOW ON CONTRACTS WITH
DESIGN PROFESSIONALS SINCE THE
RISK OF GETTING IT WRONG IS TOO
GREAT.
AND AGAIN THIS GOES BACK TO SOME
OF MY LOCAL COUNCIL DAYS AND
SOME OF MY A REGIONAL BOARDS.
WITH THAT DECISION YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT QUITE A BIT OF
EXPERTISE AND ALSO DOLLARS -- AS
PROJECTS -- THE PRICES ESCALATE
WITH CHANGEOVERS AND SO FORTH SO
THIS IS REALLY.
VERY SPECIFIC WHEN YOU COME OUT
TO THESE TYPE OF LARGE CONTRACTS
IF THIS LEGISLATION PASSES THEY
WILL STILL RETAIN THAT RIGHT TO
REQUIRE FURTHER CONTRACT
RESTRICTIONS OR DISALLOW
CONTRACTS FOR ANY REASON SO.
THAT THEY DESIRE AB SIX TWENTY
SIX MERELY SEEKS TO RESTORE SOME
OF THE CLARITY TO PUBLIC
AGENCIES THAT A DESIGN PROFIT
PROFESSIONAL IS NOT
AUTOMATICALLY INCLUDED FROM
PARTICIPATING IN SUBSEQUENT
PHASES.
OF WORK IF THEY HAD ANY
INVOLVEMENT IN THE EARLIER PHASE
ULTIMATELY THE PUBLIC DESERVES
THE BEST SAFEST AND MOST COST
EFFECTIVE PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT.
IT IS IN THE PUBLIC WHO IT IS
THE PUBLIC -- SUFFERS WHEN
THEY'RE PROJECTS ARE NOT ABLE TO
BE DESIGNED BY THE BEST MOST
QUALIFIED PROFESSIONALS.
OUT WITH THAT TODAY HAVE WITH ME
JOHN MOFFITT ON BEHALF OF A C.
E. C. CALIFORNIA AND MIKE BELOW
OFFER A I A CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
GREAT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JOHN
MOFFITT ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES I THINK THE AUTHOR --
OUTLINED SORT OF THE SERIES OF
EVENTS THAT GOT US TO WHERE WE
ARE TODAY -- IF YOU KNOW THE THE
TWENTY THIRTEEN BILL ALLOWING
THE F. PPC TO GIVE OPINIONS AND
ALSO IN FORCE.
TEN NINETY THE THE FOLLOW A BILL --
IMPOSING AIDING AND ABETTING
LIABILITY ON AND CITY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT -- EMPLOYEES AND THEN
THIS TWENTY SEVENTEEN APPELLATE
COURT HEARING DAVIS BE FRESNO
UNIFIED WHICH WAS AN INTERESTING
CASE BECAUSE THE LOWER COURT
DISMISSED.
A NUMBER OF CAUSES OF ACTION
FRAUDULENT ACTIVITY IT'S AT
TRADE CENTER ONE OF THOSE CAUSES
WAS CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
IN THE LOWER COURT DISMISSED IT
SAID NO.
THE CONTRACTOR IS NOT AN OFFICER
OR EMPLOYEE FOR THE PURPOSES OF
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION TEN NINE
TEN NINETY ONLY APPLIES TO
OFFICERS AND EMPLOYEES.
IN THE SITUATION WHERE THERE'S A
KH CONTRACT AN UNDUE
INFLUENCE HE WENT TO THE
APPELLATE COURT IN THE APPELLATE
COURT.
REINSTATED SAID THE LOWER COURT
GOT IT WRONG IN A COUPLE OF
THOSE FRAUD ISSUES.
BUT THEN ALSO WITH RESPECT TO
TEN NINETY THE LOWER COURT
REMEMBER.
THIS CASE WAS ABOUT A CONTRACTOR
NOT AN ENGINEERING FIRM NOT AN
ARCHITECTURAL FIRM BUT A
CONTRACTOR.
WHO IS BUILDING A SCHOOL THEN
LEASING IT BACK TO FRESNO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT?
AND THE THE APPELLATE COURT
BASICALLY SAID WELL LOOK.
YOU KNOW YOU SHOULD LOOK INTO
THIS YOU SHOULDN'T JUST DISMISS
THIS CLAIM THAT THEY MIGHT.
BE AN OFFICER OR EMPLOYEE OF THE
YOU KNOW OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ENTITY.
AND AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT WHAT THEY SAID WAS
WHETHER DAVIS WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVE CONTRACTOR VIOLATED THE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST INTEREST
PROVISION OF GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION.
TEN TEN NINETY WILL DEPEND UPON
THE FACTS ESTABLISHED BY THE
EVIDENCE.
IT IN SIX CONTRACTOR WAS SAID
THEY MIGHT BE.
AND BUT WHAT THAT DID IS THAT
PUT US IN THE SITUATION THAT WE
ARE TODAY BECAUSE AS WE STARTED
TO SEE CONTRACTS IN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS START TO MOVE
THROUGH.
YOU'VE GOT CITY ATTORNEY'S
PUBLIC WORKS DIRECTORS AND
OTHERS WHO ARE SAYING HEY LOOK I
LIKE THESE ENGINEERS AND
ARCHITECTS BUT I'M NOT GOING TO
JAIL FOR ANYBODY.
SO THEY'RE EITHER SAYING HEY
SORRY YOU GUYS ARE OUT BECAUSE
WE JUST DON'T WANT TO DEAL WITH
THIS ISSUE.
OR THEY'RE SAYING LET'S GO TO
THE F. PPC AND GET AN OPINION.
AND SO WHAT OUR FIRMS ARE DOING
IS THEY'RE SAYING OKAY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BID ON THE EARLY PHASES
AND SO -- WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO
IN THIS BILL IT DOES NOT SAY
ANYBODY GETS A FUTURE CONTRACT
IT JUST AS A MATTER OF LAW?
THE FACT THAT YOU WERE IN PRE
DESIGN SERVICES DOES NOT
PRECLUDE YOU UNDER PROP CONFLICT
OF INTEREST FROM JUST BIDDING ON
FUTURE PHASES.
WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND ASK FOR
AYE BOAT GREAT AND IF I CAN IN.
THE BEGINNING OR FOR ONE SECOND
I'M GONNA TAKE THIS MOMENT TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM BEFORE LOSE
IT -- SERVE MADAM SECRETARY
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
BERMAN I ARE HERE BERMAN HERE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER HERE CALDERON
[inaudible]
LOW.
SO HERE MAYES.
MAYES HERE MULLIN WEBER.
WITH QUORUM GREAT REFORM SORRY
FOR THE INTERRUPTION.
IT'S YOUR TURN MEMBERS MIKE
BULLARD ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF ARCHITECTS
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF FIRST OF
ALL WITHOUT ATTEMPTING TO BETTER
ANYBODY UP THAT THE ANALYSIS.
WAS REALLY GOOD AT POINTING OUT.
THAT THE QUESTIONS HERE THERE'S
NOTHING INTUITIVE ABOUT SECTION
TEN NINETY AND HOW THIS KICKS IN.
IT'S AN IMPENETRABLE STATUTE AND
I THOUGHT IT LAID OUT YOU KNOW
IF YOU'VE READ IT YOU UNDERSTOOD
THE PROBLEM HERE -- THE PROBLEM
IS WE HAVE A STATUTE.
WHY WOULD ARCHITECTS BE IN THE
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE YEAH AND WHY
WOULD THEY BE IMPACTED BY A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST ON PUBLIC
OFFICIALS?
BUT THE PROBLEM IS SEVERE
BECAUSE THE CONSEQUENCES OF
VIOLATING THE STATUTE ARE SO
SEVERE AND IT IS BECOMING AN
ARTICLE OF FAITH AMONG THE
ARCHITECTS WE TALKED.
TO DON'T GET INVOLVED IN IT THE
EARLY PHASES OF A CONTRACT YOU
MAY BE DISQUALIFIED FROM THE BIG
PART PORTIONS OF THE CONTRACT
WHICH COME LATER.
AND SO THE THE BILL IS
ATTEMPTING TO GET THE BEST
PEOPLE IN EARLY TO GIVE THE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT THE EARLY
CONSULTATION THAT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT NEEDS.
YOU SHOULD ALSO KNOW THAT WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS CONSISTENT
WITH HOW STATE CONTRACTING IS
DONE UC AND CSU SO THIS ISN'T A
RADICAL CONCEPT AT ALL IT IS A
CLARIFICATION -- THERE HAVE BEEN
ARGUMENTS MADE IT YOU KNOW I'VE
LOOKED AT IT UP AND DOWN AND I
DON'T SEE THE LIABILITY ISSUE
FOR EXAMPLE THE THE QUESTION
AROSE IS THIS RELATE TO
APPORTIONMENT OF LIABILITY WE
BELIEVE THAT.
APPORTIONMENT OF LIABILITY IN
THE EVENT OF MALPRACTICE WILL.
HAPPEN EXACTLY AS IT DOES NOW A
WITH OR WITHOUT THIS BILL WHAT
THIS BILL WILL DO IS.
A COMMONSENSE READING OF TEN
NINETY SUGGEST JUST BECAUSE YOU
WERE INVOLVED IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF THE CONTRACT YOU
SHOULD NOT BE AUTOMATICALLY
DISQUALIFIED FROM LATER WORK.
AND FOR THAT WE THINK THE IT'S
GOOD FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT IT'S
GOOD FOR CONTRACTING -- AND WE
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CHRIS CON REPRESENT THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SCOTT
GOVERNOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE LARGEST.
UNIONIZED GENERAL CONTRACTORS IN
THE STATE THE FRESNO CASE
ACTUALLY INVOLVED ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS -- IT IS INTERESTING
THAT THIS BILL IS IN ELECTIONS
BECAUSE IT'S KIND OF A
CONVERGENCE OF ELECTIONS AND
PUBLIC CONTRACTING.
WHICH IS REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE. TO THE
EXTENT THIS BILL IS SIMPLY.
CLOSING THE LOOPHOLE.
WHY IS IT ONLY LIMITED TO DESIGN
PROFESSIONALS RIDE WHY NOT
CONTRACTORS ONE OUT EVERY FORM
OF PROCUREMENT?
THE REASON IS IT IS AND SHOULD
BE A CONFLICT WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS HOW WHAT WILL
WORK IN.
THE REAL WORLD.
A DESIGN PROFESSIONAL WILL GET A
PRECONSTRUCTION.
AGREEMENT SO THEY WILL ASSIST
THE AGENCY IN DEVELOPING THE
PLAN FOR CONSTRUCTION.
THEY COULD THEORETICALLY.
ALTER THAT PLAN TO CREATE -- AND
I'M LEVEL PLAYING FIELD AS IT
RELATES TO THE BIDDING FOR THE
DESIGN WORK.
AS THE DESIGNER THEY COULD THEN
TELL THE PUBLIC AGENCY THAT THEY
ARE THE ONES WHO SHOULD BE HIRED
AS THE CONSTRUCTION MANAGER.
SO TO THE EXTENT CONSTRUCTED
BILLET THE ISSUES ARISE ISN'T AS
THE LIABILITY MR BLOOD WAS
REFERRING.
TO THE ONLY WAY AN AGENCY.
COULD PROTECT THEMSELVES IS GONE
RIGHT THERE IS NO OBJECTIVE
VOICE THE CONSTRUCTION MANAGER
WOULD HAVE TO BLAME THEMSELVES
FOR DESIGN FLAWS.
AND CAN YOU IMAGINE THAT.
WE SCREW THIS UP SO WE'RE GOING
TO BE ON THE HOOK IT'S NOT GONNA
HAPPEN WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
INSTEAD IS THEY'RE GOING TO
BLAME THE LICENSE CONTRACTORS
AND SAY WELL THEY DID.
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY THE PUBLIC
AGENCIES THE TAXPAYERS WILL HAVE
NO OBJECTIVE VOICE IN THE
PROCESS THIS IS WHY.
IT IS A CONFLICT THAT'S WHY MY
MEMBERS ARE CLAMORING. TO KIND
OF PERMIT THIS PRACTICE BUT TO
THE EXTENT YOU WANT PER MINUTE
WRECK YOU KNOW RECOGNIZE THE
AGENCIES ARE LOSING OBJECTIVITY
THEY ARE ALLOWED AND ONE PARTY.
TO RIG EACH BID TO AWARD TO
THEMSELVES AND WHAT PROBLEMS
ARISE.
THERE'S NO ONE THERE SO WE THINK
THIS IS BAD POLICY IT'S REMAIN A
CONFLICT -- BUT IF THE GOAL OF
THIS COMMITTEE IS TO OPEN IT UP
TO EVERYONE THEN DO JUST THAT
ALLOW EVERYONE WHO PRIDES PRE
CONSULTING SERVICES NOT ANY
PROJECT.
ON ANY TYPE OF CONTRACT TO DO IT.
WE DON'T THINK IT'S GOOD POLICY
BUT IF YOU WANT TO HAVE A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD THAT'S WHAT YOU
SHOULD DO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TAUGHT
BLOOM STEIN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION THIS IS A DANGEROUS
MEASURE WE ASK FOR AN OVER.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
WALKER BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
SHEET METAL AIR CONDITIONING
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION A WE TO
WERE OPPOSED TO AFTER THE
CONFLICT REASONS STATED BY MR
GOVERNOR -- IF IT'S IF IT'S
CONFLICT FOR US IT'S A CONFLICT
FOR THE ARCHITECTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE AT BRING
BACK TO COLLEGE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISTER MESS.
WHAT'S THE THE TALK ABOUT THOSE --
THOSE THOSE TWO THINGS -- WHAT
IS IT A CONFLICT OF IT DOES
CONTINUE TO BE A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST AND IT ISN'T THAN --
THAT AND BE AS SPECIFIC AS YOU
CAN AS AS WHITE ISN'T.
IT IT.
I THINK THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
WELL THAT WHEN THE F. PPC IS THE
HAS BEEN BROUGHT THESE CASES IN
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THEM THEY
FOUND THAT NO CONFLICT EXISTS.
TO TO MISTER GOVERNOR'S POINT TO
BE PERFECTLY BLUNT IF I WAS THEM
I WOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT THIS
FRESNO V. UNIFIED RULING AND ITS
APPLICATION TO CONTRACTORS FEW
IN THE FUTURE.
THAT WAS A CASE ABOUT A
CONTRACTOR.
AND WE DON'T DISAGREE THAT WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT WHEN YOU HAVE
FACED PROJECTS.
THAT ARE COMPETITIVELY BID USING
QUALIFIED BASED SELECTION WHICH
IS THE LAW.
WHICH IS THE MOST QUALIFIED
ENTITY OR FIRM SHOULD GET THE
NEXT PHASE OF THIS PROJECT.
AND ITS BID EVERY SINGLE STEP OF
THE WAY.
WE BELIEVE IT SHOULDN'T BE A
CONFLICT FOR THEM EITHER YOU
KNOW THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO TO
TO BE A PART OF THE EARLY
CONSTRUCTION PART OF THE PROJECT.
AND THEN GET FUTURE PHASES THAT
PROJECT TO IF THEY'RE THE BEST
FOR HIM FOR THAT.
AND AND I AGREE I THINK THIS
THIS CASE -- AND THE HESITANCY
ON BEHALF OF LOCAL PUBLIC
ENTITIES IS CATCHING UP US TO US
NOW BECAUSE WE ARE ON THE FRONT
END.
OF PROJECTS PRE DESIGN EARLY
DESIGN STRUCTURAL DESIGN AS
PROJECTS MOVE ALONG THEY'RE
GOING TO GET IN THE CONSTRUCTION
PHASES AND SO I I DON'T DISAGREE
WE DON'T BELIEVE IT'S A CONFLICT
FOR US WE DON'T BELIEVE IT'S A
CONFLICT FOR THEM.
AS LONG AS QPS IS FOLLOWED WHICH
IS STATE STATUTE AND AS LONG AS
EACH PHASES COMPETITIVELY BID
WITH THE INFORMATION PUT OUT
THERE SO THAT.
BIDDERS ON EACH PHASE THE
PROJECT CAN SEE THE WORK THAT
WAS DONE BEFORE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DATA AT ALL BUT
BEFORE THERE'S THIS CHILLING
EFFECT OCCURRED -- THOSE WHO DID
THE PRE DESIGN WORK -- HOW MANY
OF THOSE FIRMS ENDED UP GETTING
THAT THE CONTRACT OR WAS IT IS
OR ANY?
ANY DATA ON THAT AT ALL I DON'T
I DON'T HAVE ANY PRE DATE ON
THAT BUT I CAN GIVE YOU A MORE
RECENT EXAMPLE ONE OF OUR
ENGINEERING FIRMS HAD DID SOME
PRE DESIGN WORK FOR A WATER
DISTRICT IN SAN LUIS OBISPO.
THEY DID THE PRE DESIGN WORK.
THE THE WATER DISTRICT GOT THAT
WORK BACK PUT THE NEXT PHASE OUT
FOR AN RFP.
THE ENGINEERING FIRM WANTED TO
BID ON THAT.
TOO THE WATER DISTRICT ASKED THE
F. PPC FOR AN OPINION THE F. PPC
SAID THERE MAY BE A CONFLICT
HERE YOU NEED TO GATHER MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT PRE WORK.
THE WATER DISTRICT DID THAT FELT
COMFORTABLE THAT THERE WASN'T A
CONFLICT.
PUT IT OUT THAT ENGINEERING FIRM
BID ON THAT CONTRACT DIDN'T GET
IT.
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT THE MOST
QUALIFIED BIDDER FOR THAT NEXT
PHASE AND SO TO SUGGEST THAT
SOMEHOW.
THESE THINGS CAN ALWAYS BE
SKEWED IN THE FAVOR OF THE OF
THE FIRM THAT DID THE EARLIER --
THE EARLIER WORK IT'S JUST FALLS
IT DOESN'T ALWAYS OCCUR THAT WAY
SOMETIMES AND EVEN THE F. PPC.
POINTED OUT THEIR MOST RECENT
OPINION SOMETIMES THERE'S A GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY REASON. FOR THE
SAME FIRM TO BE DOING YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT PHASES OF WORK AND
THAT'S OKAY THAT IS NOT A
CONFLICT.
MICHELLE I'M GONNA MOVE THE BILL
TODAY -- BUT I THINK THERE'S
PROBABLY NEED TO BE SOME
ASSURANCES.
ON THIS BUT I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT
THE AUTHOR -- BUT WOULD WOULD
BRING FOR THE BILL -- THAT IS
GOING TO ALLOW FOR A FOR
INCREASED CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
AND I'M A I WOULD IMAGINE THAT
THE AUTHORS GONNA CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO MAKE
SURE.
OF THAT WOULD THAT WE GET SOME
CLARIFICATION OF CLARIFICATIONS
NEEDED SOME OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU IN MOTION THE SECOND
BY SIR GALLAGHER.
YES SO I MEAN HEY LOOK IN THIS
OVER IT'S IT'S REALLY NOT I
THINK IT IS A PRETTY COMPLEX
ISSUE.
AND I GUESS.
MY UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO AT LEAST IN CURRENT
FORM IS SORT OF PROVIDE A
BLANKET EXEMPTION. FOR CERTAIN
DESIGN PROFESSIONALS ARCHITECTS.
AND SAY THERE IS NO CONFLICT OF
INTEREST IS THAT CORRECT.
WELL I WAS GOING TO ADD HERE IS
ON AND I AM VERY MUCH WILLING TO
SIT DOWN AND TALK TO THEM SOME
OF THE OPPOSITION.
BUT IN THIS CASE WERE SPEAKING
JUST ABOUT THE ARCHITECTS BUT
THAT DOESN'T PRECLUDE THAT WE
COULDN'T GO BACK AND LOOK AT
OTHER -- ENTITIES I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS IS TO MAKE THE
ASSUMPTION IS THAT JUST BECAUSE
SOMEBODY HAS WORKED ON THE
DESIGN PHASE THAT ACT
AUTOMATICALLY MEANS THEY'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE NEXT PHASES I
MEAN LIKE I SAID I'VE BEEN ON
SOME OF THE REGIONAL BOARD
SANITATION.
THAT HAS HUGE CONTRACTS AND THAT
IS NOT ALWAYS THE CASE THE
OPPOSITE OF IT IS ALSO THE
REVERSE WHERE YOU MAY.
GO OUT FOR AN RFP I ON THE BOARD
MAKES A DECISION BASED ON MANY
FACTORS WHETHER IT'S COST
pWHETHER IT'S QUALIFICATIONS AND
THEN LATER ON BECAUSE OF CHANGE
ORDERS YOU HAVE QUITE A BIT OF
DIFFERENCE IN WHAT WAS INITIALLY
PRESENTED.
SO -- AS FAR AS THIS CONFLICT
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- I
THINK RIGHT NOW IT'S VERY
SPECIFIC.
TO THE ARCHITECTS BUT IT DOES
NOT MEAN WE'RE NOT WILLING TO
LOOK AT TO EXPANSION OR EVEN NOT
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION VERY
CAREFULLY WILL BUT SO THAT
READING IS IT'S ENGINEERED
GEOLOGIST ARCHITECT LAND
SURVEYOR OR PLANNER.
RIGHT REFORM IN SPECIFIED
SERVICES ON A PROJECTS SO
THERE'S SEVERAL DIFFERENT OF THE
DESIGN THE DESIGN TEAM IN
ESSENCE BUT WHAT I'M SAYING WHAT
I'M GETTING AT IS IS THIS SAYING
THAT HEY THEY CAN NEVER BE FOUND
TO HAVE A CONFLICT UNDER.
TEN NINETY IF THIS BILL PASSES
IT'S IT'S A BLANKET EXEMPTION IF
THEY WERE INVOLVED IN THE PRE
CONSTRUCTION WORK THEY CAN NEVER
BE FOUND TO HAVE A CONFLICT IS
NOT CORRECT.
NOT THAT I'M UNDERSTANDING IT
THAT WAY YEAH I KNOW THAT I'M
ROGER PALM PRESIDENT RICK
ENGINEERING COMPANY -- AND A
MEMBER OF A CC WE'VE WORKED --
MY MEMBERSHIP -- WITH AN
ORGANIZATION FOR NUMBER YEARS ON
THIS.
THIS THIS BILL IF IT WERE PASSED
IN ITS CURRENT FORM WOULD NOT
PRECLUDE IT WOULD NOT BY
STATUTES SAY THAT THERE IS NO
CONFLICT OF INTEREST YOU WOULD
SAY BY STATUTE.
THAT THERE ISN'T NECESSARILY A
CONFLICT.
IT WOULD ENABLE -- A PUBLIC
AGENCY.
TO SELECT A A PARTICULAR DESIGN
PROFESSIONALS TO PERFORM
SUBSEQUENT SERVICE DOESN'T TELL
THEM TO DO THAT.
BUT IT WOULDN'T NECESSARILY
PRECLUDE THEM FROM BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE THOSE OVER FOR SERVICES.
IN IN A PUBLIC AGENCY IS AS IT
WOULD ALLOW THE PUBLIC AGENCY
THAT CHOICE. TWO SELECT A NEW
CONSULT IF THEY'RE DOING THE
PROJECT IN MULTIPLE FACES.
REDOING A PRELIMINARY DESIGN
PHASE THE SUB TO THE WE DECIDE
FOR EXAMPLE THAT THEY HAVE
FUNDING AND ABLE TO MOVE THE
PROJECT ON TO THE NEXT PHASE.
THEY WOULD.
THEY WOULD UNLESS THERE WAS SOME
OTHER EXTENUATING CIRCUMSTANCES
OUTLINED IN A IN IN THE BILL
THEY WOULD BE.
THAT BY STATUTE THEY WOULD BE
PRECLUDED FROM USING THE SAME
DESIGN.
FOR HER SUBSEQUENT FATE.
IT WOULD ALLOW THEM.
BUT IT WOULDN'T COME HELD THEM.
TO USE THAT SAME CARD.
RIGHT BUT ISN'T THAT KIND OF
CURRENT LAW AS WELL BECAUSE LIKE
AS YOU SAID MOST OF THE TIME
THAT AT PPC HAS WEIGHED IN ON
THIS THEY FOUND THAT THERE ISN'T
A CONFLICT HOWEVER.
THERE HAVE BEEN CASES.
WHERE THEY HAVE FOUND -- SO FOR
EXAMPLE FROM THE ANALYSIS THERE
WAS A SIMON ADVICE LETTER.
IN REACHING THAT CONCLUSION THAT
THERE WAS A CONFLICT THE F. B.
PC NOTED THAT THE ARCHITECTURAL
FIRM WAS ENTER CURRENT
INTEGRALLY INVOLVED IN THE
PRELIMINARY DISCUSSIONS.
NEGOTIATIONS REASONING PLANNING
AND SPECIFICATIONS THAT WILL
RESULT IN THE CONTRACT FOR
ARCHITECTURAL DESIGN.
OF A NEW JAIL AND AND THEREFORE
HAS THE POTENTIAL. TO EXERT
CONSIDERABLE INFLUENCE OVER THE
COUNTIES DECISIONS CONCERNING --
ZONING ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER
I THINK ONE OF THE ISSUES ISN'T
THAT THEY COULDN'T.
FIND A CONFLICT OR THAT THEY
COULD I THINK IT'S THE CLARITY.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THERE'S THIS
NARRATIVE.
THAT IF YOU START WITH THE
DESIGN PHASE THEN IT RISKY TO
MOVE TO THE NEXT PART OF THE
PROJECT AND IN ORDER TO BE
EXTREME.
IN ESSENCE A SAFE VERSUS SORRY
THERE'S THERE'S COLLUDED RIGHT
THEY'RE MAKING THAT DECISION
THEMSELVES WITHOUT EVEN GOING
THROUGH THE F. T. C. C. N. SO
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE F. T.
C. C..
STILL WOULDN'T SAY THERE'S A
CONFLICT DEPENDING ON THE
PROJECT I MEAN I THINK THAT EACH
ONE OF THESE CASES END OF IT IS
INDIVIDUALLY LOOKED AT SO YOU'RE
SAYING THAT WOULD JUST REALLY
QUICKLY SO YOU'RE SAYING IN.
IN YOUR COMPANY'S CASE YOU'LL
EVEN EXCLUDE YOURSELVES FROM.
OTHER WORK ON THE JOB OTHER WORK
ON A PARTICULAR JOB BECAUSE
YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT THIS.
ABSOLUTELY.
IF THERE'S A LOCAL PAYS FOR A
PROJECT IT'S REALLY SIMPLE DAY
TYPICALLY NOT NECESSARILY ALWAYS
BUT TYPICALLY THE FRONT END OF A
PROJECT FOR LIMON EVERY SERVICES.
INVOLVES A LESSER AND LOWERED
FEET.
THAT L. HIGHER FEE IS USUALLY
ATTENDED WITH THE PROPRIETORS
PREPARATION OF CONSTRUCTION
DOCUMENTS AND SPECIFICATIONS
RIGHT IF YOU FEEL THAT YOU'RE
WELL QUALIFIED TO DO EITHER BUT
YOU KNOW THAT YOU'VE GOT A
CHANCE TO DO ONE OR THE OTHER.
SOME FIRMS AND WHERE ONE OF THEM
HAVE IT TIMES DECIDED WE'RE
GONNA KEEP OUR POWDER DRY ON THE
FRONT END OF THIS PROJECT
BELIEVING THAT THERE WILL BE A
SECOND PHASE AND THEN COMPETE
ONLY ON THE BACKEND.
OKAY [inaudible]
YES IN.
SO WHAT I STRUGGLE WITH THE JUST
A LITTLE BIT HERE IS BECAUSE I
CAN SEE THAT THERE COULD BE
CONFLICTS YOU KNOW AND AND I
THINK THERE'S INSTANCES FOR
EXAMPLE WHERE THERE'S MAYBE.
YEAH EVEN IN SMALL TOWNS WHERE
THERE'S ONLY.
ONE YOU KNOW GROUP IN TOWN AND
THEY HELP TO THE KIDS THE DESIGN
AND AND ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW
SURPRISE SURPRISE THEY GET THE
CONTRACT.
YOU KNOW DOWN THE ROAD I MEAN
SAID THERE THERE IS ESPECIALLY
WHEN THERE'S A LOT OF
INVOLVEMENT ON THE FRONT I'M
WITH HOW THIS THING GET SET UP.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR I THINK THERE COULD BE
ISSUES OF CONFLICT OF INTEREST
TEN NINETY IS A REALLY HARSH.
STANDARD AS WE KNOW AND AND AND
I THINK THE OTHER ISSUE HERE IS
THAT USUALLY.
AT LEAST THE WAY I'VE ALWAYS
HEARD EXPLAINED TEN NINETY IS
REALLY SPECIFICALLY GEARED
TOWARDS ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES.
IT'S NOT REALLY THE INTENT OF IT
IS NOT TO GO AFTER CONTRACTORS --
HOWEVER SINCE WHERE THEY GET SO
INTER TWINED IN THE DECISION
MAKING.
THAT THERE COULD BE AN ISSUE AND
SO.
THAT'S A MAN THAT'S WHY I THINK
I KIND OF STRUGGLE WITH THIS
BILL LITTLE BIT THERE COULD BE
THE THE CONFLICT.
BUT AS YOU SAY -- AND IN MANY
CASES THERE REALLY ISN'T AS
PRECLUDING GOOD PEOPLE FROM
BILLION -- PROJECTS -- AND I
THINK IT IS BECAUSE OF THE
DILEMMA IT I MEAN I I'VE SAID
PROBABLY THREE TIMES TO MY LOCAL
COUNCIL DAYS.
I IT YOU MAY HAVE AN INITIAL.
ARCHITECT DESIGN FIRM THAT DOES
INDEED GET THE NEXT PART OF THE
PHASE AND IF YOU ANALYZE THAT IS
WELL I MEAN IF THERE'S ONLY.
ONE IN A SMALL CITY OF THERE'S
ONLY ONE BIG FIRM.
THERE ARE IN ANY THEY'RE USING
THIS THIS PRACTICE IN THAT VERY
WELL COULD BE ON THE OTHER HAND
IF YOU HAVE MULTIPLE FIRMS I
KNOW.
IN FULLER TEN WE YOU I WAS PART
OF THE LAST MAJOR REDEVELOPMENT
PROJECT.
THAT WE HAD IN SOME OF THOSE
WERE SUBSTANTIAL THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECTS TO TO DESIGN
REDO A LIBRARY COMMUNITY CENTER
SOME OF THESE PROJECTS.
AND WE DID IN FACT USE THE SAME
FIRM FOR BOTH PROJECTS ON THE
OTHER HAND THERE WERE OTHER
PROJECTS THAT WE DID NOT USE
THEM BUT WE DID USE THE SAME
FIRM FROM BEGINNING. TO END ON
TWO PROJECTS I CAN THINK OF BUT
WE HAD MULTIPLE PROJECTS THAT WE
DIDN'T USE THEM.
FOR THANK.
DID TO JUST ONE LAST POINT. ONE
LAST POINT YOU KNOW I THINK WE
RECOGNIZE WE COULD USE SOME FINE
TUNING AS WE MOVE ALONG HERE --
ONE OF THAT ONE OF THE LETTERS
THAT WAS GIVEN TO THE COMMITTEE
RAISE THE ISSUE OF DESIGN BUILD
WE'VE ALREADY OFFERED AN
AMENDMENT TO EXEMPT DESIGN BUILD
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN SPECIFIC
STATUTES WITH RESPECT TO
CONFLICT FOR DESIGN BUILD.
WAS NOT OUR INTENT TO GO AFTER
THOSE THINGS AND SO WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY WILLING TO KEEP FINE
TUNING IS THE BILL MOVES THROUGH
THE PROCESS GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES.
SO I THINK WHAT OFFER CLICK
IMAGE CHAIRS AGAIN LISTEN IS
CONVERSATION OR ALRIGHT ABOUT
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE BUT WE KEEP
THE PUBLIC'S TRUST.
EVEN BE EVEN IN REGARDS TO
BIDDING I THINK ABOUT THE SMALL
COMMUNITIES AND VERY SMALL
PROJECTS THIS IS WHEN THIS
BECOMES.
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
YOU MIGHT NOT GET ENOUGH BEDS --
YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE SOMEBODY BED
AFTER THE DOING THE PLUMBER
DESIGN WORK TO ACTUALLY DO DO TO
DO THE PROJECT AND SO -- AGAIN
MY WILL JUST BEFORE MAKING THE
MOTION I THINK THE AUTHORS WELL
WHERE THIS INITIAL CONTINUE WORK
ON THIS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
GET CONTINUE.
TO KEEP THE PUBLIC TRUST IT IN
MIND -- AND AND WORK ON IT AS AS
WE GO FORWARD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I JUST THAT I'D LIKE TO MENTION
THAT IT'S NOT THE INTENT OF THIS
LEGISLATION TO SUPERSEDE THE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST PROVISIONS
THAT ARE ALREADY PRESENT UNDER
DESIGN BUILD.
AUTHORIZING STATUTES AND WE
COMMIT TO CONTINUING TO WORK ON
THIS GREAT I APPRECIATE THAT --
YEAH THE I AGREE WITH THE MOST
OF IF NOT ALL THE CAUGHT --
COMMENTS ARE MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUES THIS IS PROBABLY THE
BILL THAT I STRUGGLE WITH THE
MOST AND AND THERE WERE A LOT OF
BILLS I STRUGGLE WITH IN THIS
HEARING -- BUT THERE I'M
CONVINCED THAT THERE IS A A
PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM
DOESN'T CREATE OTHER PROBLEMS --
AND I'M NOT CONVINCED OF THAT
TODAY -- WHICH IS WHY.
YEAH WE'VE WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE -- BUT
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON THE BILL WITH INTERESTED
PARTIES WITH THE OPPOSITION --
AND WITH THE F. F. PPC.
AND WITH THE THE EXPLICIT
UNDERSTANDING THAT I MAY ASK FOR
THE BILL TO COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE DEPENDING ON HOW THOSE
DISCUSSIONS GO.
I AM PREPARED TO SUPPORT THE
BILL THE DAY TO A LOT OF
DISCUSSION TO CONTINUE -- SO
WITH THAT -- READY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE.
BERMAN AYE AYE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER I CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE LOW.
NO I'M MAYES.
MAYES MULLIN WEBER.
WEBER I THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THE BILL IS OUT WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS --
MISTER VICE CHAIR I'M GONNA ASK
YOU TO TAKE OVER AFTER THE
PRESENT IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
OKAY SEE WE HAVE MISSED MELENDEZ
HERE -- GOOD COME UP -- OR SORRY.
MR GLORIA WAS HERE FIRST COME ON
UP.
SORRY MULLIN WE ARE IN SIGNED IN
ORDER MELENDEZ WAS NUMBER ONE
BUT SHE'S TRADING WITH MR GLORIA
SAID THAT DOES HAPPEN HERE ALL
RIGHT.
SO MR GLORIA YOU HAVE.
I'M LOOKING FOR MY AGENDA HERE.
BOTTOM FOURTEEN AB.
ELEVEN FIFTY GO AHEAD SIR THANK
YOU -- IN APPRECIATION OF MY
COLLEAGUE.
FROM LAKE ELSINORE FOR ALLOW ME
GO AHEAD OF HER A GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF COMMITTED I'M
REPRESENTING AB ELEVEN FIFTY
TODAY.
IN MOST LARGE CITIES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BOARD MEMBERS ARE
REQUIRED TO EITHER PAY A FILING
FEE OR PRODUCE SIGNATURES FROM
THE COMMUNITY IF THEY'RE SEEKING
TO REPRESENT.
IN FACT ALL OF YOU IN THIS ROOM
TODAY YOU HAD TO PAY A FEE OR
GATHER UP TO THREE THOUSAND
SIGNATURES TO NOT ONLY
DEMONSTRATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
SERVICE.
BUT ALSO TO SHOW THAT YOU HAVE
SUPPORT IN THE COMMUNITIES YOU
WISH TO REPRESENT.
THE CITY OF COMMITTEE CALLS
DISTRICT BOARD AS WELL AS THE
GROSS MONTHLY MARKET COLLEGE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT BOARD
I DO NOT HAVE THE SIMPLE
DEMOCRATIC.
REQUIREMENTS AB ELEVEN FIFTY
ADDRESSES THIS BY REQUIRING CAN
IT'S FOR THE GOVERNING BOARDS OF
THESE TO COMMUTE BECAUSE
DISTRICTS TO COLLECT AT LEAST A
HUNDRED SIGNATURE ABOUT LEGAL
BUT SIGNATURES OF VOTERS AND
THEIR TRUSTY AREA.
AND SUPPORTER CANDIDACY IN ORDER
TO QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT WITH
THIS BASIC BALLOT APARTMENT
THERE HAVE BEEN CASES OF
CANDIDATES RUNNING FOR MULTIPLE
OFFICES AT THE SAME TIME. FOR
EXAMPLE MOST RECENT LOGIC SITE
SELECTION CYCLE THERE WAS A
CAN'T DEVOTE BAND FOR BOTH THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE THIS REPORT.
AND THE LEMON GROVE CITY COUNCIL
COLLECTING SIGNATURES THE
COMMONSENSE DEMOCRATIC WAY TO
DEMONSTRATE WITH ME SUPPORT --
TO ENSURE THE KIDS READY FOR
THESE POSITIONS ACTUALLY HAVE
SUPPORT OF THE DISTRICTS ARE
SEEKING REPRESENT.
WITH ME THIS MORNING AS BRIAN
HOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS EXPECT WE
ASK YOUR EITHER.
IS MOVED IN BY SUMMER CALDERON
SECONDED BY MISTER LOW.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN HOW
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS ARE I WANT TO JUST
ECHO EVERYTHING THAT MR GLORIA
JUST SAID BUT I DO WANT TO ADD.
THAT THIS BILL IS ALSO
COSPONSORED BY THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS SCALE
LOCAL.
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE AND
SUPPORTED BY THE CENTER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
GROSSMONT CUYAMACA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT SAN DIEGO MESA
COLLEGE ACADEMIC SENATE.
AND THE SAN DIEGO MAYES A
COLLEGE CLASSIFY SENATE I YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION --
ANY -- ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CENA BRING IT BACK SOME MEMBER
MAYES.
IT'S A JUST AND AND LOOKING AT
THIS -- A HUNDRED SIGNATURES SO
ASSEMBLY WE ONLY HAVE TO COLLECT
FORTY SIGNATURES IF I REMEMBER.
CORRECTLY -- SO TO HAVE TO GET A
HUNDRED SIGNATURES TO BE ABLE TO
BUT TO RUN FOR COLLEGE BUT I I
GUESS I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PROBLEM THAT THERE'S MULTIPLE
CANDIDATES THAT ARE RUNNING.
IN THE SEATS AND MAYBE THEY'RE
NOT REAL SERIOUS ABOUT ABOUT
RUNNING AND SO YOU WOULD HAVE
SOME SORT OF LEVEL PROTECTION
BUT OUR ISN'T THE FILING FEES
AND OTHER THINGS THAT HAVE TO BE
DONE JUST SEEMS WEIRD THAT YOU
HAVE TO CLICK THE HUNDRED
SIGNATURES TO RUN FOR SCHOOL.
FOR FOR COLLEGE BOARD BUT ONLY
FORTY SIGNATURES TO RUN FOR A
FOR STATE ASSEMBLY.
MISS MISS MAYES.
WE'RE TRYING -- TO CURRENTLY
MAYOR -- THE CURRENT REQUIREMENT
THAT IS REQUIRED BY THE BY THE
K. TWELVE SEND YOU OF A SCHOOL
BOARD DISTRICT DAY CURRENTLY
ALLOW HUNDRED SIGNATURES.
OKAY I GUESS SOMEONE WONDER WHAT
WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO SOLVE FOR
HERE WHAT'S THAT WHAT'S THE GOAL
HERE WHAT WE SOLVING.
FOR WE'RE ALSO TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT THAT THAT THE CANDY THAT
DIED THAT DAY WHICH TO SERVE IN
THE DISTRICT -- THAT THEY DO
HAVE SOME SUPPORT I'M KIND OF IN
THE DISTRICT.
OKAY THAT THAT THAT THE
INSPIRATION OF A CANDIDACY IS
NOT PUBLIC SERVICE IT'S NOT SELF
AGGRANDIZEMENT -- WITH WITH NO
FEE NO SIGNATURES -- YOU KNOW
YOU SEE VACANCY DECIDE TO RUN --
IT OF ONE WOULD ARGUE THAT'S
DEMOCRATIC BUT I WOULD SAY THAT
THE THE THE PROCESS THAT WE
REQUIRE OF A LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS AS WELL AS ADJACENT --
COUNTY BOARD SCHOOL THE SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS -- AND OTHERS DO
HAVE THIS REQUIREMENT IT'S
UNUSUAL THAT THE SAN DIEGO
COMMITTEE BECAUSE DISTRICT AS
WELL AS THE GHOST BUCKLEY A
MARKET DON'T HAVE -- ANY SUCH
REQUIREMENTS OF HARMONIZING THAT
WITH OTHER AREA EDUCATION BOARDS.
THE NUMBERS ARE DIFFERENT TYPES
OF SENATORS I WILL KNOWLEDGE
THAT I WE WOULD WITH THE HIGHER --
ONE BUT AS YOU NOTED IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT SO ONEROUS THIS TO BE A
DISQUALIFYING -- BUT JUST I
THINK SHOWS MORE SERIOUSNESS OF
THE PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
APPROPRIATE MULTI MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGETS -- CAM.
SEE THE CHAIRS COME BACK HERE.
CELL PAST EXPECTED BUT I GUESS
THIS DRUG HERE'S WHY ISN'T THIS
A LOCAL ISSUE AND IT SEEMS LIKE
MAN WE GET A LOT OF SAN DIEGO
ISSUES.
HERE IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
WAS LIKE HEY MAN IF YOU GUYS
HAVE PROBLEMS WITH YOUR LOCALS
AND HOW THEY CONDUCT THINGS TALK
TO YOUR CITY COUNCILMAN AND AND
YEARS AND YEARS.
TRUSTEES AND AND SAY HEY MAN WE
THINK YOU GUYS SHOULD CHANGE
YOUR STANDARDS.
I DON'T THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE
THE BODY.
THAT ESTABLISHES THOSE FOR YOUR
LOCAL ELECTIONS.
YOU KNOW AND I SUSPECT HE DOES
SINCE THE FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
IS HERE THAT MAYBE THERE'S YOUR
ANOTHER MOTIVE HERE AS WELL --
AND HE OF PEOPLE RUNNING FOR
SELF AGGRANDIZEMENT AND POLITICS
MEN THAT'S A PRETTY TOUGH
PROBLEM TO SOLVE RIGHT THERE.
NOT ONLY WE'RE GOING TO SOLVE IT
IN THIS COMMITTEE BUT WITH THAT
I JUST I MEAN SO THAT WOULD BE
JUST MIGHT COME AS I THINK THIS
TO BE BETTER HANDLED LOCALLY --
BUT I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN.
THANK YOU RECOVERING MISTER
RESTER -- ANY ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS YEAHYEAH.
HI.
I JUST WANTED -- TO I DON'T KNOW
WHICH ONE IS MY PHONE YEAH I
GUESS IT IS THANK YOU -- I WANT
TO THANK MY CYNICAL COLLEAGUE
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I HAD
NO IDEA THAT THEY DIDN'T HAVE.
TO FILE ANY ANY ELVES SIGNATURES
AND MAINLY BECAUSE IT'S PRETTY
MUCH A STANDARD IN CAL IN SAN
DIEGO THAT I WAS ON THE SCHOOL
BOARD AND YOU KNOW ALL THE OTHER
SCHOOL BOARDS AND WHAT HAVE YOU
THAT.
THE ASSUMPTION IS THAT
EVERYBODY'S COLLECTING
SIGNATURES IN -- TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT THEY HAVE SOME SUPPORT OF
FORD AND SO -- SO I AND YOU KNOW
I THIS IS INTERESTING THAT THEY
DIDN'T SO I HAVE I WOULD
DEFINITELY SUPPORT IT WHY
DOESN'T DO LOCAL STUFF THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION.
OKAY AND I THINK THAT THE
PRESIDENT MAY WOULD HAVE TO GO
TO THE BALLOT I THINK OR THEY
DON'T HAVE TO GO THE BALLOT THEY
COULD DO IT THEMSELVES.
WHAT THE I MEAN THE THESE ARE
ENTITIES OF THE STATE OKAY SO
I'LL HAVE RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT'S WHY WE'RE WE'RE BRINGING
IT FORWARD CRACKED OKAY OKAY
THAT IS?
BUT I I I SUPPORTED I MEAN WE
REALLY NEED -- TO AND OF SAN
DIEGO IS IS INTERESTING IT'S
IT'S A IT'S A BIG CITY THAT JUST
BECAME BIG IN MENTALITY IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS.
YOU KNOW OF IF YOU GO THERE YOU
THINK IT'S REALLY LIKE A LITTLE
HOME TOWN -- IN A LOT OF
PEOPLE'S MINDS AND SO MUCH MANY
OF THE POLICIES AND THINGS HAVE
BEEN THERE HAVE REALLY BEEN VERY
PAROCHIAL IN TERMS OF OF HOW WE
OPERATE IT'S IT IS A DIFFERENT
PLACE AND SELL.
OF THEIR A LOT OF THINGS THAT
ARE HAPPENING NOW IN THE CITY TO
HARMONIZE.
WHAT DO PRACTICES EXIST BETWEEN
VARIOUS AREAS AND AND SO MANY
THERE'S SEVERAL DIFFERENT OF
COMMUNICABLE AS BOARDS IN SAN
DIEGO -- AS WELL AS SCHOOL
BOARDS AND SO -- THERE'S A LOT
OF EFFORTS TO TRY TO STANDARDIZE
THE EXPECTATIONS THAT ARE THERE
BECAUSE PEOPLE LIVE IN ONE AREA
BUT WORK SOMEWHERE ELSE AND SO
THE ASSUMPTION IS.
THAT IT'S PRETTY MUCH ONE BUT IS
IT REALLY IS NOT SO I WOULD
SUPPORT THIS I THINK IT'S IT'S
IT'S MODEST IN TERMS OF THAT
IT'S A LARGE AREA SO BEING ABLE
TO COLLECT HUNDRED SIGNATURES.
YOU CAN DO THAT IN A LESS THAN A
WEEK IN IN FRONT OF A MALL OR
FOR JUST KNOCK ON PEOPLE'S DOORS
AND WE'D HAVE BEEN FAIRLY
LIBERAL ABOUT FOLKS.
ACTUALLY NOT MEETING THE TARGET --
IF THEY GO TO COURT WHICH IS OUT
NOW THE WHOLE WEIRD STORY ITSELF
THAT HAPPENS ALL THE TIME IN SAN
DIEGO -- WHERE YOU ONLY HAVE
NINETY EIGHT SIGNATURES EVEN
THOUGH HE TOOK A HUNDRED AND
FIVE AND SO YOU STILL IN UP ON
THE BALLOT?
BUT NONE THE LESS I I SUPPORT
THIS AND I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FORTH.
THANK YOU DOCTOR OUR MISTER
CALDERON.
THIS GUY THAT THE BILL MAKES
SENSE I GET IT I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE -- I
MEAN I THINK THE HUNDRED IS A
LITTLE BIT HIGH I THINK IF IT'S
GOOD FOR IS GOOD FOR US TO COULD
BE GOOD FOR THEM.
I KNOW IT'S NOT THAT DIFFICULT
BUT STILL KIND OF A PAIN IN THE
**** TO GET THE FORTY SIGNATURES
IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
IT SHOULD BE THERE IT JUST.
YOU KNOW WE CAN BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE REASONABLE ON THE THE
NUMBER OF SIGNATURES THAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR NOT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT REASONS WHY THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT REASONS THAT SOMEBODY
MAY PUT THEIR NAME ON THE BALLOT.
IN ALTHOUGH THERE ARE LAWS
PROTECTING AGAINST THIS IT
DOESN'T STILL PRECLUDE PEOPLE
FROM PUTTING THE NAME ON A
BALLOT BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
UNDER CUT ANOTHER PERSON SO THAT
THEY DON'T WIN AND SO THERE'S A
LOT OF DIFFERENT REASONS.
WHY PEOPLE PUT THEIR NAMES ON
THE BALLOT BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT ANYBODY WHO WANTS
TO RUN FOR OFFICE WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO RUN FOR OFFICE
BUT THEY ALSO HAVE TO HAVE A
STAKE?
AND THERE HAS TO BE AT LEAST
SOME LEVEL OF SUPPORT WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY SO THAT THEY'RE NOT
JUST PUTTING.
THEY'RE NOT JUST PUTTING THE
NAME ON THE BALLOT FOR THE SAKE
OF PUTTING THEM IN NAME ON THE
BALLOT FOR WHATEVER REASONS --
AS OUR MOTIVATING THEM IT'S
THERE THERE'S INVESTMENT THERE
AND OUR PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT THEY'RE TALKING TO AND
THEY'RE ACTUALLY.
DOING THE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE FOR TO RUN A LEGITIMATE
CAMPAIGN TO BE A LEGITIMATE --
PUBLIC OFFICIAL IF IN FACT THEY
DO IT.
THANK YOU.
THE MISTER CALDERON DID ALL THIS
IS MADE JUST ONE LAST THING AND
BUT JUST BE QUICK AND ACTUALLY
DO AGREE WITH -- MISTER CALDERON --
BUT THE IDEA THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE SOME LIMIT YOU GOT TO HAVE
SOME SOME BOMB BAIRD ENTRY IF
YOU WILL NOT EVERYBODY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO HAVE.
OTHER NAME ON ABOUT YOU GOT TO
SHOW THAT THERE SOME SOME OF THE
SUPPORT I I DO WONDER THOUGH
SHOULD THIS BE THE STATE RULE
THAT APPLIES TO ALL OF THE ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ALL CALLS
DISTRICTS -- BUT WHY DO WE LIMIT
DISTRICT FOR FOR THOSE FOR THOSE.
TWO WITH THIS IN LEASES IN SAN
DIEGO AREA THE ONES THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED I MEAN.
STATEWIDE LEGISLATION I GUESS
WOULD BE MAYBE SOMETHING THAT
THIS COMMITTEE COULD CONSIDER --
SUGGESTING.
I WOULD SAY SPEAK FOR YOUR
COMMUNITIES BUT I KNOW THIS IS
THE NATION'S INDIA OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITH THAT MISTER GORE WE LIKE TO
CLOSE OUR THE CHEF OF THE TIME
IT WILL HAPPEN.
DOCTOR WEBER NOW HAVE EXPLAINED
THE COMMITTEE WHY SAN DIEGO'S
CHANGING -- OUR PHYSICAL
PRESENCE HERE IS THE
ILLUSTRATION OF THAT -- AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
A CANDIDATES FOR MANY OFFICES
ARE REQUIRED TO COLLECT
SIGNATURES ON NOMINATION PAPERS
IN ORDER TO QUALIFY TO BE ON THE
BALLOT THAT'S ESPECIALLY TRUE IN
LARGER JURISDICTIONS WHERE THE
POTENTIAL POOL OF CANDIDATES IS
LARGER.
THIS BILL WOULD IMPOSE A MODEST
NOMINATION REQUIREMENT FOR
CANDIDATES IN TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS IN THE NEAR
THE AUTHORS DISTRICT SO I'M
RECOMMENDING SUPPORT.
ON THIS DISTRICT BILL WITH THAT --
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
HI GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CALDERON CALDERON I
LOW.
LOW I'M MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN WEBER.
WEBER I THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
FIVE TO ONE VOTE OKAY THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
COLLEAGUES I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
REMIND EVERYBODY THAT WE HAVE.
EIGHTEEN BILLS.
TODAY -- WE'VE HEARD THREE I'M.
I'M I'M I'M LEAVING FOR MY
WEDDING AT FIVE O'CLOCK.
SO WHETHER THIS HEARING AND A
FIVE OR NOT YES I'M OUT SO WE
GOTTA GET DOWN BY FIVE BECAUSE I
GOT TO BE OUT.
SO NEXT ON THE AGENDA IS ITS OWN
NUMBER MELENDEZ I REMEMBER FOR A
POINT OF ORDER I DIDN'T GET AN
INVITE.
IT'S IN THE MAIL.
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT TO YOU AB.
THREE FIVE NINE AFTER SERVING
THE LEGISLATURE FORMER ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND SENATORS OFTEN
REGISTERED LOBBYISTS TO MAKE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
REPRESENTING CORPORATIONS AND
SPECIAL INTEREST GROUPS.
MANY HAVE RESIGNED FROM OFFICE
IN ORDER TO WORK FOR LARGE
CORPORATE FIRMS.
NEARLY EVERY STATE HAS STRONG
REVOLVING DOOR PROHIBITIONS TO
FOR BED FORMER LEGISLATORS FROM
LOBBYING FOR CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
TIME INDENTURE FORMER OFFICIALS
DON'T INTENTIONALLY OR
UNINTENTIONALLY.
PLACE IMPROPER INFLUENCE ON
STAFFING COLLEAGUES YET
CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE MOST
LENIENT REVOLVING DOOR POLICIES
ONLY WHEN YOU'RE AFTER THEY
SERVE THEY CAN ENTER IT AS A
LOBBYIST.
IT DOES THIS DOES NOT GO NEARLY
FAR ENOUGH TO COMBAT POLITICAL
CORRUPTION WITH A TEAR
LEGISLATIVE CYCLE FORMER
LEGISLATORS CAN HEAVILY
INFLUENCE POLICY NEGOTIATIONS
THAT THEY TOOK PART OF JUST A
YEAR PRIOR AS A LEGISLATOR.
EXCEPT THIS TIME THEY CAN
INFLUENCE NEGOTIATIONS WITH
FISCAL PROMISES AND TIME AND
TIME AGAIN CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATORS HAVE CONTINUED TO
RESIGN TO TAKE HIGHER PAYING
LOBBYING JOBS -- AB THREE FIFTY
NINE WILL EXTEND THE PROHIBITION
ON FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
SENATORS LOBBYING THE
LEGISLATURE TO FIVE YEARS ALONG
A COOLING OFF PERIOD BETWEEN
LEGISLATORS TIME IN OFFICE IN
THEIR ABILITY TO INFLUENCE
CURRENT POLICY NEGOTIATIONS.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
CONSUMER WATCHDOG CALIFORNIA
LANDS A RETIRED AMERICANS IN THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS -- I DOOR
REYES IS HERE FROM THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS TO TESTIFY I WOULD
LIKE TO ADD THOUGH THAT I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE LENGTH OF TIME -- AND
TO MY KNOWLEDGE NO ONE'S OFFICE
HAS COMMUNICATED THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
LOWERED THOUGH I'M OPEN TO THAT
SO PERHAPS IT COULD BE PART OF
THE DISCUSSION TODAY WITH THAT
MISTER REISS FAMILY WOMEN BETTER
SCRIPT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OF THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY ON
BEHALF AND IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE FIFTY NINE OF ALL OF THE
FEATURES IN THE MODERN POLITICAL
SYSTEM PERHAPS NONE THAT FUELS
PUBLIC CYNICISM.
AS MUCH AS THE REVOLVING DOOR
BETWEEN PUBLIC SERVICE AND PAID
LOBBYING.
IN PARTICULAR ADVOCACY.
ON BEHALF OF WELL FUNDED
CORPORATE INTERESTS.
T. LOBBYIST DRAWN FROM THE RANKS
OF FORMER LEGISLATORS ARE ABLE
TO TRADE ON THEIR RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THOSE FORMER LEGISLATORS
WITH THEIR PAST COLLEAGUES. TO
USE EXPERTISE THAT'S BEEN
ACQUIRED WHEN THEY WERE IN THESE
HALLS DOING THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS.
THEY BRING INSIDER SAVVY RIGHT
THEY THEY KNOW WHO THE
LEGISLATORS THEY KNOW HOW TO
PITCH MESSAGING THEY UNDERSTAND
THE INTRICACIES OF CAUCUS
DYNAMICS.
THEY ENJOY ACCESS IT'S HAD BY
VERY FEW OF US THEY CAN GET
BUSINESS DONE OVER TAX THEY CAN
GET BUSINESS DONE OVER TO A
STEAK DINNERS WE'VE ALL SEEN.
RECENTLY OR THAT COUPLE YEARS
AGO THERE WAS A ASSEMBLY BILL.
THAT WAS INTRODUCED TO REDUCE
AIR POLLUTION AND AIR POLLUTION
REDUCTION BILL.
FULL DISCLOSURE THIS WAS A BILL
THAT WAS SUPPORTED BY THE LEAGUE
AT THE TIME [inaudible]
SO.
IT WENT DOWN IN A REALLY TIGHT
VOTE.
AND IT WENT DOWN AFTER BIG OIL
HIRED FORMER LEGISLATORS.
OF A WELL LIKED FOR LEGISLATORS
INFLUENTIAL ONES TO LOBBY THEIR
COLLEAGUES.
ON ON OILS BEHALF.
WHILE RECENT LEGISLATION HAS
TIGHTENED READ THE STAFF
ANALYSIS THE RULES FOR OF
LEGISLATORS WHO RESIGNED MID
TERM THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
DOES NOT BELIEVE THAT THAT IS
SUFFICIENT [inaudible]
IT.
IN FACT WE THINK THERE ARE LACKS
RESTRICTIONS ACTUALLY LEGITIMIZE
THE BETRAYAL OF THE PUBLIC TRUST
BY FORMER LEGISLATORS.
AS THE WORK AGAINST THE
INTERESTS OF THOSE VERY
CONSTITUENTS WHO PUT THEM INTO
OFFICE.
ORDINARY VOTERS SHOULD NEVER BE
SECOND PLACE THEY SHOULD NEVER
BE SECOND PLACE TO MONEYED
INTEREST TO PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS THEY SHOULD NEVER
BE SECOND PLACE. TO TO THE LOWER
OF THE PRIVATE SECTOR. TO THE
EXTENT THAT AB THREE FIFTY NINE
TO TURN SOME CANDIDATES
[inaudible]
SPEEDED UP.
ELECTED OFFICE THAT'S A FEATURE
NOT A BUG THE LAW IS GOING TO
HAVE A SALUTARY EFFECT ON
FILTERING OUT CANDIDATES WHO ARE
PURSUING ELECTIVE OFFICE FOR THE
WRONG REASONS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN FLORIDA
VOTERS APPROVE THE MOST
STRINGENT COOLING OFF ON THE
NATION MANDATING A SIX YEAR
PERIOD.
BEFORE FOR LEGISLATORS CAN TAKE
ON PAY LOBBYING CALIFORNIA HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY HERE. TO
REINFORCE ITS REPUTATION AS THE
LEADER IN CLEAN GOVERNMENT.
THIS LEGISLATION REPRESENTS A
REALLY BOLD STATEMENT IN SUPPORT
OF ACCOUNTABLE RESPONSIVE
POLITICS THAT LEVELS THE PLAYING
FIELD FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
VOTERS SO WE DO REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL AB THREE
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
DO YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE.
I'M.
SORT OF SUPPORT -- DISCOVER
COULD MONEY CAMPAIGN -- THREE
VERY WELL.
IF AMENDED -- WEEK WE CAN'T TAKE
A POSITION ON THE CURRENT FIVE
YEAR BAN BUT WE DEFINITELY THINK
A TWO YEAR RESTRICTION WOULD BE
VERY VERY APPROPRIATE FOR ALL
THE REASONS THAT THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS.
A SAID IN THE AUTHOR SAID WE
THINK OFF THE FOR BRING THIS
FORWARD AND AND WE WOULD
DEFINITELY -- G. TO SUPPORT IT
STRONGLY IF YOU.
IF IT IS OMITTED THAT WAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
CALL AT THE TWEETER SECTION ANY
OTHER TWEENER.
THERE IN THE AUDIENCE YEAH
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SING NUMBERING ABOUT A COLLEGE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
BRING BACK TO THE AUTHOR FOR
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WITHOUT A LONGER COOLING OFF
PERIOD CORPORATIONS AND SPECIAL
INTEREST GROUPS WILL HAVE JUST
AS STRONG A VOICE AS THOSE WHO
HONESTLY IN INTENTIONALLY
BROUGHT US HERE ARE CONSTITUENTS.
THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA CHOSE US
TO REPRESENT THEM AND WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER WHETHER WHEN YOU'RE
PROHIBITION IS REALLY NOT TO
KEEP BUT TO KEEP ABUSE AND
MANIPULATION FROM TAKING PLACE.
IN OUR SYSTEM -- MEMBERS PLEASE
I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THIS MORNING I KNOW THERE MAY BE
SOME HESITATION BUT I THINK I
SUSPECT THAT EVERYBODY FEELS THE
SAME AS I DO IS THAT WE NEED.
TO BRING THIS UNDER CONTROL OF
IT THINKING I SWEAR I ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR WEBER.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF THIS
IS REALLY A PROBLEM -- I REALLY
AM BECAUSE I DON'T SEE A WHOLE
LOT OF MEMBERS WALKING THE HALLS
HERE.
ARE GIVEN THE TERM LIMITS IN
TERMS OF A LOT OF LOBBYIST I
JUST DON'T SEE IT YOU KNOW I SEE
THEM LEAVING TO RUN FOR THE
OFFICES.
BUT I CAN PROBABLY THINK OF ONE
PERSON WHO IT AND WE DO ADDRESS
THAT THE PERSON WHO LEFT IN THE
MIDDLE OF A TERM.
OUT WE'VE GOT SOME FOLKS WHO
RETIRED WHO LEFT BECAUSE OF ALL
THE OTHER STUFF THAT HAPPENED
WANTED TO SO I'M JUST TRYING TO
YOU KNOW I'M I'M I I I
UNDERSTAND THE FIVE YEARS I MAY
THINK IT'S KIND OF EXCESSIVE IN
TERMS A CERTAIN EXTENT.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW
MAYBE BECAUSE AT THAT I HAVE NO
DESIRE TO BE A LOBBYIST EVER AND
I DON'T KNOW -- AND SO MAYBE
THIS IS NOT AN ATTRACTION.
NO FANS NO BUT I MEAN IS GIVEN
WHERE I AM IN MY LIFE YOU KNOW I
DON'T WANT TO BE IN ON IN A
WHEELCHAIR AS A LOBBYIST BUT
NONE THE LESS AND I'M SURE
THERE'S SOME OR OR ON CRUTCHES
OR WHATEVER BUT A WALKER BUT ALL
OF IT.
HUH BUT I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT IF THERE'S IF THERE'S
A PROBLEM YOU KNOW I MEAN.
I SEE CREATING A RULE BUT I
DON'T NECESSARILY SEE THAT
HAPPENING HERE SO THAT'S THAT'S
MY CONCERN THAT I JUST DON'T SEE.
OF FOLKS LEAVING IMMEDIATE
COMING BACK AS LOBBYIST I MEAN
I'VE SEEN SOME WILL WORK WITH.
AGENCIES NOT AS LOBBYISTS BUT
JUST AS CONSULTANTS OR WHATEVER
SO I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE THE PROBLEM IS THAT THAT'S
MY NUMBER ONE CONCERN I DON'T.
KNOW I I DON'T WANT TO JUST
START CHANGING NUMBERS FOR THE
SAKE OF CHANGING NUMBERS AND WE
GO TO FIVE AND THEN DISCOVER.
THAT'S REALLY DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE WHO -- BECAUSE YOU GET
INTO THIS PUT THESE JOBS IN
THERE THERE'S NOT A WHOLE LOT OF
JOB SECURITY INVOLVED IN IT.
YOU GOT TWELVE YEARS TWELVE
YEARS OF YOUR EARNING A LIFE
EARNING WITHOUT PENSION WITHOUT
BENEFITS WITHOUT ALL THAT STUFF
THAT COMES IN SO YOU KNOW ALL
THAT WEIGHS ON ME THAT I I
RECOGNIZE THE FOLKS HERE MAKING.
QUITE A SACRIFICE TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT TO BE HERE ESPECIALLY
THOSE WERE YOUNGER AND THIS IS
THERE YOU KNOW WHAT TIME AND
WHICH THEY SHOULD BE TRYING TO
DEVELOP A PENSION OR SOMETHING.
AND THEY'RE NOT BECAUSE IT DOING
THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS FOR TEN
TWELVE YEARS AND OLDER ROUNDER
HUH THANKS FOR THE REMINDER YEAH
IT.
IS TIME YOU KNOW I'M I'M
EMPATHETIC TO WHAT DO TO THAT
GENERATION SO.
I YEAH I I JUST THE END IS NOT
THAT I'M OPPOSED TO IT I JUST
NEED A BETTER ARGUMENT THAT THAT
THIS IS HAPPENING BECAUSE I
DON'T REALLY.
SEE IT A LOT NUMBER ONE AND
NUMBER.
TWO FOLKS ARE INFLUENCED BY
VARIOUS PEOPLE UP HERE I DON'T I
HOPE THAT PEOPLE AREN'T SO
OVERLY INFLUENCES SIMPLY BECAUSE
I KNEW YOU AT ONE POINT IN YOUR
LIFE.
THAT YOU MAY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK TO ME BUT THAT DOESN'T
MEAN I WILL VOTE FOR THE
CRAZINESS THAT YOU MIGHT BE.
PROMOTING AT THE TIME SO.
AT TELL ME THERE'S A PROBLEM I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE PROBLEM IS WHEN I LOOK AT
THE NUMBERS EVEN THE RATIONALE A
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS AND I TRY
NOT TO BASE DID SOMETHING YOU
KNOW BECAUSE THEN THAT AFFECTS.
A WHOLE LOT OF FOLKS WHO NOT
DOING THAT SO.
I DON'T KNOW I'VE MAYBE I'M I'M
NOT AWARE OF IT BUT I'D LIKE TO
KNOW THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM.
BEFORE I'D GO TO ONE FOR ONE TO
FIVE YOU KNOW I I'D LIKE TO KNOW
THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM.
WELL FIRST.
I'M AS A MATTER PRINCIPLE THE
LEAGUE'S POSITION IS THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE'S NOT A TRAINING
GROUND FOR A LUCRATIVE CAREER
AND THAT'S NOT THE WAY WE WANT
OUR REPRESENTATIVES TO BE
THINKING ABOUT IT THEY REPRESENT
THE INTERESTS OF THE VOTERS.
THEN THAT DO NOT.
REPRESENT THE INTEREST.
OF OR THEY SHOULD NOT REPRESENT
THE INTERESTS OF CORPORATIONS
WHICH IS WHAT THIS KIND OF CHURN
THIS REVOLVING DOOR.
OF RESULTS IN.
I DID COME WITH THE ONE EXAMPLE
OF AND IT WAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA IS BILL COUPLE
YEARS AGO MANY OF YOU VOTED IN
FAVOR OF IT.
OUT TO REDUCE POLLUTION AND THAT
NARROW.
DEFEAT THAT I WAS TALKING ABOUT
WAS VERY CLEARLY THE DIRECT
RESULT OF THE LOBBYING BY FOUR
FORMER LEGISLATORS.
WHO WERE HIRED SPECIFICALLY BY?
OIL COMPANIES AND BLOOM PRESS
ONE OTHER INDUSTRY. TO DEFEAT
THE BILL AND THEY WILL IT WORKED
THEY DID YOUR HONOR THIS REALLY
NARROW.
WAY.
ON THE FLOOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA WAS.
IN.
TWO BECAUSE SHE COULD NOT
BELIEVE THAT A BILL THAT WAS
PITCH TO HELP HER CONSTITUENTS.
AND AND HELP THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA COULD REALLY P.
DEFEATED BY THE KINDS OF MAC IN
NATIONS THAT GO ON WHEN THE
FORMER LEGISLATORS BODY UP.
WITH THE CURRENT LEGISLATORS AND
AND TURN THE TIDE.
IT WAS A SURPRISE AND WE SEE
THOSE KINDS OF SURPRISES IN
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES AS WELL.
WELL YEAH I MEAN.
YEAH THAT'S ONE INSTANCE.
WE SEATED OTHER INSTANCE
INSTANCES BUT IN GENERAL IT IS
SIMPLY THE WRONG DYNAMIC.
IN THE TIME THAT I'VE BEEN HERE
YOU AND I HAVE BEEN HERE AND
THERE ARE THREE THAT I KNOW OF
JUST OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD WHO
WERE IN THE LEGISLATURE ONE IN
THE SENATE. TO THE ASSEMBLY WHO
LEFT -- IN MILITARY TERMS ONE
LEFT FOR HEALTH REASONS THE
OTHER TWO RESIGNED AND THEN THEY
WENT ON TO BE LOBBYIST.
I UNDERSTAND.
THAT I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT I'M
I'M I'M TRYING.
TO YEAH I GUESS AND OKAY SO
WE'VE HAD THREE AND SIX IT'S
ALMOST SEVEN YEARS NOW -- SO I'M
TRYING TO I'M JUST I STILL AM
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE THIS
BIG PROBLEM IS AND AND AND AND I
I UNDERSTAND THE THE THE PASSION
AND THE EMOTIONS OF THOSE WHO.
OF US WHO DO BILLS THAT WE
REALLY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT AND
ALL OF US FIGHT THE MONSTERS
THAT ARE IN THE OTHER PLACE AND
WE DON'T CALM THE THIRD HOUSE.
WHAT BUT OUT THERE WHO WHO CAN
LOBBY AND WHO CAN?
GET PEOPLE TO DO THINGS MAYBE
BECAUSE OF WHATEVER REASONS I
HAVE NO IDEA THAT THEY CAN DO
BUT BUT I'M JUST.
YEAH I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE THE PROBLEM IS IN THIS
SEEMS LIKE SOMETHING IN SEARCH
OF A PROBLEM IN AN ADULT.
YOU KNOW AND I MAYBE BECAUSE I'M
NOT THAT INFLUENCED BY LOBBYIST.
YOU KNOW I HEAR PEOPLE NOT
TAKING EVERYBODY'S INFORMATION
BUT I'M NOT I JUST DON'T I DON'T
SEE THIS -- THIS HAPPENING ON A
REGULAR BASIS AND I'M NOT SURE
IF.
IN ANY OTHER AND AND AND
POLITICS IS IS IS ONE ARENA BUT
YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT.
OF FOLKS GET AN EXPERTISE IN
SOMETHING LIKE POLITICS OR LIKE
LOBBYING ALIKE Là BIT BILL
MAKING A BILL WRITING WHATEVER.
OUT AND THEREFORE THEY SHOULD
NEVER USE THAT SKILL AGAIN -- AS
AS WAS SAYING A BEING TRYING TO
DO SOMETHING THE WEATHER HERE.
IN AND YET WE HAVEN'T REALLY
ATTACK THE REAL ISSUE WHICH IS
OF UNFORTUNATELY TERM LIMITS AND
ALL THOSE OTHER THINGS THAT THE
KEY PEOPLE FROM ACTUALLY.
DEVELOPING -- HERE AS REAL GOOD
LEGISLATORS.
AND AND BASICALLY OF A MASKING
THE KIND OF KNOWLEDGE AND SKILL
TO SO ESSENTIAL TO BE AN
EFFECTIVE LEGISLATOR TAKES
SEVERAL YEARS TO DO THAT -- SO I
YOU KNOW I DON'T I DON'T KNOW I
I I JUST.
OF I WOULD LOVE TO SUPPORT
SOMETHING BUT I'M NOT SURE GOING
TO FIVE YEARS IS REALLY THE THE
RIGHT THING TO DO IT MAYBE TWO
YEARS MAY BE A GOOD TIME FRAME
OR I'M NOT SURE BUT IT JUST
SEEMS TO BE.
A SOMEWHAT EXCESSIVE TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT GIVEN THE FACT
THAT AND THAT I DON'T HAVE
EVIDENCE OF THIS IS A HUGE
PROBLEM THANK AND UP AND I GUESS
IT AND I'VE LOST BILLS AND%
OTHERS OF LOS BILLS THAT WERE
VERY PERSONAL.
VERY EMOTIONAL FOR US COLLEAGUE
GOT THEIR NOSE WE'VE GONE
THROUGH SOME TEARS WITH SOME
BILLS -- AND YOU KNOW AND HAVE
BEEN DEFEATED BY WHO KNOWS WHAT
MAYBE MONEY THAT'S PEOPLE GIVING
FOLKS FOR CAMPAIGNS ALL KINDS OF
THINGS.
BUT THAT'S THE REALITY OF THIS
PLACE I WOULD LIKE TO TO BE PURE
AND WHAT HAVE YOU BUT I'VE COME
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER FORCES THAT AYE CONFLICT
FIGHT AGAINST.
WHEN I'VE GOT DIFFICULT BILLS ON
THE FLOOR THAT A MORE THAN A
COMMA AND SEMICOLON?
AND AND SO.
I DON'T KNOW ANYWAY IT'S JUST
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO ENVISION
FIVE YEARS WITHOUT A REAL
PROBLEM AND AND I'M YOU KNOW AND
I THINK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
INDICATED THAT SHE IS WILLING TO
TAKE AMENDMENTS TO REDUCE AT
FIVE YOU RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
MISTER MAYES NOW.
THANK YOU SO OBVIOUSLY OF
DEMOING TO SPEAK UP BUT DOCTOR
WEBER INSPIRED ME TOO I KNOW
WE'RE TRYING TO MOVE BILLS AND
WE'VE GOT A WEDDING THAT'S A
GOOD IDEA SO I SAW I'LL BE I'LL
BE I'LL BE QUICK.
YOU KNOW THAT THE I'M NOT GONNA
SUPPORT THIS TODAY -- AN ACTUAL
TELL YOU -- WHAT'S GOING ON IN
MY HEAD -- AND HAVE HAS GONE ON
IN MY HEAD -- A BEING SOMEBODY
WHO STUDY POLITICAL SCIENCE TO
OF THE DECIDED WHEN HE WAS
TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD TO RUN FOR
POLITICAL OFFICE THINKING.
OF THAT AT SOME POINT IN TIME --
I WANTED IT TO CONTINUE TO RUN.
THERE ARE LOTS OF DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT MOVE US AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS ONE THING I'VE LEARNED
SINCE I'VE I'VE BEEN HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
IS THAT THE EIGHTEEN MET THE
SEVEN NINE COLLEAGUES I HAVE IN
THE ASSEMBLY THE OTHER FORTY AND
THE SENATE ARE GOOD PEOPLE WE
HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION.
I DON'T KNOW OF ANYBODY THAT GOT
THAT RAN FOR OFFICE -- GOT
ELECTED -- TO TRY TO MAKE A
LIVING OUT OF OUT OF OUT OF
SACRAMENTO -- BUT THE TRUTH IS
THE TRUTH IS FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME
WHO STUDIED POLITICAL SCIENCE
AND WHO HAVE BEEN IN OF THE
ELECTED OFFICE FOR SOME TIME I
KNOW PUBLIC POLICY REALLY WELL
IN FACT.
I DON'T KNOW MUCH MORE OTHER
THAN PUBLIC POLICY I GUESS I
COULD GO BACK AND BE A FINANCIAL
ADVISER I'M AT SOME POINT TIME
BUT I THINK THE CURRENT RULES
THAT WE HAVE THE HAVING THAT
COOLING OFF PERIOD.
OF ONE YEAR AFTER MAKES A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF SENSE AND I
WOULD SUPPORT THAT THAT I THINK
FIVE YEARS IS IS TOO LONG JUST
TO MOVE A BILL TO COME UP WITH
SOME OTHER.
TIME FRAME I'M NOT SURE IS IS
IMPORTANT HERE IS THE OTHER
TRUTH I COULDN'T -- AFTER I WAS
OUT OF THE THE THE THE THE OUT
OF OFFICE I HAVE TO GET A JOB
SEVEN OF MONEY BY NOT MONEY MY
BANK ACCOUNT A TO BE ABLE. TO TO
SURVIVE FOR A YEAR AND SO MOST
OF US -- ARE GOING TO GO DO THAT
WHEN WE'RE WHEN WE'RE DONE HERE --
I WOULD SAY AND I THINK THE BOB
MAYES BILL OF THAT RANT WAS RAN
BEFORE WAITING TILL AFTER -- OUR
TERM OF OFFICE IS OUT FOR THAT
YEAR TO START AT THE THAT MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE BUT I THINK --
ANYTHING AFTER THAT IS -- IS
JUST IS JUST TOO MUCH I THINK
THAT THE CURRENT RULES ARE ARE
FORGET IN.
WESTERN GALLAGHER IS VERY VERY
BRIEFLY I'LL I WOULD HOPE WE
COULD SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY I
THINK'S ARE I THINK WE ALL KNOW
THAT -- YOU KNOW.
AT WE ALL LIKE EACH OTHER A LOT
WE HAVE GREAT RELATIONSHIPS EACH
OTHER BUT WE YOU KNOW IF IF THE
ISSUE IS ONE THAT WE DISAGREE
WITH.
AND I DON'T CARE HOW MUCH I LIKE
YOU AND YOU KNOW I'M STILL GO
VOTE NO.
AND AND AND I DO AND I DO.
I VISIT FIRSTLY DISAGREE WITH
THE WITH THE CONTENTION MADE
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED WITH THAT
BILL.
LAST YEAR WAS A LOT OF DIFFERENT
REASONS IT WAS GOING INTO THAT
DEBATE AND PEOPLE HAD VERY
DIFFERENT REASONS FOR WHY THEY
VOTED YES OR NO AND HAD.
YEAH HENRY PRAYERS REALLY GOOD
GUY BUT WE DON'T LIKE HIM THAT
MUCH.
I MEAN SO -- I MEAN.
IS LIKE BUT I MEAN THAT'S WHAT
PEOPLE ARE BRING ENOUGH BUT I
JUST I I DON'T I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT IS TRUE AT ALL THAT
THAT'S WHY THAT BILL DIED OR ANY
OF THOSE THINGS -- AND SO BUT I
I DO THINK THAT THERE'S A
THERE'S A LEGITIMATE.
YOU KNOW ONE YEAR TURNAROUND YOU
RESIGN AND WHEN YOUR TURN AROUND
I MEAN.
THERE'S SOMETHING THERE THAT
MAYBE IT DOES NEED TO BE
EXTENDED SO IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WANTED TO WORK
ON THAT AND FIND WHAT IS THAT
RIGHT TIMELINE I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN ALL SUPPORT --
BECAUSE THE PUBLIC PERCEPTION IS
IMPORTANT -- AND ENSURING THAT
THERE IS SOME SEPARATION BEFORE
SOMEONE'S BACK LOBBY IN THIS
AGAIN SO.
THE YOU MISTER CALDERON.
Q. I APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
OF REACH OUT TO YOUR OFFICE
ALREADY HAD TO LET YOU KNOW MY
POSITION ON THIS BILL -- I THINK
A COUPLE THINGS NEED TO BE
CLARIFIED IT IS IN ONE YEAR
AFTER YOU RESIGNED.
THE CURRENT LAW AND I DON'T
THINK THAT BASED ON THE THE LAW
THAT HAS BEEN PASSAGE.
THERE REALLY ISN'T A LOT OF
INFORMATION OUT THERE BUT IT'S
SAY I TERM OUT WILL OKAY IT'S A
YEAR AFTER I TURNED OUT THAT I
CAN GO AND LOBBY IF THAT'S WHAT
I WANT TO DO BUT IF I RESIGNED
EARLY SAY I RESIGNED TODAY.
IS IN IN NEXT APRIL THAT I CAN
BECOME A LOBBYIST NO IT'S
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THAT I WOULD BE ABLE TO BECOME A
LOBBYIST BECAUSE IT STARTS AFTER
THE TERM THAT I RESIGNED FROM
ENDS.
ARE ALSO THE INDIVIDUAL THAT WAS
NAMED ALONG WITH THE OTHER
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S BEEN TALKED
ABOUT -- FROM THE OIL INDUSTRY
THEY'RE NOT LOBBYIST AND THEY
NEVER HAVE BEEN LOBBYIST.
OUR AND THEIR NOT LOBBYING THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
REGISTERED LOBBYISTS ARE SO IT'S
AN IMPORTANT DISTINCTION TO MAKE
AS WELL AS THAT.
YES IN INDIVIDUAL MAY HAVE
RESIGNED BUT THEY DID RESIGNED
TO BECOME A LOBBYIST OR
LOBBYIST'S NOW YOUR LATER
THEY'RE NOT LOBBYIST.
AND THEY DO NOT LOBBY -- AND I
AND I JUST.
I I APPRECIATE AND RESPECT BILLS.
THAT ARE MEANT TO KIND OF BEAT
UP ON OURSELVES A LITTLE BIT IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW OUR
MOTIVATIONS AND WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO WHAT WE USE THESE POSITIONS
FOR AFTERWARDS BECAUSE I GET I
GET THE CYNICISM OF GOVERNMENT.
AND THE AND PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
GOVERNMENT WHAT THEIR
MOTIVATIONS ARE BUT I JUST
WHOLEHEARTEDLY REJECT THIS IDEA
THAT ANYTHING I DO RIGHT NOW IS
PREDICATED UPON WHAT MY LIFE IS
GOING TO BE.
AFTER OR WHAT I'M DOING NOW WAS
MOTIVATED BY WHAT MY LIFE WILL
BE LIKE LATER TON OF PEOPLE
CONTRIBUTE TO ALL OF OUR
CAMPAIGNS.
I DON'T AND I BOUGHT EVERY
SINGLE DAY AGAINST PEOPLE THAT
HAVE CONTRIBUTED MIKE TO MY
CAMPAIGN THAT IS NOT WOULD
DECIDE WHAT I DO WANT TO BILL
AND WHAT I DO AFTER THIS HAS NO
BEARING WHATSOEVER.
ON ON YOU KNOW THE RELATIONSHIPS
OR ANYTHING THAT I BUILT RIGHT
NOW HASEVERYTHING TO DO WITH
THIS JOB -- AND SO WHILE I
APPRECIATE THESE TYPES OF
MEASURES I JUST THINK IT'S IT'S
KIND OF AN EASY THING TO DO.
IT GETS A LOT OF PRESS THE LET
THE PRESS LED TO TALK ABOUT
BILLS THAT WE AUTHOR WE PASSED
WE BEAT UP ON EACH OTHER.
I I THINK THE CURRENT THE
CURRENT LAWS ARE ARE ARE
SUFFICIENT.
AND WE ALSO HAVEN'T HAD ENOUGH
TIME WITH THE CURRENT LAW TO
MAKE ANY TYPE DETERMINATION
WHETHER THAT THAT IS AN
INSUFFICIENT OR NOT SO BECAUSE
THAT RIGHT -- REASON I WON'T BE
SUPPORT OF THE DAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WITH THAT --
WE DON'T HAVE A MOTION OR A
SECOND SO ALSO MOVED SO WE HAVE
A MOTION WELL -- MR BERMAN SINCE
OUR CHAIRMAN BERMAN EXCUSE ME
SENSE -- THIS IS BEEN A LITTLE
UNORTHODOX I'M USED TO CLOSING
AND THEN GOING TO ABOUT NOT
CLOSING AND THEN EVERYONE
GETTING NOT RETUNING NEED TO
COMMENT.
SO IF YOU DON'T MIND IF I COULD
JUST ADD A FEW -- I APPRECIATE --
EVERYONE'S OPINION THAT THEY'VE
EXPECT THAT -- COMMUNICATED THIS
MORNING I MUST SAY I'M A LITTLE
TAKEN BY SURPRISE BECAUSE WE
REACHED OUT TO EVERYONE'S OFFICE
AND NO ONE COMMUNITY ANY OF THE
COMMUNICATED ANY OF THESE
CONCERNS.
I'M A TO THIS POINT IN FACT A
TIME LIMIT MAJOR OFFICE SAID
THAT YOU WERE SUPPORTING THE
BILL SIZE VERY SURPRISED THIS
MORNING TO HEAR.
ON THAT HE WAS NOT SO -- IF IF
THERE IS INTEREST IN LOWERING.
THE THRESHOLD TWO THREE YEARS OR
TWO YEARS AS I'VE STATED BEFORE
HIM I AM INTERESTED IN HAVING
THAT COMMUTE THAT CONVERSATION
NO ONE HAS ENGAGE IN THAT
CONVERSATION.
IF THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE WANT TODAY
IN ORDER TO MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD WE CAN AMEND THE BILL IN
THE NEXT COMMITTEE TO WHATEVER'S
AGREED UPON THIS MORNING BUT I
THINK.
IT SOUNDS LIKE WE ALL AGREE THAT
WE DON'T WANT UNDUE INFLUENCE
WERE PERHAPS A LITTLE BIT IN
DISAGREEMENT A NUMBER OF YEARS
SO I GUESS THAT'S MY QUESTION TO
THE COMMITTEES IF.
YOU'RE COMMITTED TO THIS IDEA
ABOUT WANT TO SEE THE NUMBER
CHANGED THEN HOW ABOUT WE AGREE
UPON THAT NUMBER TODAY MOVE THE
BILL FORWARD AN AMENDED IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IT LOOKS LIKE MR LOAD OF A
COMMONER.
YEAH YEAH IF I MIGHT MISTER HERE
MY RIGHT NOW YOU'LL GET A CHANCE
THERE.
FOR AND THEN THAT'LL BE IT.
I THINK IT I THINK I THAT
EVERYONE GETS A CHANCE TO TALK I
I I I APPRECIATED THE THE
KNOWLEDGE IN IN TRYING.
TO ADDRESS IN IT ACCOMMODATE THE
UNDUE INFLUENCE BUT I CAN I I
ALSO SIMILARLY TAKE RESERVATION
TO THE NOTION.
THAT.
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO ADVOCATE AND
LOBBY IS INHERENTLY BAD OR EVIL
WITH A. B. FOR CYSTIC FIBROSIS
OR CANCER SOCIETY THAT
REPRESENTED FROM LEGAL AND
VOTERS U. S. A. YOU MADE THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT CORPORATIONS.
ABOUT THIS IS DEMOCRACY IN
ACTION AND WHAT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE HAVE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE THING
THAT INDIVIDUAL THAT WE CARE
ABOUT OR THOSE THAT ELECTED HIM
BRING US HERE.
AND WHICH WE GO BACK TO SEE THEM
EVERY WEEKEND THERE ARE ALSO A
NUMBER OF MEMBERS WHO FLY UP AND
OF POSTED ABOUT THIS THAT LEAVE
THEIR HOMES AT FOUR AM IN THE
MORNING TO FLY UP HERE.
ON THIS IS ABOUT DEDICATION OF
WORK AND SO I THINK EVEN WHEN
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
REQUIREMENTS AND THRESHOLD OF
THAT OF A REGISTERED LOBBYIST.
OF THAT OF ONE THIRD OF THAT
WORK TO AN INDIVIDUAL A FORMER
LEGISLATOR COULD STILL FUNCTION
IN THIS CAPACITY SHOULD THEY NOT
ADVOCATE OF FOR MORE THAN A
THIRD OF THEIR TIME.
SO I THINK WHEN WE TALKING ABOUT
AS THE AUTHOR STATES IN A
STATEMENT ABOUT THAT OF THE ON
INTO INFLUENCE PERHAPS THEN WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE TYPE OF
COMPENSATION THAT WE REQUIRED SO
WE CAN.
PREVENT AS MUCH OF THE ONION TO
INFLUENCE OR THE NOTION THAT IT
AN INDIVIDUAL A LEGISLATIVE WE
TRY TO SEEK HIGHER COMPENSATION
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR PERHAPS WE
SHOULD COMPENSATE THEM WELL SO
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT.
AND LEAVE THEIR FAMILIES AND NOT
BE THE BREAD WINNER AT HOME SO I
THINK THAT'S THE NOTION THAT
WHICH WE WERE BUT TIME AND TAKE
A LOOK AT AND AGAIN IT'S THE TO
THE AUTHOR WHEN YOU SAID IT'S
ABOUT THE TO THE TIME FRAME OF
THE YEARS.
MY FIRM FOR ME THIS IS NOT ABOUT
THE NOTION OF JUST A BLANKET BAN
I THINK WE'RE IF WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE AT
HAND.
IT IS TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW WE CAN PROTECT THE THE
PUBLIC INTEREST IN TERMS OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THANK YOU AND IT'S ARM ALIGNED
AS YOU LIKE TO RESPOND OR ELSE.
WELL I'LL JUST RESPOND BRIEFLY
IN SAYING THAT I DON'T THINK
ANYONE SITTING AT THIS TABLE
SUGGESTED THAT THOSE WHO GO INTO
LOBBYING ARE ARE ARE EVIL --
THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT IT'S IT'S
I'M A PURPOSE.
FOR IT'S A PROFESSION THAT MANY
CHOOSE AND I'M NOT TRYING TO
PREVENT ANYONE FROM GOING INTO
THAT LINE OF WORK I JUST THINK
THAT THE TIME FRAME OF THE
COOLING OFF PERIOD -- IS
APPROPRIATE I THINK EVERYONE
OBVIOUSLY HAS A RIGHT TO GO MAKE
A LIVING FOR THEIR FAMILY IN
WHATEVER WAY THEY CHOOSE.
BUT I DO THINK IT'S A PERFECT
HAVE SOME SORT OF BUFFER IN
BETWEEN THE TIME THEY WERE
LEGISLATOR IN THE TIME THAT THEY
ARE ABLE.
TO INFLUENCE THE PEOPLE LIKE US --
HONOR BOTH WHETHER IT'S FOR THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY OR IT'S
FOR YOU KNOW A BIG OIL COMPANY --
BUT WITH THAT I WILL EXTEND MY
QUESTION AGAIN WHICH IS IT IS IT
IN THE INTEREST OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
TO MOVE THE BILL FORWARD WITH
THE PROMISE THAT WE WILL LOWER
THE THRESHOLD TO TWO YEARS OR
THREE YEARS OR WHATEVER -- SEEMS
TO BE THE CONSENSUS ON THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT
I HEARD A LOT OF WAS THE THANK
YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION -- IT'S
SO WITH RIGHT NOW THE BILL HAS A
MOTION IT DOES NOT HAVE A SECOND
WILL KEEP THE ITEM OPEN UNTIL
THE END OF THE HEARING. FOR A
SECOND -- IF SOMEBODY CHOOSES TO
TO MAKE THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN --
I WOULD MOVE THE BILL AS AMENDED.
TO MAKE IT A TWO YEAR.
LIMITATION OF MAKE THAT MOTION
GOTCHA THERE'S A MOTION.
WE'LL KEEP THAT MOTION OPEN WILL
GIVE ALL THE MOTIONS OF IN FRONT
OF OUR PROCEDURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WHEN YOU'RE [inaudible]
YEAH.
YEAH YEAH.
OKAY SO I I'VE BEEN.
THE COLLEGE REGULATE YOUR
ATTENTION COLLEAGUES IF I COULD
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION SO IT I I'VE
BEEN TOLD THAT WE CAN'T MOVE ON
THE NEW BUSINESS WITH AN OPEN
MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
THAT MODE SO THAT MOTION FAILS
FOR LACK OF A SECOND BUT THE
ITEM IS STILL OPEN IF FOLKS WANT
TO MAKE.
ADDITIONAL MOTIONS -- BEFORE THE
END OF THE HEARING.
YEAH SO MOVING ON IT TOO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ IS --
ITEMS NUMBER NINE AND TEN SB SIX
A ONE EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN THREE
WHICH EVER ONE YOU PREFER I KNOW
SOME FOLKS MIGHT NOT BEEN HERE
THE BEGINNING OF THE HEARING WE
HAVE A LONG HEARING TODAY WE'RE
GONNA BE KEEPING A TIGHT TIME
LIMIT ON WITNESS TESTIMONY.
OF A MAXIMUM OF TWO MINUTES PER
PERSON AND THREE WITNESSES PER
AUTHOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AYE AYE I WOULD LIKE
SERVICE A. B. SEVEN SEVENTY
THREE IT.
WOULD VOTE WHICH EVERYONE YOU
WANT AB IS A SEVEN SEVEN TO HEAR
YOU I HAVE.
TEN ALRIGHT SIR THANK YOU FOR
MOVING THE BILL THIS IS REALLY
EASY IT'S JUST TEACHING HIGH
SCHOOLERS ACTUALLY THE MECHANICS
OF HOW TO VOTE.
ANY COMMENTS WOULD ASSIST NOTE
ANYONE IS IN SUPPORT WE SUPPORT
A I'M I'M RICHARD BRAUER FROM
THE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CUT JACKSON W. TO BRIDGE AND A
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SUPPORT REQUEST DRIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY THIS NOTICES IN SUPPORT IS
SHOWN BEHALF OF SECRETARY STATE
ALEX BY THE END SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
TONY TOOK CARE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THE EURO MUCH.
SEMOLINA BEHALF OF ME FROM LEVEL
TO AND SUPPORT THANK YOU -- MY
MOOD SEVERAL FAR DIRECTOR OF
MUCH FIVE CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THE YOU'RE MUCH. THREE CHERRY
BAND MEMBER OF MY FEEL AS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI JOEY FORESIGHT FOUNDER OF
AMANDA VOTERS IN SUPPORT GREAT
THANKS SO MUCH.
ANYONE IS IS OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON BRING BACK TO COLLEGE
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A SECOND CAN
WE GET ANOTHER SECOND DURING
[inaudible]
GOT IT.
YOU GUYS ARE TOUGH TODAY ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
AS A MEMBER CONSULTED A TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
GREAT IS A GREAT BILL I
RECOMMEND SUPPORT.
MADAM SECRETARY -- PLEASE CALL
VOTE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN AYE.
BERMAN I DOUBT GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CALDERON I DID NOT
BE OF CALDERON.
LOW.
LOW ON MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN.
WEBER.
WEBER I THE BILL IS OUT ON A
FIVE TO ONE VOTE WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
MOVING ON YOUR NEXT BILL SB SIX
EIGHTY ONE ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
NINE THANK YOU.
I'M REALLY MOTION.
WE HAVE A SECOND.
AB X. EIGHTY ONE IS JUST A
MEASURE TO TRY -- TO CIRCUMVENT
WHAT WE WHAT WE FOUND IN LAST
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION WHERE A
LOT OF FOLKS DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
IF YOU'RE NOT REGISTERED A
CERTAIN PARTY YOU MAY NOT
RECEIVE THE BALLOT THAT YOU
THINK THAT YOU WANT TO VOTE IN.
AND FOR EXAMPLE AT A NO PARTY
PREFERENCE VOTER IN CALIFORNIA
I'M CAN'T REQUESTED DEMOCRATIC --
BALLOT DATE WOULD HAVE TO RE
REGISTER AS A REPUBLICAN TO GET
A REPUBLICAN BALLOT IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY THIS TRIES
TO INFORM THE MULTIPLE TIMES BY
MULTIPLE METHODS THAT THIS IS
HAPPENING SO WE DON'T HAVE.
SOME SORT OF DISCONTENT THAT ODD
THAT I DON'T KNOW YOU.
THE FIGHT [inaudible]
I JUST [inaudible]
THAT'S COOL.
IT I IT ALSO DEALS WITH THE
SITUATION OF COURSE WE KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE HAVE
REGISTERED AS AMERICAN
INDEPENDENCE THINKING THAT
THEY'RE NO PARTY PREFERENCE --
ALERTS THEM TO THAT ALERT THEM
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO IN ORDER TO
VOTE FOR THE PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY WHICH THEY'RE INTERESTED
IN.
WITH ME IS PAUL MITCHELL.
WHO'S BEEN HOUNDING ME ABOUT
THIS ISSUE FOR YEARS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- PAUL
MITCHELL ON WITH POLITICAL DATE
INCORPORATED AND THIS IS
DEFINITELY A A A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE BUT IT KIND OF GETS LOST
BECAUSE WE ONLY THINK ABOUT IT
EVERY FOUR YEARS AND IT'S SUCH A
LITTLE KINDA NICHE THING.
BUT THE STATE HAS AN OPEN
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY FOR PRESIDENT
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT.
BUT IT'S OPEN IN AIR QUOTES
BECAUSE OF THE PROCESS.
I IF YOU'RE A NON PARTISAN VOTER
OR ACTUALLY.
IT'S ACT WE CALLED IT.
A PRIMARY QUALIFY DTS PQ DTS.
I ANY NEW N. P. P. VOTER OR
SOMEBODY WHO'S IN A IN A
REGISTER OR IN A PART OF ITS NOT
QUALIFIED LIKE IF YOUR REFORM
PARTY MEMBER.
OF YOU PUT BEACH PARTY OR PIRATE
PARTY YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO VOTE
IN THESE QUOTE UNQUOTE OPEN
PRIMARIES.
HOWEVER IF YOUR POLL VOTER IT'S
PRETTY SIMPLE.
YOU GO IN TO THE POLLING PLACE
AND THEY OFFER YOU A
PRESIDENTIAL BALLOT YOU TAKE IT
YOU GO WITH THE WITH YOUR
REGULAR ABOUT NEW VOTE.
BUT IF YOU'RE A VOTE BY MAIL
VOTER.
IT ISN'T THAT EASY THEY HAVE TO
MAIL YOU A LITTLE POSTCARD.
AND YOU HAVE TO SIGN IT FOR YOU
FILL IT OUT SIGN IT AND RETURN
IT -- IT'S EVEN HARDER IN THIS
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION CYCLE
BECAUSE OF THREE FACTORS. ONE IS
THERE'S AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE REGISTERING NO
PARTY PREFERENCE NOTABLY THOSE
TO REGISTERING UNDER THE NEW
AUTOMATIC VOTER REGISTRATION THE
DMV MORE THAN HALF OF THEM ARE
CHOOSING NO PARTY PREFERENCE.
SECONDLY THERE'S MANY MANY MORE
VOTE BY MAIL.
SO TWO THIRDS OR MORE OF THE
PEOPLE REGISTERED TO VOTE ONLINE
OR REGINALD ABOUT AS VOTE BY
MAIL.
AND THIRD THE TIME FRAME.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A MARCH THIRD
PRIMARY THAT MEANS BALLOTS HAVE
TO BE MAILED FEBRUARY THIRD.
THAT MEANS BALLOTS HAVE TO BE
PUT TOGETHER BY THE COUNTY IS
PREPARED FOR MAILINGS IN MID
JANUARY.
SO WHEN ARE THEY GONNA SEND OF
THESE POSTCARDS.
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO SELL THESE
POSTCARDS UP POSTCARDS OVER THE
HOLIDAYS THIS YEAR.
SO YOU'RE GONNA BE PLANNING FOR
THANKSGIVING CHRISTMAS FAMILY
AND YOU GET WITH ALL THE JUNK
MAIL YOU CAN GET LITTLE TINY
POSTCARDS YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
FILL OUT AND RETURN.
MOST VOTERS GET CONFUSED BY THIS
PROCESS AND THE NUMBER HAS BEEN
SKYROCKETING THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE IN THE
SITUATION.
SO THERE ARE FIVE POINT SEVEN
NINE FIVE MILLION PRIMARY
QUALIFIED TEACHERS VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
OF THOSE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THOSE WHO ARE P.
A. V. OR IN ONE OF THE NEW VOTE
CENTER COUNTIES.
THAT'S FOUR MILLION OF THEM SO
[inaudible]
IN COMPARISON.
THERE WERE TWO MILLION VOTERS
WHO IN THIS SITUATION BEING A
VOTE BY MAIL AND A NON PARTISAN
VOTER IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THERE ONLY ONE MILLION OF THEM
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT AND
THIS COMING ELECTION IN TWENTY
TWENTY THERE'S GOING TO BE FOUR
MILLION.
OF THOSE FOUR MILLION HOW MANY
OF EVER VOTED.
IN A PRIMARY INTERPOSE EVENTUAL
PRIMARY LESS THAN.
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND SO AND THE
ON TOP OF THAT OVER ONE AND A
HALF MILLION.
OF THOSE FOUR MILLION VOTERS
HAVE NEVER EVEN VOTED BY MAIL AT
ALL IN ANY ELECTION.
SO.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE LOOK
AT THIS ISSUE AND WE FOUND THAT
43% IN A POLL.
DID NOT KNOW HOW TO GET THE
ABSENTEE BALLOT THAT THEY'RE THE
BALLOT THAT THEY WANTED -- WE
FOUND THAT TWO THIRDS OF THE
VOTERS SAID THEY WANTED TO VOTE
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
YET.
OVER A MILLION BALLOTS WERE
RETURNED WITH NO PRESIDENTIAL
RACE AT ALL ON THE BALLOT.
REMEMBER IF YOU DON'T FILL OUT
THE POSTCARD.
YOU GET THE BALLOT AND IT HAS
LEGISLATIVE AND CONGRESSIONAL
AND BALLOT MEASURE IN CITY
COUNCIL BUT THE PRESIDENTIAL
SECTION IS BLANK.
AND OVER A MILLION BALLOTS WERE
RETURNED WITH A BLANK
PRESIDENTIAL SECTION AND WE
PULLED THEM AND FOUND THAT --
36% OF THEM SAID THEY'D WANTED
TO VOTE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN BUT DIDN'T
KNOW HOW.
TO SO THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
VOTER DISENFRANCHISEMENT ISSUE
WHERE IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE
CAN SEE.
THAT EVEN THOUGH THERE WAS HALF
AS MANY VOTERS IN THE SITUATION
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
WERE DISENFRANCHISED BECAUSE OF
THIS PROCESS SO WHAT THIS BILL
ATTEMPTS TO DO IS BRING
EDUCATION.
TO THE PROCESS OF WHAT PARTY ARE
YOU IN.
WE CAN TALK FOREVER ABOUT THE
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY IN
THE CONFUSION THERE -- AND THE
PROCESS FOR GETTING A BALLOT IF
YOU WANT TO VOTE IN EITHER THE
DEMOCRATIC OR REPUBLICAN
PRIMARIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THE GUARDS OPEN [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
ALL MY NAME IS CALLING BRITAIN
I'M WITH THE ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA.
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL IF
AMENDED.
AND I JUST WANT TO READ JUST
VERY VERY CLEAR.
VERY QUICKLY NAME AN
ORGANIZATION OKAY.
WE JUST URGE THAT THE BILL BE
AMENDED. TO CHANGE THE MANDATED
NUMBER OF VOTER NOTICES TO ONE
CARD VERSUS THREE OF THREE IN IN
SIXTY DAYS OF WE BELIEVE THAT
ONE SENT BY MAIL IT WOULD BE
SUFFICIENT.
TO GROW EDUCATE SEVEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT WAS THE TWEEN AROUND AGAIN.
WE'RE NOW WE'RE GOING TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS ERIC HARRIS OF WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE TO BRING ABOUT A
COLLEGE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NINE WE'VE GOT A MOTION
AND A SECOND MAN.
SOMEONE ORGANS ALL AS WE LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I A I DO WANT TO NOTE -- I ATE I
DO PLAN TO AMEND THIS IN TWO
WAYS I JUST WANT TO LET.
ALL OF YOU KNOW IT AFTER TALKING
TO MY REGISTER HE ASKED THAT I
MOVED IT FROM NINETY DAYS TO A
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS IN ADVANCE --
TO TRULY PREPARE I HAVE ENOUGH
TIME -- SO THAT THEY CAN START
TO DO THAT AND IN DOING SO IT
PUTS US AT A A POINT WHERE WE
WILL OF COURSE HAVE TO ADDED
URGENCY CLAUSE IN ORDER -- TO TO
HAVE THE THE BILL IMPLEMENTED IN
TIME -- I THINK IT'S SUCH A
COMMONSENSE MEASURE -- AND I DO
I HE POINTED OUT THAT THEY
PULLED OUT ON THE DEMOCRATIC
SIDE BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THEIR
NUMBER OF INDEPENDENTS WHO DON'T
REALIZE.
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO RE
REGISTER AS A REPUBLICAN ABOUT
NOT PRIMARY I THINK THAT'S A
POSITIVE FOR REPUBLICANS AS WELL
AS WELL AND I'LL BE HONEST I
MEAN PEOPLE DON'T LOVE THIS ON
OUR SIDE BUT DISENFRANCHISES
DEMOCRATS WHO WHO.
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES AS
REPUBLICANS IT WILL ALSO -- WHO
ARE TRUMP SUPPORTERS IT IT WILL
ALSO ALLOW THEM TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY WON'T HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO VOTE NOT ELECTION SO?
I I THINK TRANSPARENCY IS GOOD I
THINK TELLING VOTERS WHAT WHAT
THEY SHOULD EXPECT IN AND HOW
THEY SHOULD EXPECT IS GOOD IF IT
BENEFITS US OF A BENEFITS OTHER
FOLKS BUT THIS IS JUST ABOUT --
LETTING THEM KNOW HOW TO
EXERCISE THE RIGHT TO VOTE SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CAN YOU.
DO TO THEIR TWO MOMENTS THAT YOU
WERE PLANNING TO MAKE YOUR THE
URGENCY CLASS.
HAS OF THE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAYS KNOWS THAT ONE
GOTCHA -- GREAT NO THIS WAS AN
ISSUE WHEN I WAS.
FIRST RUNNING IN TALKING A LOT
OF DOORS I HEARD A LOT OF
CONFUSION FOR DTS VOTERS ABOUT
THIS AND I DIDN'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE AND SO I
WASN'T ABLE. TO TO KIND OF GIVE
THEM GOOD GUIDANCE ON WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO AND I THINK THIS WILL
WILL HOPEFULLY -- KIND OF SOLVE
A LOT OF FRUSTRATIONS THAT EXIST
WITH A LOT OF VOTERS AND EDUCATE
FOLKS ON ON WHAT THEY NEED TO DO
TO TO HAVE THEIR VOICE HEARD TO
REALLY APPRECIATE THE BILL WITH
THAT -- HAPPY TO MAKING MY
RECOMMENDATION AMOUNT OF
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE.
YES YES SO YOU MAKE THE MOMENTS
THE IT IN YOUR COMMITTEE ON THIS
YEAH I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
I WAS.
VERY TRANSPARENT ABOUT IT
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IT IT.
COINCIDES WITH ISSUES I THINK
THAT THIS COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE
AS WELL SO BRIDGET THANK YOU TO
MOVING THE BILL AS IS CURRENTLY.
IN PRINT THANK YOU SORRY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE BERMAN
AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CALDERON CALDERON AYE LOW WELL I
MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN.
WEBER WEBER I SO THAT BILLS OUT
ON A FIVE OH VOTE WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MOVING ON IT I SAW MR BONTA IN
THE AUDIENCE.
WITH ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB EIGHT
FORTY NINE OR A NUMBER SIXTEEN
TO BE THIRTEEN AND ONE YOUR PICK
THAT'S OUR THIRTY NINE ONE FIRST
PERFECT FOR TO BE A LITTLE
FASTER.
AB THIRTY NINETY ONE IMPROVES
THE ACCESSIBILITY OF TRANSLATED
VOTING MATERIALS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT VOTERS.
THANK YOU.
THIS RIGHT NOW WE HAVE REALLY
LOW UPTAKE I AM ON OUR BOB
PEOPLE SIGNING UP FOR NON
ENGLISH LANGUAGE PREFERENCE IN
THE USE OF THE BY THE GOAL
MATERIALS THIS WILL HELP.
INCREASE OF THE USE OF THE
MATERIALS THAT ARE AVAILABLE BY
LAW.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
JONATHAN STEIN REPRESENTING
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND
SAMMY MOLINA REPRESENTING ME
FAMILIAR VOTE THAT A CO SPONSOR
OF THE BILL GREAT AND BEFORE WE
GET STARTED -- MISTER OFTEN DO
WE HAVE CONFIRMATION YOU'RE
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS -- THE
COMMITMENTS.
IT WAS SMALL TECHNICAL MOMENT
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE IT THANK
YOU FOR OF THE MOMENT AND JUST
CONFIRMING THE MOTION THE SECOND
INCLUDE THE AMENDMENTS.
YES.
YES PERFECT FOR TO THINK WITH
LOW FREON ARISING ABOUT NINETIES.
PERFECT PLEASE I'LL I'LL COME I
JUST MONEY HALF OF MY NAME IS
JONATHAN STEIN I RUN THE VOTING
RIGHTS PROGRAM ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS.
OUR TEAM WORKS TO ENSURE THAT
HISTORICALLY DISENFRANCHISED
UNDER PARTICIPATING COMMUNITIES
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS OUR DEMOCRACY.
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO SEE
SEVERE AND PERSISTENT VOTER
PARTICIPATION DISPARITIES -- IN
CALIFORNIA'S TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN GENERAL ELECTION OF
ELIGIBLE ASIAN AMERICANS JUST
33% VOTED OF ELIGIBLE LATINOS
JUST 36% VOTED OF ALL OTHERS
OVER 61% VOTED.
SHOCKINGLY THESE VOTER
PARTICIPATION DISPARITIES ARE
ACTUALLY WORSE THAN THE
DISPARITIES WE SAW TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN WE PASSED AUTOMATIC
VOTER REGISTRATION PARTIAL SAME
DAY VOTER REGISTRATION PRE
REGISTRATION OF SIXTEEN TO
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD.
THESE ARE ALL EXCELLENT BILLS
AND THEY HELP DRIVE UP TURN OUT
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE SAW WAS
THAT VOTER PARTICIPATION AMONG
ASIAN AMERICANS LATINOS ONE UP
LESS THAN ELECTED AT LARGE WHICH
MEANT THAT TURNOUT DISPARITIES
GOT BIGGER.
AND OUR STATE SELECTOR ACTUALLY
LOOKS LESS LIKE THE STATE ITSELF.
SO WITH AN EQUITY LINE LENDS IN
MIND WERE PROUD TO SPONSOR A. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE AB THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE WHAT IN EIGHT MAKE IT
EASIER.
FOR NON ENGLISH SPEAKING VOTERS
TO ACCESS THE TRANSLATOR
MATERIALS TO WHICH THEY ARE
ENTITLED UNDER LAW AND WHICH
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS ARE
EXPENDING GREAT EXPENSE AND TIME
IN ACTUALLY MAKING.
BUT ARE BEING REQUESTED A
DRAMATICALLY LOWER RATES -- ONLY
3% OF VOTER REGISTRATIONS AND
THE STATE'S VOTER REGISTRATION
DATABASE HAVE A LANGUAGE
PREFERENCE IDENTIFIED FOR
SOMETHING OTHER THAN ENGLISH
JUST 3%.
THIS IS TRUE DESPITE THE FACT IT
UP CITIZENS OF VOTING AGE IN
CALIFORNIA. 35% SPEAK A LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH AT HOME FOLKS
ARE NOT X. AT REQUESTING THE
MIGHT TRANSLATE A MATERIALS
WHICH THEY ARE ENTITLED.
AND AB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
ATTEMPTS -- TO MAKE THAT EASIER
TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MY NAME SAMUEL IN IN
THE STATE DIRECTOR FOR ME
FAMILIAR VOTE THAT WE ARE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON
INCREASING CIVIC PARTICIPATION
MIKE'S LOOKING ON IMMIGRANT.
COMMUNITIES WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE ON IT'S A GOOD TIME JUST THE
SERVER A QUICK STORY -- LAST
LAST YEAR BE FAMILIAR WITH THE
HOST THE TO VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT
PARTIES AND BY SALIH AND FRESNO --
COUNTIES TOTALING MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED ATTENDEES ARE
VENTS WERE CONDUCTED IN LEAGUE
WITH ONE OF ITS OWN. TWENTY ONE
AND A MAJORITY OF OUR ATTENDEES
WERE MONOLINGUAL SPANISH
SPEAKERS DURING OUR EVENTS WE
MET A WOMAN NAMED LORD THIS LORD
THIS WAS X. VERY EXCITED TO
ATTEND OUR EVENT AND SHE EVEN
BROUGHT ADDITIONAL VOTERS WITH
HER.
SHE BOTTOM BECAUSE SHE HAD NEVER
REALLY VOTED FOR ANY OF THE
BALLOT MEASURES IN THE PAST
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
THEM AND SHE WAS SCARED TO VOTE
FOR SOMETHING THAT WOULD HARM
HER FAMILY.
AND OUR COMMUNITY.
SO SHE WOULD ONLY VOTE FOR THE
CANDIDATES IN THE GENERAL
ELECTION SHE WAS REALLY EXCITED
BECAUSE WHILE ATTENDING OUR
BALLOT PARTY SHE FELT INFORMED
AND CONFIDENT ON HER VOTES --
LORD THIS EXPERIENCE XP SPEAKS
TO HOW IMPORTANT.
ARE GETTING CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY SUPPORT CAN BE
FOR VOTERS ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE IS A STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION.
AND GETTING MORE SPANISH
LANGUAGE BALLOTS IN THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO NEED THEM.
WE REQUEST YOUR YES VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I AM GRAHAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WHEN IS A SEVEN O'CLOCK THEM
WITH THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU?
DOOR ROSE THE RIVER IS A
CALIFORNIA WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL AND STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JERRY FORESIGHT AMANDA VOTERS
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING ABOUT
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS SAYING
NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THIS PANEL YES PRIVATE THANK YOU
GREAT.
ALAS SESSION I WAS HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS AUTHORS EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE THE AVAILABILITY OF
TRANSLATED VOTING MATERIALS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S LANGUAGE MINORITY
COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL TAKES AN IMPORTANT
NEXT STEP TO IMPROVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR VOTERS TO
REQUEST BALLOT MATERIALS IN
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
A SO I'M RECOMMENDING SUPPORT
WITH THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENT
THAT IT HAS BEEN ACCEPTED BY THE
AUTHOR -- WITH THAT MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN.
BERMAN I GALLAGHER.
CALDERON CALDERON I'D LOW.
WELL I'D MAYES.
MAYES I'M MULLIN [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
I THAT'S OUT ON A FIVE OVER WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF
YOU'D LIKE TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB.
EIGHT FORTY NINE YES PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES IN STAFF I AM
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS ON AB EIGHT FORTY NINE
THANK YOU FOR THOSE.
AND ALSO BE TAKEN SOME
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS RESPONSIVE
TO SOME OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE
CONCERNS I'VE HEARD RAISED BY
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ASSOCIATIONS INCLUDING REDUCING
THE MAXIMUM NUMBER OF HEARINGS
FROM.
TEN TO SIX ONLY APPLY THE NEW
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT REQUIREMENTS
OF THE REDISTRICTING CONTEXT AND
SCALING BACK SOME OF THE HEARING
ACCESSIBILITY.
REQUIREMENTS.
REDISTRICTING IS OF CRUCIAL
IMPORTANCE TO LOCAL DEMOCRACY
HOW LOCAL GOVERNMENT ELECTION
DISTRICTS ARE DRAWN CAN HELP
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT A
COMMUNITY WILL BE FAIRLY
REPRESENTED.
AT THEIR MOST INTIMATE AND
CLOSEST LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
UNLIKE STATE LEVEL REDISTRICTING
THERE ARE VERY FEW REQUIREMENTS
GOVERNING LOCAL REDISTRICTING TO
ENSURE THE PROCESS IS FAIR AND
TRANSPARENT.
AND THAT THE PUBLIC AND
ESPECIALLY UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES ARE ENGAGED IN THE
PROCESS CURRENTLY LOCAL DISTRICT
MAPS CAN BE DRAFTED THEN
INTRODUCED AND ADOPTED AT THE
SAME MEETING WITHOUT FIRST BEING
PUBLISHED AND SHARED.
WITH THE PUBLIC ADDITIONALLY
THERE IS NO PUBLIC OUTREACH
REQUIREMENT INCLUDING TO NON
ENGLISH SPEAKING COMMUNITIES
WERE LESS LIKELY TO BE AWARE.
OF THE PROCESS THE CURRENT LAW
UNDERMINES THE GOAL OF FAIR
REPRESENTATION AB EIGHT FORTY
NINE WILL BRING TRANSPARENCY AND
CREEK CLEAR STANDARDS THAT WOULD
BE SIMILAR TO THOSE OF STATE AND
CONGRESSIONAL.
REDISTRICTING REQUIREMENTS I'M
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT
WE STRUCK THE RIGHT BALANCE HERE
BETWEEN COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
TRANSPARENCY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE I HAVE WITH
ME NICHOLAS HEIGHT ONE POLICY
AND LEGAL DIRECTOR OF COMMON
CAUSE CALIFORNIA AS WELL.
AS JONATHAN STEIN ONCE AGAIN HAD
A VOTING RIGHTS AND SENSES
PROGRAMS THAT ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RESPOND AND JUST
CLARIFICATION THE MEMONS WILL BE
TAKEN IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE
BECAUSE OF TIMING ISSUES.
THANK YOU FOR FOR AGREEING TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HELP OUT WITH THEM AND
APPRECIATE CLARIFICATION BRIDGET
THANKS PLEASE.
CHAIR BERMAN MEMBERS NICKEL SIDE
ON WITH CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE.
FAIR REDISTRICTING IS CRUCIAL AT
ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT TO
ENSURE A REPRESENTATIVE AND
INCLUSIVE DEMOCRACY.
IS PRO TRUST IN THE FAIRNESS
WERE SYSTEM.
IT IS HARD TO UNDERSTATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF REDUCING WHEN THE
PROCESS IS MISUSED A CAN OF THE
PRACTICAL EFFECT.
OF DEPRIVING COMMUNITIES OF
VOICE IN GOVERNMENT FOR AN
ENTIRE DECADE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS A WHEN IT COMES
TO STATE AND CONGRESSIONAL
REDUCING CALIFORNIA'S THE
NATIONAL MODEL.
THE STATE'S CITIZENS REDUCING
COMMISSION AS A TRANSPARENT
PROCESS COMMITMENTS PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT AND APPLIES FAIR IN
CLEAR CRITERIA.
HOWEVER MANY OF THESE
PROTECTIONS ARE LACKING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. FOR EXAMPLE UNLIKE
FOR STATE AND CONGRESSIONAL
REDISTRICTING THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT FOR LOCAL REDUCING.
THE COMMUNITIES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS BE CAPS HOLE.
IN FACT OTHER THAN FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT OF EQUAL POPULATION
AND YOU'RE A COMPLAINTS THERE NO
MANDATORY STANDARDS AT ALL FOR
LOCAL REDUCING JUST
DISCRETIONARY CONSIDERATIONS THE
CAN BE IGNORED.
AND WHERE IS A STATE COMMISSION
GAUGES AND AN EXTENSIVE HEARING
PROCESS STATE LAW REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS JUST HOLD ONE PUBLIC
HEARING PRIOR TO ADOPTING MAPS
AND NO PUBLIC OUT REQUIREMENTS.
AS A RESULT.
MANY COMMUNITIES AND ESPECIALLY
ALREADY UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES OFTEN FAILED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE REDUCING
PROCESS.
YOU MAY NOT EVEN BE AWARE THAT
IT IS OCCURRING.
TAKEN TOGETHER THIS PROVIDES A
LITTLE ONLY A LITTLE SAFETYNET
AGAINST EXTREME GERRYMANDERING
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. FOR EXAMPLE
I LIKE TO THE COMMITTEE -- THIS
MAP WHICH IS THE COUNCIL
DISTRICTS OF THE CITY MARTINEZ
WHICH I BELIEVE ILLUSTRATES THIS
POINT.
PROTECTING COMMENTS FOUR OF WHOM
LIVE NEAR EACH OTHER THE COUNCIL
DO SKINNY AND CONTORTED NORTH
SOUTH DISTRICTS.
CRACKING NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES WITH ALMOST COMPLETE
DISREGARD.
THIS INVERTS VERY PURPOSE THREE
DISTINCT RIGHT FAIR
REPRESENTATION TOLL PEOPLE.
INSTEAD MAKES THE PROCESS JUST A
TOOL DOUBLE STRING COMMENTS
THANK YOU.
THE SPLITTING OF NEIGHBORHOODS
AND COMMUNITIES ITSELF A PROBLEM
ALSO CONTRIBUTES THE STARK UNDER
REPRESENTATION OF RACIAL
MINORITIES IN CALIFORNIA LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
IN THE LAST CYCLE SO RICH
ORGANIZATIONS REPEATEDLY
OBJECTED TO MINORITY COMMUNITIES
BEING SPLIT THREE DISTINCT
INCLUDING AND COUNTIES LIKE LOS
ANGELES SAN BERN DINO ORANGE
INTO LAURIE.
CITIES LIKE LONG BEACH OAKLAND
PLACENTIA IN SACRAMENTO AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS LIKE KERN HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
REDUCING HAS ALSO BEEN ABUSED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
DISENFRANCHISE VOTERS BASED ON
THEIR PARTY AFFILIATION.
AFFECTING PEOPLE OF BOTH PARTIES.
AB EIGHT FOUR NINE THE FARM
OUTSIDE TO STRENGTHENS LOCAL
REDUCING PROCESS AGAINST THESE
PIECES IN TWO KEY WAYS FIRST.
REFORMS A CRITERIA FOR LOWER
DISTRICT TO MINIMIZE POSSIBILITY
GERRYMANDERING THOSE HOUSES
MANDATORY RANK CRITERIA.
MODEL CLOSELY OFF OF THE STATE
CRITERIA.
SO THE KEEPING NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES WILL BE PRIORITIZED
THE BILL ALSO FOR THE FIRST TIME
PROHIBITS PARTISAN
GERRYMANDERING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
FINALLY AB EIGHT FOUR NINE ALSO
PROVIDES IMPORTANT PROCEDURAL
AND TRANSPARENCY SAFEGUARDS SO
THE PUBLIC CAN BETTER
PARTICIPATE IN THE LOCAL PROCESS.
THIS INCLUDES REQUIRING MINIMUM
FOR HEARINGS BEFORE MAP CAN BE
APPROVED NO PART OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ENGAGING COMMUNITY
OUTREACH SO DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING NON ENGLISH SPEAKING
CHINESE COMPRESS SPATE.
TOGETHER THESE CHANGES PROPOSED
MAYBE A POINT ON WILL CONTRIBUTE
TO MORE REPRESENTATIVE INCLUSIVE
IN ACCOUNTABLE LOCAL MOXIE AND
WE ARE.
WE URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU IF
YOU.
MY NAME IS JONATHAN STEIN AGAIN
I HAD THE VOTING RIGHTS AND
SENSES PROGRAMS THAT ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK TO THE COMMUNITY EDUCATION
AND PUBLIC PARTICIPATION PARTS
OF THE BILL.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IN THE
BROADEST POSSIBLE SENSE IS GIVES
HISTORICALLY DISENFRANCHISED
COMMUNITIES THAT BEEN LEFT OUT
OF OUR DEMOCRACY A FIGHTING
CHANCE I LIKE TO SHARE STORIES?
IN A CITY SHIFT FROM OUT LARGE
DISTRICT ELECTIONS THAT REQUIRED
HOLD FOR PUBLIC HEARINGS THE
CITY OF FREMONT GOTTA CBRE
NOTICED LETTER AND BEGIN TO CHIP
THE DISTRICTS.
WE FOUND OUT ABOUT IT AFTER TWO
HEARINGS HAVE BEEN COMPLETED AND
DRAFT MAPS THAT ARE THE PUBLIC.
FREMONT IS HOME TO THE LARGEST
AFGHAN POPULATION OUTSIDE OF
AFGHANISTAN IS FAMOUS ACROSS THE
AFGHAN DIASPORA WORLDWIDE.
AND YET BECAUSE THE AFGHAN
COMMUNITY HAS NO VOICE IN CITY
POLITICS NO AFGHANS HAVE BEEN
CONSULTED IN THE DRAWING OF MAPS
AND THAT SPLIT THE AFGHAN
CULTURAL AND COMMERCIAL HUB INTO
TWO DISTRICTS OR THREE DISTRICTS
DEPENDING ON THE MAP.
WE BROUGHT INTO THE COMMUNITY
TEACHING AFTER A COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ABOUT DISTRICTS HELPING
THE MAP THEIR COMMUNITY AND
PREPARE THEM TO STEP FORWARD AND
PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
IN THE FIRST TWO HEARINGS NEVER
ZERO AFGHANS PRESENT FOR THE
LAST TWO AFGHANS OVER HALF OF
THE SPEAKERS NONE OF THEM EVER
SPEAK INTO THE CITY COUNCIL.
FOR EACH SPOKE PASSIONATELY
SOMETIMES THE TRANSLATOR BUT HOW
IMPORTANT FREMONT LOS THE AFGHAN
COMMUNITY AND HOW IMPORTANT
AFTER A COMMUNITY WHAT'S THE
FREMONT.
THIS BOOK ABOUT FINDING A NEW
HOME AFTER LEAVING ONE TORN BY
WAR.
WE SPOKE ABOUT WANTING TO FEEL
VALUED LISTEN. TO ONE WOMAN IN
BROKEN ENGLISH THANK THE CITY
COUNCIL PER SERVING THE CITY AND
SAID THAT SOMEDAY SHE HELPED HER
SON WHO'S GETTING GREAT GRADES
IN SCHOOL WOULD SOME DAY BE THE
MAYOR OF FREMONT.
LONG STORY SHORT THE MAPS
REDRAWN AND THE AFGHAN CULTURE
BECAUSE COMMERCIAL HUB WAS KEPT
TOGETHER IT WAS A VICTORY FOR
REPRESENTATION AND FOR DEMOCRACY.
BUT HERE'S THE THING NO ONE
OTHER THAN US REACHED OUT TO THE
AFGHAN COMMUTING TOLD IN THIS
PROCESS WAS HAPPENING IF WE
HADN'T DONE THAT THAT VICTORY
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
IS A WORKING PEOPLE THEY CAN'T
TAKE TIME OFF IF THOSE MEETINGS
HAVE BEEN HELD AT NIGHT THIS
VICTORY WHAT HAPPENED.
THERE WERE NO TRANSLATORS ON
HAND IF COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAD
BEEN WILLING TO TRANSLATE THAT
VICTOR WOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
IT TOOK TIME TO ORGANIZE TO
EDUCATE TO MOBILIZE IF THERE'D
BEEN JUST ONE HEARING THAT BACK
VICTORY WOULDN'T OF HAPPENED.
IT FREMONT LITERALLY EVERYTHING
WENT RIGHT IF ONE THING HADN'T A
COMMUNITY HAS ALREADY LEFT OUT
OF LOCAL DEMOCRACY WITHIN SLICED
AND DICED IN THE DISTRICT IN
PROCESS.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
CREATE A LOCAL REDISTRICTING
PROCESS WHERE THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN WE'RE COMMUNITIES HAVE A
FIGHTING CHANCE TO MAKE
THEMSELVES HEARD.
I KNOW SOME LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
MAY SEE THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
ADDITIONAL HEARINGS FOR DOING
OUTREACH AND PROVIDING
TRANSLATORS AS BURDENSOME.
BUT WITHOUT THOSE THINGS
CONSIDER THE BURDEN PLACED ON
OUR COMMUNITIES.
LIVING UNDER DEMOCRATIC SYSTEMS
THAT DON'T REPRESENT THEM THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND THEIR NEEDS
THEY DON'T LOOK AT THE
COMMUNITIES THE MEANT TO SERVE.
AND LIVING AS AN AFTERTHOUGHT IN
YOUR OWN LOCAL DEMOCRACY FOR A
TEN YEAR REDISTRICTING CYCLE
THAT IS BURDENSOME.
VOTE YES ON A. B. EIGHT FOUR
NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
I ANGER MAYES FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOUR ROSY ROOM VOTERS TO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT CO SPONSOR
AND I'D LIKE TO CORRECT THE
RECORD WE'RE NOT CO SPONSORING
AB THIRTEEN ONE BUT WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. TOO MANY BILLS
TODAY THANK YOU AGREED THANK YOU.
SEMOLINA MI FAMILIA VOTE THAT
WERE CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
AND OFTEN SUPPORT.
THANKS TANYA PELLEGRINI WITH THE
MEXICAN AMERICAN LEGAL DEFENSE
AND EDUCATIONAL FUND IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SOME LOOK AT THEM WITH THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAVE CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEETHER HAS BEEN OF THE PRESS
FROM SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
TRENT LINE CALIFORNIA MONEY
CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PAT LANG CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY
PLEASE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JACQUELYN DOOR A SACRAMENTO BY A
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATE AND CLEAN
MONEY -- VOLUNTEER PLEASE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL SHEA FROM CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MUCH.
POWER RANDALL SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JENNIFER HAITI CLEAN MANY
CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION.
WE ARE PLENTY OF ROOM UP HERE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBER STATE
HUTCHINGS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE MEASURE -- EVEN AT AS THE
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN PROPOSED
ADD TO BE ACCEPTED -- THERE
STILL SOME PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES THAT CITIES ARE
FACING WITH WITH REGARDS TO
COMPLIANCE OF ROGER ACOSTA BELT
SET SET SET SET ASIDE FOR A
MOMENT.
THE YOU KNOW THE THE COMPLETE
OVERHAUL OF THE CRITERIA AND HOW
MAPS ARE DRAWN THE OUT REACH
REQUIREMENTS WILL STILL RESULT
IN HUNDRED NINETY DOLLARS AND
FUNDED AT OR AND OR SUSPENDED
MANDATE COSTS -- EVEN AS AMENDED
THE MAP THE MEASURE STILL
REQUIRE SNIPPET SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF DIGITAL HEARING NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS AND POSTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT EXCEED THE
BROWN ACT -- REQUIRING
TRANSLATION SERVICES AUDIO
VISUAL AND DROPPED IT MINUTES
FOR EACH -- HEARING AND ALL
APPLICABLE LANGUAGES TO THE
JURISDICTION -- YOU KNOW -- IT
REQUIRES THAT -- SIGNIFICAN OUT
OF WEBSITE POSTING A TRANSLATION
REQUIREMENTS ARE STILL REQUIRED
AS WELL.
YOU KNOW AND I I THINK I YOU
KNOW ON A BROADER SCALE AND I'VE
I'VE EXPRESSED THIS PRETTY
DIRECTLY TO THE SPONSORS THIS
BILL WE HAVE WORK -- TO IN IN
CONCERT WITH THE BOAT PEOPLE
THEY'RE SITTING AT THIS TABLE
THEY'VE SPOKEN AT OUR
CONFERENCES THEY'VE SPOKEN.
YOU KNOW AT TO TO OUR MEMBERS
ARE WORKING TOGETHER TO TRY TO
FIND YOU KNOW MEAN FOR SOLUTIONS
TO ENGAGE VOTERS -- AND WITH
SIXTY PAGES OF AMENDMENTS I
THINK IT DROPPED INTO A MEASURE
THAT AFFECTS EVERY ASPECT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT I THINK THE
NARRATIVE THAT THAT IT CLEARLY
SUPPORT ABOUT THE TESTIMONY IS
THAT.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE ACTIVELY
TRYING TO JERRY MANDER THEY'RE
ACTIVELY TRYING TO
DISENFRANCHISE VOTERS AND I
WOULD REMIND AT ALL BUT ONE
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE SERVED
IN A AND A CAPACITY OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
I WOULD ASK THAT YOU TAKE THAT
IN CONSIDERATION WHEN YOU'RE
THINKING OF THE FACT THAT ARE WE
ACTIVELY TRYING -- TO SUPPRESS
VOTING I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT IS
THAT TO BE THE CASE IN
CALIFORNIA GIVEN THAT WE ARE --
THE REALLY THE MODEL OF
DEMOCRACY MOVING FORWARD SO --
WITH THAT -- THE BECAUSE IT IS
DOES OPPOSED MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DON'T GIVENS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION OF THIS MEASURE.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS A MOSTLY ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH TO ALL
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND I THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE WE LOOK
AT WHO THIS IS APPLYING TO IN.
AND IN PARTICULAR HOW TO
APPLYING TO THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS -- THERE ARE JUST FOR
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
THERE ARE THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
REPRESENTED.
BY THE BY THIS COMMITTEE THERE
OVER TWO THOUSAND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE.
NOW WHILE MOST OF THEM ARE
CURRENTLY NOT HAVING BY DISTRICT
ELECTIONS THAT NUMBER IS RAPIDLY
CHANGING IN RESPONSE TO THE CVR
A LAWSUIT SO WHILE A IT'S
PROBABLY LESS THAN HALF NOW IT'S
GOING TO BE IT.
I I DID I THINK AT SOME POINT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE ALMOST ALL OF
OF OUR OUR DISTRICTS RANGE IN
SIZE FROM -- THEY THEY COVERED
MULTIPLE CITIES TO WORK -- TWO
SQUARE MILES OR GO OVER TWO OR
THREE DIFFERENT COUNTY LINES.
YOU FOR THE JUST FOR THE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE WITHIN
REPRESENTING THIS COMMITTEE THAT
WOULD BE AT THE MINIMUM OF FOUR
MEETINGS FOR THE THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE DISTRICTS THAT'S ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN PUBLIC OUTREACH MEETINGS.
AND THAT'S JUST FOR SPECIAL
DISTRICTS THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE
ALL THE CITIES THAT ARE WITHIN
YOUR YOUR JURISDICTIONS OR THE
COUNTIES.
AND AND AND THIS IS NOW SENATE
SOMEHOW BRING IN THE PUBLIC TO
BE MORE ENGAGED IN THE THE
DISTRICTING LINES FOR THEIR
WATER DISTRICT. FOR THEIR
UTILITY DISTRICT SPECIAL
DISTRICTS -- TYPICALLY PROVIDING
ONE SINGULAR SERVICE WHAT THE
RESIDENTS TYPICALLY CARE ABOUT --
FROM THEIR FROM THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS IS VIEWED AS A POWER
TURNOUT.
DOES THE WATER WORK.
IT IT'S NOT IT'S NOT AN ISSUE OF
I MEAN THESE ARE NONPARTISAN
ELECTIONS THERE THERE ARE
DIFFERENT THAN STATE AND
CONGRESSIONAL.
RACES WITH THE WE'RE WE'RE NOT
DRAWING LINES TO TRY AND HAVE
REPUBLICANS BECAUSE WE'RE
NONPARTISAN.
IT'S AGAIN TO THE WATER TURNOUT
DISEASE DOES YOUR UTILITY WORK --
IT WILL INITIALLY THIS IS GOING
TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT UNFUNDED
MANDATE.
COST TO OUR PUBLIC AGENCIES MANY
OF ART SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE
EVEN ELIGIBLE FOR REIMBURSEMENT
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE MANDATE
PROCESS AT THE COMMISSION ITS
STATE MANDATES.
SO THESE ARE SIGNIFICANT COSTS
THAT WILL BE PASSED ON TO
RESIDENTS DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
THEIR HOW MUCH MONEY THEY MAKE
THEIR FEES MAY HAVE TO GO UP
JUST TO PAY THE WATER BILL OR
THEIR UTILITY BILL -- FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE POSES MEASURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN HEARST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA.
ARE WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION AS COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS WHO.
RUN LOCAL ELECTIONS AND ARE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT --
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS WE HAVE
SORT OF THE UNIQUE.
ROLE IN SORT OF BRINGING UP THE
ISSUE OF THE COST OF THIS.
THE MANDATE PROPOSED BY AB.
EIGHT FORTY NINE WE ARE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE PRACTICE OF
REQUIRING LOCAL AGENCIES TO DO
NEW AND HIGHER LEVELS OF SERVICE
IN ELECTIONS AND THEN THOSE
MANDATES GET SUSPENDED RESULTING
IN A NO FUNDING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL OR THE CHOICE.
TO STOP PROVIDING THIS SERVICE
OBVIOUSLY IN ELECTIONS THAT'S
VERY DIFFICULT OUR ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS IN OUR COUNTY LEADERS
DON'T REALLY WANT TO GO DOWN
THAT PATH -- YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT
SOME OF THE PRACTICAL
COMPLEXITIES WE CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES ON THOSE BUT
WE REALLY WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU
TO CONSIDER.
THE COST OF IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS MEASURE AS OF THIS BILL IS
CONSIDERED BY THIS COMMITTEE --
AND AGAIN WE HAVE -- AND OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE THE
DIALOGUE BUT VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE COST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
JEFF NEAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
ONE ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
MY COLLEAGUE TING THANK YOU.
THOROUGHBRED ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS WOULD ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WHEN THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION SING NONE BRING IT
BACK TO COLLEGE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR MOTIONS OR SECONDS
[inaudible]
MISTER MISS.
I'M JUST GOING TO AGAIN FOR
BREVITY'S SAKE JUST TO ALIGN
MYSELF WITH US SOME OF THE AT
THE OPPONENTS -- THE COMMENTS --
I AT ONE POINT TIME IN TWENTY
GUESSES TWENTY ELEVEN I WORKED
FOR A COUNTY SUPERVISOR AND SAM
YOU COUNTY AND WE ACTUALLY BUT A
LOT OF TIME.
A DRAWING THE LINES DECEMBER YOU
KNOW COUNTY -- AND IT'S
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT WHEN YOU'RE
WHEN YOU'RE DOING THAT I DO
THINK THAT THIS IS A LOCAL A
LOCAL CONTROL ISSUE IN JUST LET
MY COMMENTS WITH THEM ABOUT THE
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
NEED ADDITIONAL.
COMMENTS FROM ANY COLLEAGUES.
DR WEBER.
I WANT TO OF THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS I THINK --
AND I'M I DIDN'T GET THE
ORGANIZATION YOU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION RIGHT OKAY.
BOB AND I I SAY THIS BECAUSE I
THINK.
OFTENTIMES THERE'S A PERSPECTIVE
THAT EVERYTHING IS GOING WELL.
AND THAT EVERYBODY'S HAPPY AND
UNTIL YOU GET TO DIFFERENT
GROUPS THAT ARE SMALLER DO YOU
REALIZE THAT EVERYBODY'S NOT
HAPPY THOSE WHO GENERALLY ON THE
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS AND RUN
AND THINGS ARE VERY HAPPY.
WITH WHAT HAPPENS THEY THINK
IT'S VERY FAIR VERY HONEST THEY
EITHER IN SAN DIEGO THEY HAD WE
HAD JUDGES WHO WOULD BASICALLY
DOING THIS.
AND AND IT ENDED YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU GET DOWN TO THE LEVEL FOLKS
THEY WERE SAYING YOU KNOW OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN DIVIDED WE
HAVEN'T HAD BEEN HURT WE DON'T
KNOW YOU KNOW ON AND ON AND ON
AND SO.
IF YOU'RE NOT A PART OF IT THEN
YOU DON'T REALIZE YOU KNOW THAT
THAT THAT THERE THERE'S THIS
THIS THING GOING ON AND MANY OF
OUR SPECIAL DISTRICTS PARTICULAR
HOSPITAL DISTRICTS.
OF OF FOLKS DON'T EVEN KNOW THEY
EXIST -- AT LEAST I DISCOVERED
IN IN SAN DIEGO THAT SOME OF
THEM BOB AND YET THEY'RE MAKING
MAJOR DECISIONS ABOUT HEALTHCARE
IN COMMUNITIES AND WHO'S BEING
SERVED WHO'S NOT BEING SIR.
SO THE HEALTHCARE DISTRICT IN
SAN DIEGO NOW PEOPLE GOES MY
PARTICULARLY THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE RAISING ISSUES THAT ARE
COMING FORTH BUT MOST COMMUNITY
FOLKS HAVE NO IDEA BECAUSE OF
THE WAY THE DISTRICTS THE THE
STRUCTURE.
OR HOW THEY DO THE BUSINESS THEY
DO THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW THEY
EXIST SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT --
THAT -- THAT WE DO OPEN UP THIS
WHOLE AREA BECAUSE THERE ARE
MANY MANY COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
OF A SPLIT AND I HAVE SOME THAT
A SPLIT AND DIVIDED IN VARIOUS
WAYS.
AND IT DOES MAKE IT DIFFICULT
FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES TO EVEN
JUST TO ACCESS THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS SOMETIMES PEOPLE SAY
WELL YOU'RE VERY FORTUNATE TO
HAVE THREE ELECTED OFFICIAL WANT
TO TALK TO THREE ELECTED.
ME YEAH IF YOU HAVE NOTHING ELSE
TO DO BUT IF YOU KNOW.
THE WHOLE IDEA OF IT THEY HAD
YOUR YOUR YOUR POWER HAS BEEN
DIVIDED UP SO YOU THINK YOU HAVE
THREE REPRESENT IS WHAT YOU
REALLY DON'T BECAUSE OF THE
WEIGHT OF THE OF OF THE THE
COLLECTIVE IS NOT THERE AND SO
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW YOU DO IT AND I KNOW IT'S
DIFFICULT AND IS EXPENSIVE AND
DEMOCRACY ALWAYS TAKES MORE TIME
THAT WE WANT TO GIVE?
UP BUT I THINK THERE'S SOME
VALUE AND IT'S OUR I REALLY
RESPECT YOUR COMMENTS BECAUSE I
KNOW IT'S HARD.
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO MANAGE ALL
THESE THINGS IN TRYING TO GET
THINGS GOING AT IT IT REQUIRES
MORE RESOURCES AND WHAT TIME BUT
AT THE SAME TIME THOSE THE TO
GET PEOPLE INVOLVED AND ENGAGED --
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT SO THAT
UP THOSE ENTITIES HAVE A LOT
MORE -- OF PARTICIPATION I THINK
BUT THE GENERAL PUBLIC IN THAT
SENSE SO I EXT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL AS WE
MOVE FORWARD.
SECOND HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
MS ONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
IT JUST SUPER QUICKLY I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF THE
OPPOSITION AND WE WILLCONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM TO TRY TO
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE HERE
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO IMPOSE ANY
UNNECESSARY.
WORK OR BURDEN WHAT EVERYTHING
THAT WE ASK OUR LOCAL DISTRICTS
AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO DO IN
THIS REGARD TO HAVE VALUE.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO
BE EFFICIENT. FOR EXAMPLE
ALLOWING THE HEARINGS TO BE
CONSOLIDATED WITH ALREADY
SCHEDULED MEETINGS SO THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE A SEPARATE MEETING
BUT YOU CAN JUST INCORPORATED AS
AN AGENDA ITEM AT A TIME CERTAIN
DURING.
AN EXISTING MEETING WE THINK
THAT'S PRACTICAL THAT THAT'S
HELPFUL -- I ALSO DON'T THINK
IT'S NECESSARY OR PRODUCTIVE TO
GET IN INTO INTENTIONS OF OF
WHAT ANY CITY COUNCIL OR
JURISDICTION HAS HAS.
INTEND TO DO OR NOT DO.
YOU KNOW I'LL ALWAYS HAVE GOOD
INTENTIONS BUT I ALSO NEED TO
LOOK AT THE OUTCOMES AND THE
OUTCOMES ARE ARE ARE NOT
ACCEPTABLE WE SAW THE MARTINEZ
MAP.
OF WE HAVE BEST PRACTICES THAT
WE LEARNED BOB AT THE STATE
LEVEL SHOULD BE AND COULD BE
APPLIED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
CREATE -- A FAIR DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS SO.
THE EASY WAY THAT ALWAYS THE
FAIREST OF THE JUST TO THE BEST
WAY -- THIS WILL CREATE SOME
BURDENS BUT WE WE WHAT DO ARE
OUR BEST TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYTHING WE ASK OUR LOCAL
JUSTICE THIS CAN FICTIONS TO DO.
HELPS OUR DEMOCRACY AND ADDS
VALUE WITHOUT A RESPECT AFTER
RIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO A MEMBER BONTA.
A CLEARLY THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE TO MODERNIZE THE
RULES THAT GOVERN LOCAL
REDISTRICTING IN THIS BILL
CONTAINS A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT
ELEMENTS. TO IMPROVE THE LOCAL
REDISTRICTING PROCESS.
THAT BEING SAID IT'S IMPORTANT
TO FIND THE PROPER BALANCE
BETWEEN PROVIDING FOR AN
INCLUSIVE REDISTRICTING PROCESS.
IN ENSURING THAT THE PROCESS IS
WORKABLE FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THE OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL RAISE
SOME VERY LEGITIMATE ISSUES --
AND SO I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
EFFORTS TO TRY TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AND ADDRESS SOME
LOGISTICAL AND LOGISTICAL
CONCERNS THAT I HAD ABOUT THIS
BILL ACTUALLY.
HAD A MEETING A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
WITH WITH THE PROPONENTS OF THE
BILL BECAUSE I FIRST HEARD ABOUT
IT I THOUGHT THIS IS A VERY
RIGHTEOUS ISSUE -- WITH A LOT OF
BIG PROBLEMS IN THE BILL AS IT
WAS INITIALLY DRAFTED AND SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE -- YEAH THE
WILLINGNESS OF OF THE AUTHOR --
AND AND THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
TO MAKE SOME CHANGES MY
ASSUMPTION IS THOSE WILL BE THE
LAST CHANGES MADE -- AS YOU ALL
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH WITH THE THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS -- SO DOLLARS
INCREASE AT THE OTHERS COME INTO
ANY WORKING WITH THE OPPONENTS
AS WE DISCUSSED WITH THAT
UNDERSTANDING IN THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE AUTHOR WILL
BE TAKING AMENDMENTS.
THAT IT OUTLINES PRESENTATION
WHEN THIS BILL REACHES THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE I'M
RECOMMENDING A SUPPORT ON THE
BILL TODAY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BERMAN HI BERMAN I'D
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CALDERON.
LOW.
NO I MAYES.
MAYES NO MULLIN.
WEBER.
WEBER I SO WE WILL KEEP THAT
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO
ADD ON IT THERE.
TO WAIT BACK AND GET MY
NOMENCLATURE ON CALL ON SECOND.
HOW?
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PUT ON CALL MR
BONTA YES I WOULD PERFECT THE
BILL IS ON CALL.
WE'LL TAKE IT OFF GONNA GET MORE
FOLKS -- MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
CALLING THANK YOU THAT
[inaudible]
RIGHT -- YEAH FIRST OF SOME OF A
SINGLE PERSON [inaudible]
YEAH.
WHAT DO COME ON UP GET SAID --
YEAH GREAT [inaudible]
AT I I GUARANTEE YOU IT'S NOT
YOU.
WE DON'T BELONG TO HOURS MIGHT
BE ANOTHER LONG TWO HOURS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA WITH ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB.
FIFTY NINE AND FOR FOLKS IN THE
AUDIENCE YOU TO YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE THE BE
GREAT -- IF SOMEONE WERE KALRA
PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTY NINE BUILDS UPON OUR
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO INCREASE
EVICTING GAUGE WHEN AND VOTER
TURNOUT AMONG YOUNG VOTERS.
I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT FOR THE ANALYSIS.
OF THE BILL WOULD DO THE THE
FOLLOWING REQUIRE A VOTE CENTER
OR SATELLITE OFFICES OF THE
COUNT COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICE TO
BE PLACED.
ON A CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUS REQUEST THAT YOU SEE
SYSTEMS AT A PLACE OF THOSE
VOTES ON OUR SIDE OFFICE ON
THEIR CAMPUSES.
GIVE PREFERENCE TO VOTE CENTERS
AND SATELLITE OFFICES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S BEAUTY COLLEGE
CAMPUSES AND PRIVATE
UNIVERSITIES.
REQUIRED COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS TO CONSIDER COLLEGE
CAMPUSES WILL THESE TEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS FOR A BOAT CENTER
LOCATION AS PART OF THEIR JOB
PLANTS.
AND REQUIRE EACH VOTE CENTER
SIDE OFFICE TO BE ACCESSIBLE TO
VOTERS WITH DISABILITIES.
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
ACCESSIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
DESCRIBED IN THE FEDERAL.
EIGHTY EIGHT HAVING ACCESS TO
ABOUT CENTER CAN EASILY SOLVE
EVERY REASON A PERSON MAY HAVE
THAT PREVENTS THEM FROM CASTING
ABOUT. FOR THE MOVE FORGOT TO
BETTER SIR LOS ABOUT THE AT WORK
OR SCHOOL ON TUESDAYS.
I DON'T HAVE STAMPS MAYBE
ENGLISH AS THEIR FIRST LANGUAGE.
IT CAN ALL BE SOLVED.
AND THEY WILL BE ABLE TO CAST A
BALLOT.
CALL CALL CAPS ARE UNIQUELY
SUITED TO HOST VOTE CENTERS AND
SATELLITE OFFICES BECAUSE CALL
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY BASS THESE
BARRIERS TO VOTING AND AS WE
KNOW COLLEGE CAMPUSES OURS.
WRINKLED THROUGHOUT OUR ENTIRE
STATE.
THAT'S CSU SACRAMENTO -- BY WAY
OF EXAMPLE WERE ABOUT CENTER WAS
PLACES PAST ELECTION WE SAW A
TOTAL OF FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
FOUR IN PERSON VOTERS FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT PEOPLE THAT
REGISTERED AND VOTED.
USING CONDITION WHICH IS AN
ENORMOUS NUMBER WHICH IS.
USING CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION AT TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS
DROPPED OFF AB FIFTY NINE WILL
EXPAND THE SUCCESS THAT WE
SOUGHT CSU SACRAMENTO CAMPUSES
ALL ACROSS THE STATE.
BY BRING ABOUT CENTER TO THEM WE
ARE EMPOWERING AND ENGAGING
YOUNG PEOPLE WHICH WILL IN TURN
DECREASED A DISPROPORTIONATE
REPRESENTATION VOTER TURNOUT.
AND MOVE MOVE US TOWARD A MORE
TOWARDS A MORE PERFECT DEMOCRACY.
WITH ME PROVIDE SPORTING
TESTIMONY IS NO WELL MORE OF THE
PRESIDENT ASSOCIATES STUDENTS AT
SAC STATE.
MIKE MOOD OF FAR OUT FROM
SEATTLE BACK TO COLLEGE AND
RACHEL EBAY FROM UC IRVINE.
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING SIR BERMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS NO
WELL MORE AND I CURRENTLY SERVE
AS THE ASSOCIATED STUDENTS
PRESIDENT AT SAC STATE I WANT TO
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA --
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
IN HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE OF CIVIC RIGHTS
AND ENGAGEMENT.
I'M EXCITED TO ATTEST TO THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF HAVING A VOTE
CENTER ON A COLLEGE CAMPUS --
WILL STUDENTS DEEPLY CARE ABOUT
ISSUES OUTSIDE OF OUR COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE AND BEING CIVIC WE
ENGAGED THE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT WERE IN -- MAKING GAUGING
IN ELECTION PROCESS SEES A LOT
MORE CHALLENGING -- BOTH DUE TO
LOGISTICS AND DUE TO OVERALL
AWARENESS FOR STUDENTS LIFE CAN
GET TO BE EXPRESSLY HECTIC WITH
COMPETING RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
INCLUDE ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT OF
COURSE ENGAGING IN EXTRA
CURRICULAR.
AND PROFESSIONAL ACTIVITIES BUT
ALSO WORKING JOBS OFTEN MULTIPLE
ONES AND WELL OVER TWENTY HOURS
A WEEK TO AFFORD TO PRESENT A
COLLEGE EDUCATION.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS
BILL ENABLES ALL CSU STUDENTS TO
EXERCISE THE RIGHT TO VOTE IN
THE SAME WAY THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO AT SAC STATE.
BY INCREASING ACCESS AND
VISIBILITY TO THIS MOST
FUNDAMENTAL CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION SOME
POINTS OF PRIDE THAT WE HAVE --
REGARDING OUR VOTE CENTER WE HAD
THE LARGEST CONDITIONAL VOTER
COUNT ABOUT VOTE CENTERS AND SAT
COUNTY AND ACTUALLY THE ENTIRE
STATE.
IN ADDITION WE HAD TWO THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS DROPPED OFF AND THE
AMOUNT OF STUDENTS WAITING TO BE
ISSUED A BALLOT IN THE LINES --
AT THE POLLS WAS ALSO QUITE
EXTRAORDINARY WE GOT STUDENTS
WAITING IN LINE AND TOLL OF IN
PM WHICH REALLY UNDERSCORES THE
DEDICATION THAT STUDENTS HAD IN
EXERCISING THIS RIGHT.
IN ESSENCE IT WAS CLEARLY NEEDED
AND IT WAS USED EXTENSIVELY.
HAVING THE VOTE CENTER ALSO
PROVIDED AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
VARIOUS STUDENT LEADERS TO COME
TOGETHER AND HOST INCREDIBLE.
OF BOTH PARTIES THAT HIGHLIGHTED
THE CENTER AND THAT REALLY
CREATED A CULTURE OF COMMUNITY
OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
I'M IT SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED
VOTER APATHY A YOUNG AMONG
YOUNGER VOTERS WHICH IS A HUGE
ISSUE.
AND THE IMPACT WAS ALMOST
IMMEASURABLE -- EXCEPT IT IS AND
THAT'S WHY PROVIDED THE NUMBERS.
FOR THESE REASONS I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AND VOTE YES ON A. B.
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK HERE TODAY --
MY NAME IS MAHMOUD EL FAR I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF MUCH FOR LET'S
CALIFORNIA AND THE DIRECTOR OF
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR THE STUDENT
GOVERNMENT.
AT SUBCOMMITTEE COLLEGE ALSO
LIKE THIS THANK ASSEMBLYMAN
KALRA FOR LETTING ME TESTIFY
HERE TODAY.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY
NINE BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT IS
ESSENTIAL INISH INSURING
STRONGER VOTER TURNOUT AMONG
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AS
WELL AS COLLEGE STUDENTS IN
GENERAL.
AND THE STRENGTH IN OUR
DEMOCRACY AS A WHOLE YOUNG
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA VOTE AT
ALARMINGLY LOW RATES.
I BELIEVE ON CAMPUS VOTE CENTERS
WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO VOTE.
AND WILL ELIMINATE ANY MORE
BARRIERS THAT PREVENT THEM FROM
VOTING.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE SPECIALLY
IN NEED OF ON CAMPUS VOTE
CENTERS DUE TO THE DIVERSITY OF
THEIR STUDENT BODIES.
THERE ARE TWO POINT THREE
MILLION STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND ONE POINT THREE
MILLION OF THEM ARE UNDER.
TWENTY FIVE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS OFTEN WORK FULL TIME
AND PART TIME JOBS WHILE GOING
TO SCHOOL AND HAVE TROUBLE
FINDING TIME TO VOTE ON ELECTION
DAY.
MANY MAY HAVE NEVER VOTED BEFORE
AND HAVE NEVER HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO THE POLLS
WITHOUT APPARENT.
THE ABILITY TO VOTE I VOTE
CENTERS ON CAMPUS WOULD ALLOW
STUDENTS TO EASILY VOTE.
WITHOUT HAVING TO MISS CLASS OR
CALL OUT OF WORK.
BUT SENATOR MOWER COST EFFECTIVE
SAFE AND IT MAKES IT EASIER TO
VOTE.
IN THE PAST MID TERM ELECTION I
SAW HOW BENEFICIAL ON CAMPUS
VOTE CENTERS CAN BE EVEN FOR ONE
SINGLE DAY.
I THOUGHT ABOUT COLLEGE WE HAD A
POP UP VOTE CENTER THAT ARRIVED
ON OUR CAMPUS FOR ONE DAY ON
HALLOWEEN.
AS YOU COULD IMAGINE YOU'D
EXPECT STUDENTS NOT TO BE ON
CAMPUS DURING HALLOWEEN -- BUT
IT DEDICATED FULL SERVICE VOTE
CENTERS.
AND PROVIDE ON CAMPUS FOR FUTURE
ELECTIONS AND WE HAD A
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGH VOTER TURNOUT
ON THAT DAY.
IN THE STEPS DESPITE IT BEING A
HOLIDAY OVER THREE HUNDRED
STUDENTS CAST EARLY BALLOTS THAT
DAY AND WE CAN EXPECT THAT
NUMBER TO SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
IF THIS BILL DOES PASS.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR
MUCH REALIZE CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO EMPOWER YOUTH TO
HAVE A ROLE IN THE POLICY
DECISIONS.
THAT SHAPE THEIR LIVES AB FIFTY
NINE GIVES YOUNG PEOPLE THE
TOOLS TO MAKE THEIR VOICES HEARD.
THEREFORE I RESPECTFULLY ASK ALL
OF YOU HERE ON THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS RICHARD YOU BAY AT ONE OF THE
CORRECT THIS UP IN MY FOR LIFE
CALIFORNIA AND I'M A STUDENT AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE.
AS STUDENT I SAW FIRSTHAND THE
DIFFICULTIES AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF VOTING IN COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
STUDENTS CARE ABOUT THE ISSUES
AND POLITICS BUBBLE AT A LOWER
RATE THAN ANY OTHER AGE GROUP I
SAW YOU SAY STUDENTS CANVASSING
FOR CANDIDATES UP AND DOWN.
THE BALLOT ON AND ON ALL SIDES
OF THE SPECTRUM.
THANKS FOR A GREAT REGISTER
VOTERS YOU SEE I WAS LUCKY
ENOUGH TO HAVE SEVERAL POLLING
PLACES ON CAMPUS BUT EVERY
SINGLE ONE STILL HAD A LINE
LONGER THAN TWO HOURS.
I PERSONALLY HAD TO WAIT ABOUT
TWO AND A HALF HOURS JUST TO
VOTE BUT THE TIME I GOT TO THE
FRONT OF THE LINE I HAD MR
LECTURE IN NOTED TECHS AND THE
RIGHT TO VOTE. TO ME IT WAS
WORTH IT BUT I SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN BOTH.
MANY OF MY FRIENDS AND HALL
MATES TOLD ME THAT THEY DIDN'T
VOTE BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO GET TO
CLASS.
THEN HAVE TIME TO WAIT IN LINE
AND MANY ALSO HAD COMPLICATIONS
WHAT THEY FOUND THE RIGHT TO THE
POLLING CENTER.
IN ADDITION TO LONG LINES THE
BOWLING CENTERS THAT HAVE
TRAINED STAFF AND TOLD STUDENTS
IT WAS NO SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION.
MANY OF THE BALLOTS WERE
PROVISIONAL BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY
RAN OUT OF ORIGINAL BALLOTS.
AND MANY STUDENTS FACE
DISENFRANCHISEMENT BECAUSE OF AN
UNACCOUNTED ISSUES WITH ALL MY
REGISTRATION THAT DID NOT ALLOW
THEM TO CHANGE THE ADDRESS TO
THE SCHOOLS.
THERE'S NO DENYING THAT THEY'RE
HERE THAT THERE'S A HIGH DEMAND
AND LOW SUPPLY VOTING LOCATIONS
AND THE ANSWER WOULD BE TO
PROVIDE VOTING CENTERS AND WHICH
WOULD A LOT FOR THE EXTRA
ASSISTANCE.
AREAS LIKE LONG LINES TO TO THE
LEAD TO THE DISENFRANCHISEMENT
OF YOUNGER POPULATIONS WOULD BE
EVEN WORSE THAN.
LONG LINES WOULD BE NO LINE AT
ALL BECAUSE THERE'S NO WHERE TO
VOTE.
LIKE MANY OF MY PEERS I DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO A CAR OR RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION WOULD WOULD WHICH
WOULD MEAN THAT IF THERE WERE NO
NEARBY -- LOCATION VOTE I DON'T
KNOW HOW I WOULD GET THEIR I
CAME HERE ALL THE WAY FROM
IRVINE TO ADVOCATE FOR THIS BILL
WHICH SHOWS THAT I GO TO ANY
LENGTHS TO VOTE.
HOWEVER IT THE AVERAGE BUSY
BECAUSE CITY CANNOT AFFORD TO
SPEND MUCH TIME AWAY FROM SCHOOL
TO GET TO A POINT PLACE.
AS COLLEGE STUDENTS WE NEED AB
FIFTY NINE TO GIVE STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE TERM
FRANCHISE A POPULATION OF
AGAINST COSTED FRIENDS THAT ARE
OFTEN FORGOTTEN.
I FULLY SUPPORT AB FIFTY NINE
AND ASK OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT --
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL THANKS.
CHARACTERS SO REPRESENTING THE
CAL STATE TO ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT THE BILL AND CONCEPT
WILL HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
IN A MONTH.
THANKS.
JESSICA YESTER FROM -- MORE
TREAD LIFE SACRAMENTO'S AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SEMOLINA MI FAMILIA VOTE AND
SUPPORT THANKS.
BUSH I WAS HAPPY WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION PROUD TO BE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU JERRY FOR SAID A BAND
OF VOTERS I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU -- CARES
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A SHAMAN THE LONG ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY STATE ALEX WITH THE AT
NO FORMAL POSITION YET BUT I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US -- TO
WORK UP PRACTICAL CONSIDERATIONS
UP THAT CSU REQUIREMENT TO HIDE
BUT CENTERS CAMPUS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JEREMY SIR I WITH THE UC
BERKELEY VOTE COALITION HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE NOW PER WITH UC BERKELEY BUT
COALITION AND ON BEHALF OF THE
UC BERKELEY STUDENT GOVERNMENT
ALSO KNOWS THE S. YOU SEE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE A CHAIR ON BEHALF OF
EMPOWERING MARGINALIZED ASIAN
COMMUNITIES IN THE STOCKTON
CENTRAL VALLEY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
KELLY GROWTH NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT THANKS.
SKY WAGONER WITH MARCH FOR LIVES
IN AS A CAL STATE LONG BEACH
STUDENT STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
POR BRILEY SPORTING OF UC
BERKELEY AND MEMBER OF ALL OF A
SUDDEN NINE AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
AND HAVING REPRESENTING MARK FOR
A LIVES AND ALSO AN ORANGE
COUNTY STUDENT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO
COLLEGE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR MOTIONS OR SECONDS.
HAVE A MOTION.
HAVE A SECOND.
MS CALL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
WANT TO THANK THESE WONDERFUL.
WITNESSES FOR THEIR TESTIMONY
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
CONSULTANT STAFF THAT DID A
EXCELLENT REPORT.
THAT'S WHY THE SO I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR BRING THIS BILL FORD
YOUNG ADULT TURNOUT IS NO WHERE
WHERE IT SHOULD BE NOR NEAR
WHERE IT SHOULD BE -- AND
PLACING A VOTE CENTER OR
SATELLITE OFFICE ON A COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY CAMPUS COULD HELP
BRING ATTENTION ENGAGE THIS
GROUP THAT IS ALREADY ENGAGE AND
WANTS TO VOTE.
BUT SOMETIMES THE BARRIERS ARE A
BIT TOO HIGH.
HOWEVER I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE
STILL SOME OUTSTANDING ISSUES
THAT ARE GOING TO BE ADDRESSED
AS THE BALL MOVES FORWARD.
WITH THE AUTHORS COMMITMENT THAT
HE'S GIVEN TO WORK WITH THE
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS IN
THE SECRETARY OF STATE ON THOSE
ISSUES.
AND WITH THE ACCEPTANCE OF THE
AMENDMENT OUTLINED IN COMMON
NUMBER SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS
WHICH JUST TO CONFIRM A GOOD
STEP PERFECT.
I WILL BE RECOMMENDING SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL -- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE BERMAN
AYE GALLAGHER.
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE LOW [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MULLIN.
WEBER.
WEBER I WE WE LOST A COUPLE
MEMBERS BUT THE BILL IS ON CALL.
WILL.
GET MORE FOLKS WHEN IT COMES IN.
THANKS BRIGITTE.
MOVING ON TO MISTER GIBSON.
WITH ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
SO MY LOOKING FOR EMOTIONS ARE
SECONDS.
GOT A MOTION.
GOT A SECOND THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN WHICH WOULD
HELP PROVIDE INCARCERATED PEOPLE
IN COUNTY JAILS INFORMATION ON
VOTER REGISTRATION AND VOTERS
RIGHTS.
CALIFORNIA INCARCERATE OVER
EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IN HIS JAIL AND MORE THAN HALF
OF THEM -- HAVE NOT BEEN
SENTENCED OR ON FENTON'S OR
EXCUSE ME HAVE NOT BEEN
CONVICTED OR THEY ARE ON
SENTENCE.
OF THIS IS A LARGE COMMUNITY
THAT HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
EXCLUDED FROM CIVIC
PARTICIPATION DUE TO EITHER --
MISSED INFORMATION OR LACK OF
INFORMATION MANY.
WHO ARE BEHIND BARS DO NOT KNOW
THEY CAN REGISTER TO VOTE
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES STATES AND
LOCAL JUVENILE DETENTION
FACILITIES TO ASSIST AND VOTER
REGISTRATION FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE AGED WHO ARE AGENT?
WHO CAN VOTE OF H. AND R. HAVE
NOT BEEN SERVING A FELONY --
SENTENCE THIS BILL WOULD AN ACT
A SIMILAR PROVISION FOR ADULTS
BY REQUIRING EACH COUNTY JAIL TO
ALLOW AT LEAST ONE ORGANIZATION.
TO PROVIDE A BORDER EDUCATION
PROGRAM IN COUNTY JAIL THIS
PROGRAM WILL INCLUDE INFORMATION
ABOUT VOTERS RIGHTS.
VOTER REGISTRATION ASSISTING
WITH RETURNING THE VOTER
REGISTRATION CARD TO AN ELECTION
OFFICIAL WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES
REPRESENTATIVE.
FROM A NEW WAY OF LIFE AND ALSO
THE ACLU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BRITTANY
STONECIPHER AND I'M A VOTING
RIGHTS ATTORNEY WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE ACLU IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT
AB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN WITH WHICH
WOULD REDUCE PRACTICAL BARRIERS
FOR PEOPLE ARE IMPACTED BY THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM BUT WHO
NONETHELESS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
VOTE.
AS CALIFORNIA HAS BEGUN TO MOVE
AWAY FROM MASS INCARCERATION AND
TOWARDS CREATING MORE INCLUSIVE
ELECTORATE IT CLARIFIED THAT
PEOPLE KEEP THEIR VOTING RIGHTS
WHEN THEY'RE IN COUNTY JAIL OR
WHEN THEY'RE ON A FORM OF COUNTY
LEVEL COMMUNITY SUPERVISION.
NONETHELESS THE APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED IN COUNTY JAILS
LARGELY BLACK AND BROWN FOLKS.
FACE A UNIQUE SET OF LOGISTICAL
OBSTACLES WHEN THEY REACH FOR
THE BALLOT BOX. EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WILL HELP
CALIFORNIANS IN COUNTY JAIL TO
OVERCOME THESE HURDLES BY
REQUIRING SHERIFF'S TO ALLOW
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONDUCT IN
PERSON VOTER REGISTRATION
ACTIVITIES.
COUNTIES ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
PARTNERED WITH JAILS TO PROVIDE
THESE PROGRAMS OF OFTEN SEEN
GREAT SUCCESS.
IN JUST TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
FOR INSTANCE COUNTY
ORGANIZATIONS HELP THE REGISTER
OVER THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE AND
HELP TO RETURN OVER THOUSAND
BALLOTS FROM INSIDE LA COUNTY
JAILS.
IN ORANGE COUNTY BY CONTRAST
WITH THE SHERIFF HAS DENIED
ACCESS TO JAILS TO DO
REGISTRATION CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS OF OFTEN HAD TO
RESORT TO LESS EFFECTIVE AND
MORE RESOURCE INTENSIVE METHODS
SUCH AS WAITING OUTSIDE OF THE
JAILS AT NIGHT. FOR PEOPLE TO BE
RELEASED SECOND REGISTER THEM OR
SPENDING MONEY ON DOING MASSIVE
MAILINGS TO PEOPLE INSIDE THE
COUNTY JAILS. EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN ALSO MADE
PROCEDURAL REFORMS THAT WILL UP
THAT ON HOW COUNTIES UPDATE THE
REGISTRATION STATUS OF VOTERS
WITH CONVICTIONS.
SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE NOT IMPROPERLY
DISENFRANCHISED BECAUSE OF
OUTDATED COURT REPORTING SYSTEMS
OR MISINFORMATION.
UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE HEARD FROM
ADVOCATES ELECTION OFFICIALS AND
VOTERS THAT SOME COURTS ARE
STILL SENDING OVER INCLUSIVE
LISTS OF CONVICTED OR EVEN JUST
CHARGED.
UP PEOPLE WITH FELONIES.
LAST YEAR SEVERAL COUNTIES FACE
THE THREAT OF LAWSUITS IN
CONNECTION WITH THESE TYPES OF
ERRORS.
LAOS THE PROTECT THE RIGHT TO
VOTE FOR PEOPLE ON COUNTY
SUPERVISION AND THE I ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DEREK ANDERSON ON HER BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PARTIAL WAS READY WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION WAS
SUPPORTING CONCEPT THANK YOU --
DER SUPREME WITH ALL OF US AND
NOT STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
BOB RILEY LEGAL SERVICES OR
PRESENTS WITH CHILDREN POLICY
FELLOW AND MEMBER OF ALL OF
SUNLAND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE IS THE CHAIR WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYWAY THIS IS IN OPPOSITION OR
TRAINERS.
A GOOD MORNING -- RYAN RUN GO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF COURSE ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
DEFINITELY BETWEEN -- ON THAT
SIDE WE PROVIDED SOME AMENDMENTS
ON THIS TO MOVE FROM MAY BE
NEUTRAL -- TO TO SUPPORT -- SO
I'D ASK IT IS ACTUALLY INCLUDED
THE BILL ANALYSIS OF BAG ASK YOU
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT WE LOVE
TO WORK WITH STAFF ON THANK YOU.
BRIDGET THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BRING ABOUT THE CALLS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MS RUSHER --
SO.
I JUST WANT TO GET A LITTLE BIT
OF CLARITY ON ON SOME OF THE
SAAB'S WINDOW I MEAN I KNOW
THERE'S OTHER BILLS ON THIS BUT
IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE A FELON YOU
CAN'T.
YOU CAN'T THE REST CORRECT OKAY
JUST TO CLARIFY IF YOU ARE IN
COUNTY JAIL FOR THE CONVICTION
OF A FELONY FIRST A COUNTY JAIL
FELONY YOU CAN VOTE OR IF YOU'RE
ON PROBATION FOR FELONY.
IS A ONE OF THOSE OF ONE OH NINE
SERVING YOUR TIME IN COUNTY JAIL --
FOR SELLING ME RIGHT -- YOU DO
HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE UNDER THE
THE VIDEO CHANGE TRADE THAT
HAPPENED A COUPLE YEARS AGO
RIGHT [inaudible]
SACRAMENTO.
MY BILL IT WASN'T ALWAYS YOUR
BILL GAINES OKAY.
ANYWAY I DON'T KNOW -- NO
OFFENSE MEANT AT ALL YES.
IT CLARIFIED ONE OH NINE AND IT
WENT TO COURT.
WE WE WANTED CORD WAS BEING
BASICALLY CHALLENGED BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE ONE VIDEO
BECAME SECRETARY STATE HE
INVESTIGATED AND DROP THE
OPPOSITION BUT IT HAD BEEN.
BASICALLY ONE IN THE COURTS AND
RIGHT WE JUST DIDN'T CONTINUE TO
APPEAL IT TO DEATH READ OKAY.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION SO NOW LIKE.
ESSENTIALLY ANYBODY THAT'S IN A
COUNTY JAIL FACILITY.
IS ELIGIBLE TO VOTE.
RIGHT OKAY SO -- AND THEY DO
THAT BY.
FILLING OUT A VOTER I MEAN ARE
THERE VOTER REGISTRATION.
PAPERWORK IN COUNTY JAILS.
YES OR NO NOW SO THIS WILL
PROVIDE ORG ORGANIZATIONS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE GOING TO COME
IN BUT I'M SAYING RIGHT NOW LIKE
IF SOMEBODY SAYS.
HEY I WANT TO GET MY
REGISTRATION THAT THEY REQUESTED
YES OKAY SO THERE'S NOTHING
STOPPING THEM FROM.
GETTING REGISTRATION.
PAPERWORK TO TO REGISTER AND
THEN VOTE.
RIGHT THIS BILL WILL ENHANCE HIS
BILL PROVIDE AN ORGANIZATION THE
ABILITY TO GO INTO COUNTY JAILS.
AND AS WITH ACLU TESTIFIED
BECAUSE NORMALLY THAT THE CATCH
INDIVIDUALS LEAVING JAIL AND
SPEND MONEY ON THAT YOU WERE
HERE FOR THAT BAD PIECE THAT MS
BUT THE TESTIMONY YEAH -- HAD
SPEND MONEY TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS KNOW
THEIR RIGHTS AND THAT THE YOU
KNOW GETTING THE VOTER
REGISTRATION CARD THINGS LATER.
THIS WILL PROVIDE ORGANIZATIONS
TO COME IN AND PROVIDE VOTER
EDUCATION AND VOTER REGISTRATION.
NO NO AND I UNDERSTAND THAT I'M
INTERESTED IN WHAT THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO GET PEOPLE TO GO IN
THERE TO BE ABLE TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO REGISTER RIGHT.
BUT I'M JUST SAYING LIKE RIGHT
NOW AS WE SIT HERE TODAY.
IF YOU'RE IN COUNTY JAIL.
YOU HAVE THE ABILITY.
TO BOTH REGISTER AND VOTE RIGHT.
YOU DO YOU DO LEGALLY HAVE THAT
THAT RIGHT BUT BEFORE COMING
THEY SO YOU I SPENT A LONG TIME
WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS THE CHILDREN GOING
INSIDE OF COUNTY JAILS AND
PRISONS AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
LOGISTICAL BARRIERS TO ACCESSING.
THINGS THAT ARE VERY EASY ON THE
OUTSIDE TO LONG MAIL PROCESSING%
TIMES RESTRICTIONS ABOUT NOT
BEING ABLE TO HAVE PAN AND
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANTLY AIDED BY A
PARTNERSHIP WITH CAN'T COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE SHERIFF TO
BE ABLE TO LET ORGANIZATIONS
INSIDE TO HELP.
RIGHT OKAY SO.
SO I MEAN THAT'S WHERE I'M
GETTING A BIT.
THE POINT I'M GETTING AT IS YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY TO BILLS
REGISTER AND VOTE SO THEY'RE
JUST I MEAN TO ME IT'S LIKE
ANYBODY ELSE.
WHY SHOULD WE SPECIFICALLY --
SAY HEY LOOK FOR THIS SPECIFIC
GROUP WE GOTTA DO EVEN MORE.
YOU KNOW OF A MAN WHAT WHY NOT
SAY THAT ABOUT.
I DON'T KNOW -- HOME SCHOOL
PARENTS WE NEED TO REACH OUT TO
THEM TO MAKE SURE THEY VOTE OR I
MEAN WHY DO WE HAVE.
TO FOCUS ON ONE INDIVIDUAL GROUP
OF PEOPLE HOW DO ALREADY HAVE
ACCESS TO BILLS REGISTRATION AND
THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
HOW DO HOW DO YOU REGISTER BUT
WE HAVE NO PAN?
SO TODAY IF SOMEBODY SAID IF
THERE'S A PERSON IN COUNTY JAIL
AND SAID HEY I WANT TO REGISTER
TO VOTE -- THE INDIVIDUAL.
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THE THE YEAH
THE JAIL SUPERVISOR WOULD GIVE
THEM A REGISTRATION PAPERWORK
WITH THIS A SO I CAN'T GIVE YOU
A PEN HER I..
BUT IS THAT WHAT THEY WOULD DO
INDIVIDUALS IN JAIL RIGHT NOW --
BECAUSE WHATEVER THEY FACE WITH
WHO AGAIN HAD NOT BEEN CONVICTED --
WILL NOT ALWAYS.
TRUE RED INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN
JAIL AND COUNTY JAILS RIGHT NOW --
VOTER REGISTRATION [inaudible]
VOTING.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY WE WANT TO
GO IN THERE TO LET THEM KNOW
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T THINK THEY HAVE ANY RIGHTS
BECAUSE ONCE A GOING TO JAIL.
THEY BELIEVE THEIR RIGHTS HAVE
BEEN SOMEHOW TAKEN AWAY BECAUSE
THEY'RE THEY'RE IN JAIL AND SO
WHAT THESE ORGANIZATIONS WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO IS TO DO VOTER
EDUCATION. TO LET THEM KNOW YOU
ARE BECAUSE YOU HAVE NOT BEEN
SENTENCE -- BUT YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT -- TO ONE TO REGISTER TO
VOTE AND EXERCISE -- THAT VOTE
AS WELL AND SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL AND SPIRIT THIS BILL IS
ATTEMPTING TO TRY TO DO IS ALLOW
ORGANIZATIONS TO EDUCATE.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WERE IN COUNTY
JAIL THAT YOU DO HAVE THE RIGHT
AND THEN ALSO ONCE YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVE THAT
RIGHT IS TO ALSO PROVIDE THE
VOTER REGISTRATION CARD.
TAKE THEIR VOTER REGISTRATION
CARD TO THE ELECTION OFFICIAL
AND DEPOSIT WITHIN -- THAT
PARTICULAR STRUCTURE STILL THEY
CAN IN FACT VOTE.
BY WHY I GET OUT I GET OUT WHAT
YOUR INTENT I WILL WRAP UP HERE
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M SORRY AND I
KIND OF CAME IN HERE LATE TO
THIS -- BUT I I MEAN I THINK
WHAT I'M GETTING AT IS.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
OUT THERE IN THE WORLD THAT
MAYBE DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW
THAT FRANCES THEY COULD REGISTER
THE SAME DAY AND AND VOTE YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW EVERY SINGLE DETAIL
SURE ABOUT THEIR VOTING SO I
JUST.
HAVE A HARD TIME LIKE PIGEON
HOLE IN ONE GROUP AND SAY HEY
WE'RE GOING TO DO OUT REACH TO
THIS GROUP IN THIS GROUP ONLY.
I MEAN OVER OTHER GROUPS I MEAN
WHY NOT DO IT LIKE I SAID.
FOR A BUNCH OF OTHER GROUPS
RIGHT NOW.
I JUST THINK THAT -- ONE WE'RE
GIVING OUT NOTICES TO PEOPLE
THERE'S LOTS OF INFORMATION OUT
THERE ABOUT HOW TO VOTE.
AND AND TO ME IT NOBODY'S ACCESS
IS BEING BLOCKED OFF AND SO I
JUST DON'T SEE AGAIN THE
REASONING YOU KNOW FOR THIS
SPECIFIC RIGHT WRIST GALLAGHER
FOR THE SAME REASON THE STUDENTS
WERE HERE.
REPRESENTING THE UNIVERSITY IS
TO MAKING SURE THAT EVERY --
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS HAVE ACCESS
TO THE RIGHT TO VOTE NOW WITH
PROPER VOTER EDUCATION -- BEING
MADE AVAILABLE TO THEM THAT IT
WAS THE STUDENTS WHO RIDE I I
DON'T THINK THEY NEEDED EITHER
AND SO YOU KNOW EXACTLY -- BUT
NO I'M NOT.
IN THE BECAUSE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSISTENT RIGHT TO SAY IT
BECAUSE I MEAN JUST TO BE VERY
CLEAR LIKE. TO ME THERE'S SO
MUCH INFORMATION OUT THERE IT IS
EASY TO VOTE AND I'VE SAID THIS
MANY TIMES THIS COMMUNITY IN
THIS COMMITTEE.
SO -- TO SAY THAT AND WITH
CONSIDERING ALL THAT WE HAVE
DONE TO MAKE IT VERY EASY TO
VOTE.
IN THE STATE. TO SAY THAT WE NOW
HAVE TO TARGET SPECIFIC GROUPS
WHETHER IT'S STUDENTS OR ANY
GROUP FOR THAT MATTER -- OVER
OTHER GROUPS YOU KNOW TO ME IS
KIND OF WHY WE MAKE IN THAT
SPECIAL CASE FOR A SPECIAL GROUP
OF PEOPLE.
MAYBE THEY VOTE FOR ONE PARTY
OVER THE OTHER MORE THAN THE
OTHER I DON'T KNOW MAYBE THAT'S
THE REASON I DON'T KNOW.
I'M NOT I'M NOT SAYING THAT THAT
TO A REASON.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE BUT I THINK.
MIDDLE WITH EMPLOYEES YEAH I
HEARD THE JURY COMMISSIONER WAS
TRYING TO MAKE THE CASE TO
REPUBLICANS BUT I HEARD THAT GOT
FACT FACT CHECK FALLS ON THE
ANYWAYS.
BUT BOTTOM LINE IS I MEAN I
DON'T KNOW WHY WE NEED TO
SPECIFICALLY TARGET ANY GROUP
OVER ANOTHER -- YOU KNOW WHEN
THERE IS A LOT OF INFORMATION
OUT THERE FOR THE PUBLIC TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT.
VOTING AND AND AND KNOW WHAT
THEIR RIGHTS ARE AND WHAT THEY
HAVE ACCESS.
TO THE WAS ROASTER BUT WEBER.
I JUST WANTED IS SIMPLY SAY YOU
KNOW.
THIS IS A THIS IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT ARE MY
COLLEAGUES RAISING YOU KNOW MOST
OF YOU KNOW I SPENT IF YOU THE
FIRST FOUR YEARS OF MY LIFE HERE
AT THE CAPITOL.
BASICALLY WITH VARYING VOTING
RIGHTS BILLS TO IN TERMS OF
THOSE WERE INCARCERATED MAKING
SURE IT AND IN COURT MAKING SURE
THAT -- THAT PEOPLE KNEW THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE AND I WAS
AMAZED AT HOW MANY PEOPLE WALK
AROUND THIS CAPITAL WHO DID NOT
KNOW SOMEONE MORE PROBATION
OFFICERS WHO DIDN'T KNOW THAT --
THAT'D NEXT THE PERSON WITH THE
EX FELON HAD THE RIGHT TO VOTE
THEY THOUGHT IT ONCE YOU
COMMITTED FELONY YOU COULD NEVER
VOTE AGAIN I MEAN THESE ARE
PEOPLE TOLD ME WHEN I GOT AND I
WAS JUST TOTALLY SHOCKED.
BECAUSE THEY WERE PROBATION
OFFICERS AND OTHERS WHO DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND THE RULES WE DIDN'T
KNOW THE LAW.
AND THEN IN ADDITION TO THAT
WHEN THE WHOLE ISSUE WITH THE
CURRENT -- SECRETARY STATE CAME
DOWN THE DECISION WE DID A
PODCAST AND WE HEARD SO MANY
PEOPLE WHO TALKED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THEY WERE ADVOCATES TRYING
TO GET INTO JAILS. TO BASICALLY
REGISTER PEOPLE TO VOTE AND HELP
THEM UNDERSTAND AND THEY WERE
BEING BLOCKED BY SHERIFF'S WHO
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE LAW NUMBER
ONE IN WHO DIDN'T REALLY CARE
SOME OF THEM.
NOW THERE'S SOME SHERIFFS LIKE
THE ONE IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY WHO
GOES OUT OF HIS WAY GORE DOES TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE MATERIALS
THERE IS AVAILABLE BUT HE'LL
TELL YOU EVERYONE DOESN'T DO THE
SAME THING.
AND SO AS A RESULT WE HAVE A
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED.
WHICH MEANS THEY HAVE LIMITED
ACCESS TO TELEPHONES MATERIALS
ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS AND IF
THAT JAIL DOES NOT PUT UP
MATERIAL FOR THEM TO REGISTER TO
VOTE THEY WILL LET HIM GO ONLINE
AND REGISTER TO VOTE.
AND ALL THAT OTHER KIND OF STUFF
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN IN MOST
FOLKS DON'T KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO VOTE THAT EVEN
GROUPS ARE GOING TO PICK UP
THEIR ABSENTEE BALLOTS -- IF
THEY GIVEN AFTER THE BALLOT
BECOMES AN OBSTACLE IN A
CHALLENGE SO.
THIS IS UNLIKE YOU KNOW I CAN
SOMETIMES UNDERSTAND STUDENTS
BECAUSE STUDENTS REALLY CAN MAKE
THE TIME TO DO WHATEVER THEY
WANT TO DO YOU KNOW BEGIN SOME
SLACK THEIR YOUNG WHATEVER.
YOU KNOW BUT BUT IF IT WAS A
PARTY GOING ON YOU KNOW
EVERYBODY BE DEAR AND SO -- SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT.
I'M I'M I'M JUST SAYING IT ON
CAMPUS AS I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
STUDENTS WILL FIGURE IT OUT IF
THEY REALLY WANT TO BECAUSE IT
UBER LIFT ALL OVER THE WORLD
OKAY.
BUT BUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED WILL LOCKED UP OR
AT THE MERCY.
OF OF THE SHERIFF IN THE JAILER
AND ALL THESE OTHER PEOPLE WHO
MAY NOT GIVE THEM THE MATERIAL
AND SO I THOUGHT ON THIS PODCAST
ARE A LOT OF COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATION WAS SAYING.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THIS AS OUR
MISSION WE GO INTO JAILS WE TAKE
MATERIAL WE EXPLAIN THINGS AND
WE CAN'T GET THROUGH THIS SUCH
AN ABEER YOUR THAT YOU KNOW YOU
CAN'T BRING CERTAIN PEOPLE YOU
CAN'T HAVE THIS KIND OF AND SO.
SOME JAILS DO NOT GET THE
BENEFIT OF COULD NOT PROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS GOING IN TO HELP
THEM SO THIS IS REALLY A SPECIAL
CASE OF FOLKS WHO ARE WHO DON'T
HAVE ACCESS.
BECAUSE THEY ARE LOCKED UP AND
IF THEY AND YET THEY NEED THE
INFORMATION AND THEY NEED THE
MATERIALS THAT THEIR SELF YOU
KNOW I I SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE IT
IS A HUGE PROBLEM FOR THE
NONPROFIT GROUPS THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
TRYING TO HELP FOLKS REGISTER TO
VOTE UNLIKE SOME OF THE OTHER
STUFF JUST TRYING TO GET PEOPLE
MOTOR.
MOTOR MOTIVATED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO GO TO THE POLLS
THESE FOLKS EVEN IF THEY'RE
MOTIVATED HAVE TREMENDOUS
OBSTACLES.
THANK YOU DOCTOR MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU -- FOR THIS IS JOE AND
I JUST I JUST WANNA MAKE A
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE I MEAN I
THINK HE WAS HALF JOKING BUT YOU
KNOW THERE IS THIS IDEA THAT WE
THAT WE AUTHOR -- THESE TYPES OF
BILLS DEMOCRATS BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IN THE PUBLIC BELIEVES
THAT THIS POPULATION IS A
POPULATION OF A VOTE FOR
DEMOCRATS AND IT'S ANOTHER WAY
FOR US TO HOW TO RIG THE
ELECTION IN OUR FAVOR BECAUSE
WE'RE ALLOWING THEM. TO VOTE
WHEN OF COURSE YOU SHOULD HAVE
NO SYMPATHY FOR SOMEONE WHO
MESSED UP -- IN LIFE IN A
GRANTED NOBODY.
NOBODY IS GOING TO EXCUSE SOME
OF THE BEHAVIOR OF SOME THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE BUT OUR LAWS ARE
LAWS AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THERE LAW THAT THESE LAWS ARE
ENFORCED.
AND THAT EVERYBODY'S AWARE WHAT
THE LAWS ARE -- BUT I I DO WANT
TO MAKE THE CLARIFICATION THAT
WHEN WHEN GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS
WAS ASKED ABOUT HIS TIME IN JAIL.
A HE SAID IT WASN'T BAD AT ALL
BECAUSE THE GUYS WE SOARING WITH
WORLD SHOT STOCKS TRUMP
SUPPORTERS AS IN A TREATED.
WELL.
YEAH AND HE FELL RIGHT AND HOW
MANY THAT HERE ON THE RIGHT SO I
JUST IF THIS IS THIS IS NOT
ABOUT ANECDOTAL ARTISAN.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT A PARTISAN
ISSUE AND THEIR PEOPLE IN JAILS
ABOUT FOR BOTH REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS I JUST THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT -- TO MAKE THE
CLARIFICATION THAT THIS ISN'T
ABOUT -- TRYING TO GET MORE
VOTES FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S
ABOUT THE LINE MAKE SURE THE LAW
IS ENFORCED CORRECTLY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES -- MISTER
GIBSON.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES AND
ALL THE MEMBERS IN THIS ROBUST
CONVERSATION I DO WANT.
TO MAKE ONE CORRECTION A NEW WAY
OF LIFE WAS HERE BUT HAD TO
ACTUALLY -- CATCH A FLIGHT BACK
HOME AND TO MR GALLAGHER'S ON
POINT -- HE'S MADE A REFERENCE
TO SPECIAL GROUPS OF PEOPLE AND
I THINK THAT YOU KNOW IT IT IS A
SPECIAL GROUP OF PEOPLE AS A
SPECIAL GROUP OF PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE BEEN -- IN IN THIS
SPECIFIC REGARD -- HAVE BEEN
TOLD OR BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE
NO RIGHTS AND THIS BILL
CLARIFIES WITH EDUCATION -- IN
THIS PARTICULAR REGARD -- BUT
AGAIN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO EVERYTHING WE CAN FOR THIS
A POPULATION OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
STILL HAVE RIGHTS -- ON IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
GIBSON THIS BILL ESTABLISHED
STATEWIDE PROCEDURES THAT WILL
HELP ENSURE OR MUSICIANS THAT
CONDUCT IN PERSON VOTER
REGISTRATION.
ACTIVITIES AT JAIL FACILITIES
ARE TREATED FAIRLY ACROSS THE
STATE.
I HOPE HOWEVER THAT THE AUTHOR
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR OF
INDICATIONS THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS. TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS REGARDING THE
DATA SHARING PROVISIONS THANK
YOU -- IN THE BILL -- WITH THAT
I'M RECOMMENDING A SUPPORT ON
THE BILL MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I'D GALLAGHER.
THINKING ABOUT IT GALLAGHER IS
NOT VOTING ANOTHER LOOKING BACK --
CALDERON CALDERON ON A LOW
[inaudible]
MAYES MULLIN.
WEBER.
WEBER I THE BILL IS ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVING ON I SEEMS MCCARTY IN THE
AUDIENCE WANTS TO EXPAND SOME
RIGHTS -- WORKING WITH THE ITEM
NUMBER -- EIGHT SB SIX FORTY SIX
YES MISTER GIPSON JUST WARNED AS
THAT THAT'S RIGHT YEAH.
THIS IS A SIMILAR -- TOPICAL BIT
DIFFERENT THIS IS PART OF A A
PACKAGE OF BILLS THE TO BILL
PACKAGE I'M WORKING ON TO
RESTORE THE VOTE FOR PAROLEES
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SERVED THEIR
TIME.
BUT HAVE BEEN RELEASED FROM
PRISON BUT STILL AREN'T ALLOW
THE RIGHTS TO VOTES.
MISTER MISTER VICE CHAIR THIS IS
IN A RED STATE OR A BLUE STATE
ISSUE.
MISTER VICE CHAIR.
YES.
THE STATE A FLORIDA UTAH MAINE
NORTH DAKOTA.
HAVE A RESTORED RIGHTS FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SERVED THEIR
TIME IN PRISON TO VOTE.
THERE'S EVEN TWO STATES IN THE
COUNTRY.
OR YOU CAN VOTE.
WHILE YOU'RE INCARCERATED IN
STATE PRISON ONE OF THEM IS A
REPUBLICAN STATE ONCE A DEMOCRAT
STATE SO IT'S NOT A BLACK AND
WHITE ISSUE WE SAW IN FLORIDA
THAT JUST AS MANY PEOPLE WHO OUT
THERE -- RIGHTS RESTORED TO VOTE
REPUBLICAN AS DEMOCRAT THIS IS
ABOUT FULLY REINTEGRATING
INDIVIDUALS BACK INTO OUR
SOCIETY WE WANT INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE ON PAROLE. TO BE ABLE TO
FEEL THAT THEY ARE A FIRST CLASS
CITIZENS AND NOT.
LEFT WITHOUT SOME RIGHTS LIKE
BUILDING SO THIS IS CONTINGENT
ON THE PASSAGE OF A CA SIX WHICH
WILL BE BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE IN
THE COMING WEEKS BUT BUT BECAUSE
OF SCHEDULING ISSUES -- WE HAD
TO BRING THIS TRAILER BILL --
FORWARD AND A BIT EARLIER -- ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY WITH ME ARE
TWO REPRESENTATIVES -- ONE FROM
ACLU AND WENT FROM ALL OF US OR
NOT.
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN I'M FOR
INSTANCE A FOR A VOTER IT'S
ATTORNEY WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND ACLU IS PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR AB SIX FORTY SIX
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT ALLOWING
PEOPLE TO VOTE WHILE THEY'RE ON
PAROLE MAKE OUR DEMOCRACY
STRONGER.
AND OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER.
AS MENTIONED AB SIX FORTY SIX AS
A COMPANION BILL TO A CA SIX AN
ACA SIX A PLACE MEASURE ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY BALLOT TO
ELIMINATE PROLE
DISENFRANCHISEMENT FROM THE
STATE CONSTITUTION.
AND AB SIX FORTY SIX WILL GO
INTO EFFECT TO CLEAN UP THE
ELECTIONS CODE ONLY IF THE
MEASURE PASSES.
AT THE LEGISLATION IS NEEDED NOT
ONLY BECAUSE VOTING IS A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT BUT ALSO
BECAUSE IT'S AN ACTIVE COMMUNITY.
RESTORING VOTING RIGHTS TO
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE ON PAROLE
GIVES PEOPLE WERE RETURNING HOME
A VOICE IN THE POLICIES THAT
SHAPE THERE'S THEIR LIVES AND A
STAKE IN THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
IT'S NO WONDER THEN THAT STATES
WITH YOUR BARE BARRIERS TO
VOTING ALSO HAVE LOWER RATES OF
RECIDIVISM.
IN FACT A RECENT SURVEY FOUND
THAT 76% OF CALIFORNIANS ON
PAROLE SAID THAT VOTING WOULD
HELP KEEP THEM OUT OF JAIL.
PEARL DISENFRANCHISEMENT
ISOLATES ARE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS CORD
DISPROPORTIONATELY PEEPER PEOPLE
OF COLOR.
AND A CHILLS ELECTORAL
PARTICIPATION OVERALL.
BECAUSE CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
PEOPLE ON SOME FORMS OF
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION LIKE
PROBATION AS WE DISCUSSED
EARLIER TO ACCESS THE BALLOT BOX
BUT IT BANS IT FOR PEOPLE --
ROLE CONFUSION INEVITABLY HOUSES
SOME ELIGIBLE VOTERS TO STAY
HOME INSTEAD OF GOING TO THE
POLLS. EIGHTY SIX FORTY SIX
ALONG WITH A CA SIX WILL MAKE
CLEAR THAT ANY OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE ADULTS CAN VOTE ONCE
THEY FINISH THEIR PRISON TERM.
AND WILL MAKE A LITERAL THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS STRONGER AND
MORE INCLUSIVE FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THEY ARE GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE.
MY NAME IS DARREN SUPERMAN --
SENIOR ORGANIZER WHAT ALL OF US
NON COMPONENT PARTS OF RATED AND
NOW I'M CRIMINAL PEROT.
AND JUST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT ALL
OF US NONE -- WE'RE GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION FORMED BY PHONE
ACROSS FOR THE PEOPLE TO RESTORE
CIVIL HUMAN RIGHTS A FORMER
CLASSMATE OF PEOPLE -- TODAY I'M
HERE TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST FELONY
DISENFRANCHISEMENT -- I'M FIFTY
YEARS AGO.
AND I VOTED ONE TIME IN MY
ENTIRE LIFE.
I CAN VIVIDLY REMEMBER THE DAY I
ACTUALLY VOTED -- I WENT TO THE
POLLS OF MY FATHER -- WE CAST
OUR VOTE.
AND AFTERWARD ON THE WAY HOME I
REMEMBER HIM LOOKING AT ME
SMILED AND I REMEMBER LOOK ON
HIS FACE THE LOOK IN HIS EYE.
I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND IT AT THE
TIME OF EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO --
BUT HE WAS PROUD OF ME I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY BUT TODAY I FULLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT I HAVE TWO SONS
OF MY OWN.
AND DOWN I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPERIENCE THAT.
THAT THAT YOU KNOW THAT FEELING
HE HAD [inaudible]
ARM.
I SPENT TWENTY SIX YEARS IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT CORRECTION.
I CURRENTLY HAVE FIVE YEARS OF
PEROT -- I'VE BEEN HOME ABOUT
TWO AND A HALF YEARS SO I HAVE
TWO AND A HALF YEARS LEFT TO GO.
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT IN
TOTALITY BEST THIRTY ONE YEARS
THIRTY ONE YEARS THE BALLOT BOX
WE HAVE BEEN OUT OF REACH FOR ME.
THIRTY ONE YEARS MY VOICE WILL
HAVE BEEN SILENT -- I CONSIDER
MYSELF A FIGURES IN -- I'M TOLD
I'M A CITIZEN I'M COUNTING ON
SINCE THAT A CITIZEN I MEAN I
HAVE A VALID.
BIRTH CERTIFICATE DRIVER'S
LICENSE HEALTH CARE NUMBER ALL
THESE THINGS ARE.
I HAVE TO RESPONSIBILITIES AND
BURDENS OF A CITIZEN -- I'M A
TAXPAYING CITIZEN BUT I DON'T
HAVE ANY REPRESENTATION.
I HAVE NO SAY IN HOW MY TAX
DOLLARS ARE SPENT I HAVE NO SAY
IN WHAT ELECTED OFFICIAL
REPRESENTS ME MY ISSUES.
OF MY FAMILY FISHING ALL MY
COMMUNITY.
AND I HAVE TO ACT LIKE ONE TO MY
ROOMS IN.
AND MY RIGHTS BEGIN -- FOR FAR
TOO LONG I BELIEVE THAT FELONY
DISENFRANCHISEMENT HAVE.
DEPRIVE -- AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR -- OF THE
PHENOMENA RIGHT TO VOTE -- WE
KNOW THAT.
FELL IN ITS OPEN TITAN WAS
ENACTED IN -- EIGHTEEN FORTY
NINE AND IT WAS A STRATEGY -- TO
POLITICALLY MARGINALIZED AFRICAN
COMMUNITY AFTER AMERICAN
COMMUNITY -- WE KNOW FELONY
DISENFRANCHISEMENT SERVE NO
LEGITIMATE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSE NO PUBLIC POLICY PURPOSE
NO PUBLIC SAFETY PURPOSES --
IT'S PURELY PUNITIVE AND IS
ROOTED IN THE JIM CROW
[inaudible]
MENTALITY.
PUMP THIS COUNTRY HERE THIS
COUNTRY.
OF THIS COUNTRY HAVE A HISTORY
MARK [inaudible]
ARM.
BY SUCCESSFUL STRUGGLES -- TO
EXPAND VOTING RIGHTS FOR
DIFFERENT RACES AND GENDERS AND
AND CLASSES.
AND I THINK THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO BUILD
ON THAT EXPANSION -- WE KNOW
VOTING IS THE CORNERSTONE OF A
DEMOCRACY WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TODAY TO PROTECT THAT DEMOCRACY.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO LET
CALIFORNIA'S KNOW WHAT'S THAT IS
AN ACROSS THIS NATION.
NO THAT.
OF DEMOCRACY IS ALL INCLUSIVE
AND DEMOCRACY NEEDS EVERYONE.
AND I'M ACTION YOU TODAY TO VOTE
YES.
AB SIX FORTY SIX AND LATER ON A
CA SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WHEN THIS IS IN
SUPPORT -- ERIC ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF INITIATE JUSTICE PROUD
CO SPONSOR AND IN STRONG SUPPORT
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION WE
CONDUCTED A SURVEY DEMOCRACY
NEEDS EVERYONE AND OF THE SURVEY
RESPONDENTS -- PEOPLE WOULD
REGISTER TO VOTE ALONG THE SAME
IN THE SAME NUMBERS THAT THEY
REGISTER TO VOTE IN THE STATE SO
PEOPLE ARE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED ON PER ALSO
REPUBLICAN DEMOCRAT AND
UNDECIDED VOTERS.
THANK YOU.
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING
FOR VOTING RIGHTS FOR A HUNDRED
YEARS WE CONSIDER THIS
LEGISLATION TO BE THE NEW FACE
OF SUFFRAGE WORDS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND JUST A REMINDER
FOLKS AS MUCH AS I APPRECIATE IT
JUST NAME ORGANIZATION SUPPORTER
OPPOSE THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON PARTIAL MORNING
STILL PARTIAL STRIVE WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION LEARN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE ISSUE OF FOR ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
A SPONTANEOUS WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL MEADOWS WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COLLISIONS FROM
SUPPORT THANKS.
I MEAN ELSTER LEGAL SERVICES
BUSINESS CHILDREN BERKELEY
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL CERA HOWELL TO BERKELEY
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MORE A BERRY WITH THE BERKELEY
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DANIELLE MEDINA WITH THE
BERKELEY UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
POLICY FOLLOW LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PERSONS WITH CHILDREN.
AND A MEMBER OF ALL OF A SUDDEN
NINE STRONG SUPPORT THANKS.
BARBARA HI RICH A MEMBER OF
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SINGING ON ANYONE ELSE'S
IN OPPOSITION.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A
PRESENTATION OR JUST OPPOSITION
PLEASE.
UGH MY NAME IS KAREN POWERS.
I AM A REPUBLICAN AND A TRUMP
SUPPORTER.
I RESPECT ALL OF YOU TODAY IT'S
BEEN A VERY INTERESTING
EXPERIENCE [inaudible]
ALWAYS.
YEAH -- I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
OF CALIFORNIA IS NOT IN SUPPORT
OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT OPPOSITION BRING ABOUT A
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISTER ROYSTER.
SO FIRST I WANT TO APPRECIATE
THE TESTIMONY.
FROM THE GENTLEMAN HERE AND AND
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY I AYE ME OF
SYMPATHIZE WITH WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING WHICH IS THAT YOU WANT TO
VOTE AND AND THAT EXPERIENCE
THAT YOU HAVE WITH YOUR FATHER
WHEN YOU FIRST.
VOTED RIGHT AND THAT YOU WANT TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN OUR OUR REPUBLIC YOU KNOW AND
BE PART OF THAT VOTING SYSTEM.
THE WAY I LOOK AT THIS POLICY
WISE IS THE I LOOK AT IT AS FOR
PAROLE IS IS STILL PART OF
SERVING YOUR SENTENCE YOU'RE
YOU'RE.
YOU'RE OUT BUT IT'S WERE WRONG
PAROLE BECAUSE WE WANT TO SAY
HEY WE ARE GOING TO ABIDE BY
CERTAIN RULES THEY SHOW THAT.
THAT WE ARE REHABILITATED MORE
OF RAY TO GO BACK.
YOU KNOW -- AND SO THE PAROLE IS
REALLY.
YEAH PART OF YOUR SENTENCE IN A
WAY AND SO -- TO ME I THINK YOU
KNOW ONCE PEARL IS COMPLETED.
THEN YOU'RE VOTING RIGHTS ARE
RESTORED AND WE SAY AS A SOCIETY
OKAY.
YOU READY TO TO TO VOTE AND
PARTICIPATE IN A DEMOCRACY SO TO
ME I I LOOK AT THAT IS JUST THAT
WHOLE THAT WHOLE PROCESS RIGHT.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME AS YOU'RE
SAYING HERE TODAY THAT.
HE OF EUROPEAN ABOUT WHATEVER IT
WAS THAT CAUSE YOU TO BE
INCARCERATED IN THE FIRST PLACE
AND YOU WANT TO PARTICIPATE
AGAIN AND THAT'S CERTAINLY.
SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE AND I
THINK EVERYBODY PRIDE THAT
EVERYBODY AT THIS TABLE BELIEVES
IN I JUST SEE IT AS A POLICY
MATTER THAT THAT SHOULD BE DONE
AFTER PEARL IS COMPLETE.
YOU'VE COMPLETED YOUR TERMS --
YOU'VE MET WITH ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS OF YOUR PAROLE --
AND THEN I THINK ABSOLUTELY YOU
KNOW YOU SHOULD BE PARTICIPATING
IN R. N. N. AND ALL THOSE THINGS
AND ALL OF YOUR RIGHTS HAVE BEEN
FULLY RESTORED.
SO THAT'S HOW I LOOK AT IT FROM
A POLICY MATTERS.
I DO HAVE TO FACT CHECK -- MY
COLLEAGUES WHO I HAVE A LOT OF
RESPECT -- FOR FROM SACRAMENTO --
BECAUSE THIS GOT BROUGHT I MEAN
THIS HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP A LOT
TO IT.
THAT THE THAT SOMEHOW MAYBE THE
PARTISAN BREAKDOWN IS THE SAME I
GET IT THEY DID THE ONLY STUDY
THAT HAS BEEN DONE.
ON ON FLORIDA ACTUALLY -- IS
THEY REVIEWED ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION EX FELONS IN FLORIDA WHO
COULD NOT VOTE -- PREVIOUSLY BUT
WERE GIVEN RIGHTS TO VOTE A
DECADE AGO UNDER CHARLIE CRIST.
AND WHAT THEY WHAT THEY FOUND IN
THAT STUDY.
WAS THAT -- OF THE NINETEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED EXPENSE
HIS RIGHTS WERE RESTORED UNDER
CRIST.
ABOUT 58% WERE REGISTERED
DEMOCRATS. 24% WERE REGISTERED
REPUBLICANS.
AND THE REST REGISTERED WITH
NEITHER PARTY.
SO THAT'S THE ONLY REAL STUDY WE
SEE AS HOW THAT PARTISAN
BREAKDOWN GETS MADE AND I JUST I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
DEFINITIVE PROOF -- MAYBE OTHER
THAN JARED KUSHNER SAYING THAT --
YOU KNOW ON A ON A TV INTERVIEW.
THAT THERE'S MORE REGISTERED
REPUBLICANS -- YOU KNOW WHO ARE
THAT.
STRAIGHT AFTER THEY'VE HAD THEIR
RIGHTSRESTORED AS FELL AND SO I
JUST JUST FOR THE RECORD I MEAN
THAT'S THE DATA THAT'S OUT THERE --
THEN THE LATEST CHANGE IN
FLORIDA HAS NOT BEEN EVALUATED
YET.
BECAUSE THEY JUST HAVEN'T HAD
ENOUGH TIME TO EVALUATE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT
NECESSARILY MATTERS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE NEED TO
WOULD NECESSARILY TO BRING IT UP
WHAT YOU'RE PARTISAN BREAKDOWN
IS BUT JUST.
THE FACTS OF WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS
THAT.
THEY DO TEND TO BE MORE REGISTER
TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SO THE WAS RUSHER.
ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS IN COLLEAGUES ARE
MOTIONS OR SECONDS.
WELL YOU KNOW I I APPRECIATE
THAT WHAT YOU'VE DONE AND I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT AS AS
WE TALK ABOUT.
THE CONCEPT OF BOATING AND GET
PAST THE HISTORIC KIND OF
REALITY THAT WE'VE HAD AS IT IN
TERMS OF INCARCERATION AS A
BEING A VERY PUNITIVE THING.
THAT.
HAS DONE MORE DESTRUCTION THAN
THAN GOOD IN TERMS OF BUILDING
INDIVIDUALS AND WE SEE THAT --
IN TERMS OF WHAT HAPPENS WITH
RECIDIVISM AND WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
PEOPLE ARE INCARCERATED AND
DON'T GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES TO COME BACK
AND SO FORTH AND SO ON SO OUR
JUDICIAL.
ARE.
OUR OUR PRISON SYSTEM HAS BEEN
VERY DESTRUCTIVE -- IN IN A LOT
OF WAYS IT HAS IN THIS SAY TO ME
THIS ANY SAFER -- SURE THEY'RE
PEOPLE WHO WILL ALWAYS HAVE TO
GO TO PRISON BUT WE I THINK WE
ALL RECOGNIZE TO SEVENTY STAND
CALIFORNIA WE'VE OVER
INCARCERATED.
AND PART OF THAT MENTALITY IS AT
ONE POINT WE DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE
CLASSES WE DIDN'T WANT TO
IMPROVE THEMSELVES AND NOW WE'RE
COMING BACK FROM THERE THANK GOD.
OF AND AND WE SHOULD BE MOVING
TOWARD A POSITION WHERE PEOPLE
STILL ALL HAVE RIGHTS AND STILL
EXIST HAVE RIGHTS WENT WHEN
THEY'RE INCARCERATED AS WELL.
AND VOTING IS ONE OF THOSE MOST
AND FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS IN THIS
WHOLE COUNTRY WAS BUILT ON THE
WHOLE ISSUE OF NO TAXATION
WITHOUT REPRESENTATION.
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE TO PAY FOR
GOVERNMENT UNLESS WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY DECIDE WHO'S GOING
TO REPRESENT US THAT'S A
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE THAT THAT
STARTED THE REVOLUTION FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
NOW FOR ME PRO PEOPLE GET OUT OF
PRISON ANYMORE EITHER IN PRISON
ARE BEING TAXED THERE'S TAXATION
NEW PAYING PROPERTY TAXES YOU'RE
PAYING.
OF SALES TAX YOU'RE BEING TAXED
AND YET YOU CAN'T DEFINE OR
DETERMINE WHAT PEOPLE UP HERE
ARE GOING TO REPRESENT YOU IN
TERMS OF THAT TAXATION.
THAT'S A FUNDAMENTAL AMERICAN
PRINCIPLES THAT WE HAVE SCHOOL
IT OVER FOR FOR OVER FOUR
HUNDRED YEARS IN TERMS OF NO
TAXATION WITHOUT REPRESENTATION
AND THAT IS A FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLE OF THIS NATION.
AND WHY WE SUPPOSEDLY BEGAN THIS
DEMOCRATIC -- EXPERIMENT SO I I
TOTALLY SUPPORT THE EFFORT I I
YOU KNOW AND EVENTUALLY I THINK
AT SOME POINT CALIFORNIA WILL GO
FURTHER WHEN HE REALIZES WHAT IS
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO ALL OF THE
CITY OF CALIFORNIA.
WHETHER THEY REGISTERED DEMOCRAT
OR REPUBLICAN YOU KNOW WHATEVER
IT IS BOB AND YOU KNOW SO I I
THINK IT'S JUST A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT AND AND PEOPLE HAVE THE
RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE AND I
THOROUGHLY SUPPORT THIS EFFORT.
AND WILL SUPPORT THE ACA WHEN IT
COMES BEFORE SO I'M WITH THE
BILL THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER I
HAVE A MOTION LOOKING FOR A
SECOND.
I'VE GOT A TWO SECONDS.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AND COLLEAGUES
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MCCARTY WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU THAT THAT WAS A GREAT
CLOSE BY BY DODD WHATEVER JUST
ONE MORE AT ON THIS ISN'T JUST
ABOUT VOTING.
IT'S ABOUT RE INTEGRATING PEOPLE
IN OUR SOCIETY IT'S A PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE.
IT WOULD YOU RATHER HAVE A
PAROLE LEE -- IN YOUR COMMUNITY.
STEWING BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET A
JOB BECAUSE THEY COULD FILL OUT
APPLICATIONS ON PEROT THREW AWAY
THEIR APPLICATION.
STEWING IN THEIR IN THEIR HOUSE
THEIR BASEMENT BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T VOTE THEIR SECOND CLASS
CITIZEN I THINK THE PRISON
SYSTEM SAYS YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
SAFE ENOUGH TO BE OUT THERE IN
THE COMMUNITY.
AND IT DOES A DISSERVICE BY
HAVING FRAWLEY'S AS SECOND CLASS
CITIZENS THIS IS ABOUT REAP
SAFELY REINTEGRATING PEOPLE INTO
OUR SOCIETY.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT TO
THIS EFFORT ASK THE RIGHT BOOK
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY ELATED --
FIGURING BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I KNOW THAT THIS BILLS
ONLY THE IMPLEMENTING
LEGISLATION AC SIX AND WILL ONLY
BECOME OPERATIVE VOTERS APPROVED
A CA.
SIX BUT IT'S IMPORTANT ON THE
LESS AND I EXPECT WE'LL HAVE A
LENGTHY DISCUSSION OR MAYBE NOT
ABOUT THIS POLICY WHEN THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDERS A CA SIX I
AM AND I JUST WAS OUT I DIDN'T
REFLEXIVELY.
SUPPORT THIS WHEN I FIRST HEARD
ABOUT IT I WENT BACK AND I DID
SOME RESEARCH I DID SOME
RESEARCH ON WHAT OTHER STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY DID DID A
LITTLE THINKING ABOUT.
THE CONCEPT OF HAVING PAROLEES
HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE AND IT'S
TRUE.
YEAH WE PEARL IS ONE MORE STEP
TO HAVING ALL OF YOUR RIGHTS --
IT REINSTATED AND IT'S NOT THE
SAME AS BEING IN PRISON
OBVIOUSLY AND SO I THINK IT
MAKES SENSE. TO AT TO ADD THE
RIGHT TO VOTE. TO BE ONE OF
THOSE RISE THAT'S REINSTATED
WHEN YOU'RE ON PAROLE AND AND
FINISHING UP YOUR SENTENCE --
BUT WHEN IT'S BEEN IDENTIFIED
THAT YOU KNOW YOU YOU YOU NO
LONGER.
SERVE WITHOUT TO SOCIETY YOU'VE
YOU PAID A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF THE
DUES OF FROM THE CRIME THAT YOU
COMMITTED -- BUT WE DO REALLY
WANT TO RE INTEGRATE EVERYBODY
BACK INTO SOCIETY AND REDUCE THE
RECIDIVISM THAT WE SEE AND AND
HAVE PEOPLE HAVE PRIDE -- IN
ENGAGING -- IN OUR SOCIETY AND
AND THE RIGHT TO VOTE IS IN
VOTING IS IS ONE OF THE BEST
WAYS TO DO THAT SO.
I THINK IT MAKES SENSE -- AND
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT TODAY.
AND I'M SECRETARY PLEASE -- CALL
VOTE.
AT THE MOTIONS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN I BERMAN
I'D GALLAGHER [inaudible]
SHARON.
LOW.
NO I MAYES.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER.
WEBER I THAT IS OUT ON THE FOUR
OH VOTE WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU CAN HAVE AN
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES.
AND SOMETHING WE'RE CERVANTES
BELIEVE YOU GOT TO BILLS.
ITEMS ONE IN THREE AND IN THE
MEANTIME I'D LIKE TO ANNOUNCE
THAT ITEM FIVE AB -- FOR SIXTY
WAS PULLED AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR -- AND I'M GOING TO HAND
THIS OFF TO US A MEMBER LOW JUST
FOR TWO MINUTES [inaudible]
YEAH.
MISTER CHAIR IF I COULD START
WITH AB FORTY NINE I WANT TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED
ON PAGE FOR THE ANALYSIS.
ON AND THINK ARE THE COMMITTEE
STAFF IN THE CHAIR FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE ON THIS BILL.
IN A REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY
LIKE OURS NOTHING IS MORE
FUNDAMENTAL THAN PROTECTING AND
PROMOTING THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
OUR STATE ELECTION LAWS HAVE
BEEN BODY THIS BY MAKING VOTING
BY MAIL EASIER AND MORE
ACCESSIBLE.
AS A RESULT MORE MORE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS ARE CHOOSING TO EXERCISE
THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE BY MAIL THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MID TERM
ELECTIONS MORE THAN 65% OF
CALIFORNIANS.
USED VOTE BY MAIL AS OUR PRIMARY
OPTION IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT OUR
STATE LAWS REFLECT THIS GROW
REALITY.
HOWEVER SADLY DURING THOSE SAME
MID TERM ELECTIONS IT BECAME
EVIDENT THAT THERE ARE FLAWS IN
OUR SYSTEM THAT MUST BE FIXED.
THERE ARE MANY INSTANCES OF
VOTERS WHO DO NOT RECEIVE THEIR
BALLOTS IN A TIMELY MANNER.
INDEED IN MY DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT MANY CASES OF VOTERS
IN WHICH THEY DID NOT RECEIVE
THEIR BALLOT UP UNTIL THE DAY
BEFORE THE ELECTION ON ELECTION
DAY OR DID NOT RECEIVE THEIR
VOTE.
THERE BALLOT AT ALL.
SOME VOTERS EXCEEDING THE
CALIFORNIA VOTER PROTECTION ACT
WILL HELP FIX THIS IN TWO WAYS
FIRST IT WILL REQUIRE COUNTY
REGISTRARS TO COMPLETE THE
DISTRIBUTION OF MAIL BALLOTS TOO
EARLY BUT BY MAIL REGISTRANTS
WITHIN FIVE DAYS.
OF WHEN THEY ACTUALLY WHEN THEY
BEGIN TO SEND THOSE BALLOTS OUT
WHICH CURRENTLY IS TWENTY NINE
DAYS UGH.
IN CURRENT LAW BEFORE ELECTION
DAY LET ME BE CLEAR THIS IS NOT
CHANGED THE EXISTING TIMELINE
WHEN A BALLOT MUST BE SENT OUT.
IT ONLY REQUIRES THAT THESE
BALLOTS BE MAILED OUT WITHIN
FIVE DAYS.
BY ENSURING THE EARLY
REGISTRANTS -- OUR CENTER BALLOT
WITHIN FIVE DAYS OF THE EXISTING
THRESHOLD WE WILL MAKE IT MORE
LIKELY THAT VOTERS RECEIVE THEIR
BALLOT ON TIME.
THIS WILL ALLOW THEM TO PROPERLY
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE AND
GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADEQUATELY DO THEIR RESEARCH.
SECOND TO ONE AMENDED THIS BILL
WILL ALSO REQUIRE THAT.
THERE ARE VOTER VOTE CENTERS IN
EACH ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS -- I
HAVE WILL BE TAKEN COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
THAT WERE OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS I IN WHICH THE COUNTY
HAS TO INCLUDE AT LEAST FIFTY
THOUSAND REGISTERED VOTERS.
I IN DOING SO.
WE ARE GIVING MORE OPPORTUNITIES.
ACCESSIBILITY TO ALL VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
FIFTH MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT.
THE SHOW WENT ALONG ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY STATE ALEX BUT THE YET
NO FORMAL POSITION YET BUT I'M
GONNA THINK THE AUTHOR ON THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SEEN ON ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M RYAN ROCCO --
IT THE I AM THE PLASTER COUNTY
COURT CARTER REGISTAR VOTERS AND
I'M ALSO ALLEGED THAT LEGEND
COMMITTEE CO CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COURSE
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT.
WE ONLY MEET ONCE A MONTH SO WE
VOTED TO OPPOSE THIS BILL IN A
PRIOR FORM AND IS SO -- WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT THERE
IS A AMENDMENTS WE THINK THAT
THE AUTHOR -- FOR THOSE
AMENDMENTS -- WE DO HAVE ONE
MAJOR CONCERN STILL LEFT GIVEN
THAT THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN ACCEPTED.
AND THAT IS -- WITH RESPECT.
TO HE SAID THAT CONDUCT
ELECTIONS UNDER THE PROVISIONS
OF THE VOTERS CHOICE ACT HAVING
TO SITE ABOUT CENTER LOCATION
EACH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SOMETIMES
HAVE PORTIONS OF ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS THAT ARE NOT LARGE
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS SUCH AS CUT
SECTION THREE THOUSAND FIVE AS
ME ABOUT PRECINCTS.
WERE OUR RURAL AREAS WITHOUT
ADEQUATE BUILT CENTER LOCATIONS
MAKE ELECTIONS OFFICIALS FINE
BUT CENTER LOCATIONS IN ALL
ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS.
WILL CREATE AN UNDUE AND SOME
TASTE AT SOME CASES IMPOSSIBLE
MANDATE FOR SOME COUNTIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
GOT A MOTION.
WE GOT A SECOND -- AS A MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES AND
AND RESPECTFULLY OUT WHICH IS
WHY WE ADDED THE AMENDMENT A
FIFTY THOUSAND ARE.
REGISTERED VOTERS WITHIN A
CERTAIN GEOGRAPHIC AREA I HAVE
WITHIN THAT IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE WHICH IS OUR
COMMITMENT AND AND JUST A LITTLE.
COVER GAVE.
ME IN THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE NEXT THE NEXT
STAGE YES PERFECT APPRECIATE IT.
I DON'T THINK THE OTHER FOR
WORKING WITH MANY STAFF ON
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED BY THE COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
AS AMENDED THIS BILL STILL
INCLUDES IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS
TO ENSURE THE VOTERS BALLOTS ARE
MAILED IN A TIMELY MANNER SO I'M
RECOMMENDING SUPPORT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE --
YES AS AMENDED YEAH.
MOST MISTER PASSES AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I'D GALLAGHER.
CALDERON.
LOW.
LOW I MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN MULLIN AYE
WEBER.
WEBER AYE THE BULLS ARE ON THE
FIVE OH VOTE WILL KEEP IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VIEW LIKE
MOVE ON I NUMBER THREE A. B. TWO
OH ONE YES THANK YOU MISTER TERM
EMBERS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED
ON PAGE.
FOUR AND FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS
AND I THINK IF YOUR ASSISTANCE
ARE ALONG THIS PROCESS -- AND
THE MOTION IS AGAIN WELL JUST
JUST TO WHY SHARE WITH THOSE WHO
ARE WATCHING -- I WANT TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT WE'VE
BEEN SEEN ON MASS TEXT MESSAGING
MASS CAMPAIGN TAX MESSENGERS
MESSAGING'S OUR NEW FRIEND CHAIR
OF THE MODER CAMPAIGN.
AND SO WE ARE TRYING TO ADD
DISCLOSURES TO THAT AND THIS IS
WHAT AB TWO OH ONE DOES TODAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING THE ODDS WINNERS WIENER
GOT.
TO WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO THE BILL
JUST TACTICALLY CONCERNED ABOUT --
TEXTING PLATFORMS THAT DON'T
SUPPORT A HYPERLINK -- I'M
PERSONALLY CURRENTLY INVOLVED IN
A RETIREE -- CAMPAIGN THEIR LOT
A NOKIA FLIP PHONES.
STILL DON'T SUPPORT IT ACTUALLY
WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THERE'S
NO PENALTY.
FOR A TEXT LINK SHOWING UP IN
YOUR PHONE THAT DOESN'T ACTUALLY
OPERATE ON YOUR TEXTING PLATFORM
GAJAH AND JUST FOR THE RECORD
HERE MY FOLKS I'M SORRY TERRY.
BUT THAT'S YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
IT -- ANY.
MORE TWEENER IS.
TING NINE ANY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON BRING IT BACK TO COLLEGE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE.
LOOKING WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND -- WE LIKE TO CLOSE YES
AND JUST TO ADDRESS THAT THE
COMMENT THE CONCERN FOR MESSI
ARGUE OR WE'D AGREE TO WHILE
WORK ON THAT -- ACCOMMODATION
REGARDING HYPERLINKS GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- DUE TO AN
OVERSIGHT IN LEGISLATION THAT
WAS APPROVED LAST YEAR THE
REQUIREMENT FOR POLITICAL TEXT
MESSAGES TO INCLUDED DISCLOSURE
OF WHO SENT THE TEXT MESSAGE
WILL SUNSET AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR.
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
AND TO CONTINUE TO WORK TO
RESOLVE THE CONCERN THAT WAS
RAISED -- IT YOUR TODAY SO WITH
THAT COMMITMENT I'M RECOMMENDING
SUPPORT OF THE BILL MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE
EMOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI.
BERMAN I GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CALDERON.
LOW NO I MAYES MAYES AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER AYE WEBER AYE
THAT BILLS ALSO OUT ON A FIVE A
VOTE WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN [inaudible]
I BELIEVE.
OF THE ONE THANK YOU YOU WANTED --
TO TAKE A MOTION AND A VOTE ON
THE GARCIA BILL NOW BEFORE WE
BEFORE WE DO THAT WE'RE GONNA.
WE WOULD OPEN AS A SUB COMMITTEE
AND HEARD ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA'S A. B. THIRTEEN OH SIX
I'M RECOMMENDING SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL IS REMOTE.
I HAVE A MOTION SECOND I HAVE A
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON WHICH I'M
NUMBERS IS.
I REMEMBER FIFTEEN A. B..
THIRTEEN OH SIX MOTIONS TO PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN BY BERMAN
I'D GALLAGHER.
CALDERON LOW LOW AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN AYE MULLIN AYE
WEBER.
WHATEVER I THAT BILLS OUT ON A
FIVE A VOTE WILL KEEP IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE SOMETHING OR
MULLIN YOU'VE GOT THREE BILLS.
AT YOUR PLEASURE WHICHEVER ONE
YOU WANT.
I THINK WE'LL GO IN A NUMERICAL
ORDER STARTING WITH FIVE SEVEN
ONE GREAT.
LOVE FOR HIM PAYING CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE VERY
FEW STATES THAT HAVE STATE
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS LIMITS
BUT NO LOCAL.
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION LIMITS
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT UNLESS A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ADOPTED SOME
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION LIMITS
LITERALLY ANY AMOUNT CAN BE
CONTRIBUTED DIRECTLY TO A
CANDIDATE FOR LOCAL OFFICE.
WE'VE SEEN EXAMPLES OF CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS RECEIVING DIRECT
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM A SINGLE
DONOR.
THAT ARE HIGHER THAN THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIANS ANNUAL SALARY EVEN
SINGLE CONTRIBUTIONS AS HIGH AS
A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THIS MAGNITUDE
UNDERMINE PUBLIC TRUST IN OUR
DEMOCRACY.
THIS BILL CREATES A REASONABLE
DEFAULT CONTRIBUTION LIMIT TO
STOP EXCESSIVE CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR CITY AND
COUNTY RACES WHILE ALSO
RESPECTING LOCAL CONTROL AB FIVE
SEVEN ONE ESTABLISHES DEFAULT
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION LIMITS OF
FORTY SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR CITIES
AND COUNTIES THAT HAVE NOT
ADOPTED THEIR OWN CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS IT'S SOMETHING OF A
BACKSTOP WERE.
GOING TO BE PUTTING INTO LAW
HOPEFULLY.
THIS IS THE EXACT SAME AMOUNT AS
THE STATE INDIVIDUAL
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS WE ARE BOUND
TO WITH THE ASSEMBLY IN THE
SENATE.
IT SUPPORT DISTRESS THAT AB FIVE
SEVEN ONE MAINTAINS COMPLETE
LOCAL CONTROL AT ANY POINT EVEN
TWENTY YEARS FROM NOW.
A LOCAL JURISDICTION CAN OPT OUT
BY ENACTING ITS OWN CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS.
WHETHER LOWER OR HIGHER THAN THE
DEFAULT LIMIT SO WITH ME TODAY'S
NECKLACE HEIGHT ON WITH
CALIFORNIA COMMONSENSE TO OFFER
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THERE IS
A BIPARTISAN MOTION AND SECOND --
CHAIR NICKEL SEVEN WITH
CALIFORNIA COME BECAUSE OF JUST
BE BRIEF WE THINK UNLIMITED
DONATIONS ARE PROBLEM FOR
DEMOCRACY THE OPEN DOOR
CORRUPTION PAID PLAYING AND
CREATE THE PARENTS SPECIAL
INTERESTS CONTROL.
MORE LIES IS OUR DEMOCRACY WE
THINK IS REASONABLE DEFAULT
MAINTAINS LOCAL CONTROL CHRIS
GOOD BACKSTOP IS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED WEIRD SPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND IT IS NOTICES IN
SUPPORT LEGAL AND VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KEVIN WILL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY ACTION FUND IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION AND EACH
WINNER'S BRING THAT THE CALL IS
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE WE GOT A MOTION AND
A SECOND SONG NUMBER MULLIN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THE SPEC
FAST TRACK VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IS A GOOD BILL I SUPPORT IT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE.
THE MOST IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I'D REALITY [inaudible]
CALDERON.
LOW.
LOW AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN AYE MULLIN AYE
WEBER.
I THE BILLS OUT ON THE FIVE OH
VOTE WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS -- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF YOU LIKE TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM THIRTEEN AB EIGHT SIXTY
FOUR SAY THEM OF THAT MOVE VERY
QUICKLY FOR LANDMARK LEGISLATION.
IT WAS IT WAS PRESENTED SO WELL
SIR RIGHT.
MOVING TO AB [inaudible]
EIGHT SIX FOUR OKAY.
SO -- ASSURE MEMBERS PRESENTING
AB EIGHT SIX FOUR NEXT THIS IS A
SIMPLE CLEAN UP MEASURE TO THE
DISCLOSE ACT.
YOUR CALL IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN A
AUTHORED AB TWO FOUR NINE WHICH
ALLOWED VOTERS TO EAT MORE
EASILY SEE THE TOP THREE FUNDERS
A BALLOT MEASURE AND PAD
EXPENDITURE ADS.
TELEVISION AFTER NOW REQUIRED TO
SHOW DISCLOSURES FOUR FIVE
SECONDS ON THE SOLID BLACK
BACKGROUND ON THE BOTTOM ONE
THIRD OF THE SCREEN WITH EACH OF
THE TOP THREE FUNDERS LISTED ON
SEPARATE LINES.
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
EXTENDED UP THOSE DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS TO SOCIAL MEDIA AND
ONLINE PLATFORM SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF THOSE TWO MEASURES.
THE F. PPC AS REYES -- NUMBER
SMALL ISSUES THAT NEED FURTHER
CLARIFICATION BY THE LEGISLATURE.
MUCH OF THIS BILL HAS BEEN
STRIPPED DOWN TO A SIMPLE
TECHNICAL A CLEAN UP ON THOSE --
TWO DISCLOSURE MEASURES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND JUST TO
CONFIRM YOU'D BE ACCEPTING THE
MOMENTS YES I WILL SIR
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
IN SUPPORT.
WE DRIED OUT IF WE HAVE OTHER
FOLKS WHO WERE ON THE WAY HERE
DORA'S THE WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KEVIN CHALFANT THE MONEY --
CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ANY TWEETERS REGARDS WINNERS.
BASED ON CONVERSATIONS OF THE
AUTHOR I THINK IT WOULD BE A
TWEENER ALL DAY.
JERRY BRENNAN OF BEHALF OF SCA
YOU CALIFORNIA.
I'M.
NOT TOTALLY CLEAR ON ALL THE
AMENDMENTS BUT AS LONG AS WE
REMOVED ALL THE DEAL POINTS.
TO THE DISCLOSE ACT WERE FINE
WITH THE REMAINDER OF THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL TWEENER IS FOR
FOLKS IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NINE BRING BACK TO
COLLEAGUES I HAVE A MOTION.
STILL LOOKING FOR A SECOND.
WE GOT A SECOND GOT A COUPLE
SECONDS.
WE MIGHT OF ANATOMIST IT -- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS NOPE NOPE
NOPE.
AS A MEMBER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MULLIN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SPEAKER PRO TEM ON WOULD YOU
LIKE A QUOTE CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK TRAVEL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I KNOW THAT YOU'VE
DONE -- US ON ANOTHER YOU'VE
DONE A LOT OF WORK ON THIS BILL
REALLY APPRECIATED I KNOW THERE
A LOT OF FOLKS.
IN SUPPORT WHO JUST AREN'T
PRESENT TODAY -- BECAUSE THEY'RE
AT SOMETHING ELSE NEAR THE
CAPITAL.
AROUND THE CAPITAL.
GROUNDS NOT ON THE CAPITAL.
OF THE STATE HAS LIMITS ON THE
SIZE OF CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT ARE MADE TO CANDIDATES FOR
STATE OFFICE TO PROTECT AGAINST
CORRUPTION.
OR THE PARENTS I'M READING THE
WRONG BILL.
IT'S BEEN A LONG MORNING.
WHERE AM I THIRTEEN GOT IT THIS
IS STILL A GOOD BILL FOR THE
RECORD?
I WANT TO THANK THE OTHER FOR
HIS WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE SUGGESTED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THE
DISCLOSE ACT AND LAST YEAR
SOCIAL MEDIAS CLOSE ACT OR
LANDMARK REFORMS THAT HELP GIVE
VOTERS IMPORTANT INFORMATION.
ABOUT THE FUNDERS OF CAMPAIGN
ADVERTISEMENTS SO IT'S VITAL
THAT WE TAKE THE NECESSARY STEPS
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE LAWS CAN BE
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENTED AND
ENFORCED.
THAT'S WHY I'M RECOMMENDING
SUPPORT WITH THE AMENDMENTS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND WE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI.
BERMAN I GALLAGHER.
CALDERON CALDERON I'D LOW.
LOW AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN AYE MULLIN AYE
WEBER.
WEBER I GREAT THE BILL IS OUT ON
THE SIX OF A WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND MOVING ON
TO ASSEMBLY -- TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AB.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR GOT A
MOTION AND SECOND THING MATURES
SAVE THE WEIGHTY ONE FOR LAST
THIS IS A BE FIFTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR ON LOBBYING EXPENDITURE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR WOULD INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY OF LOBBYING
EXPENDITURE DISCLOSURES MAKING
IT EASIER FOR THE PUBLIC TO SEE
WHICH ENTITIES ARE SEEKING TO
INFLUENCE POLICY MOVING THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE.
CURRENTLY LOBBYING ENTITIES ARE
REQUIRED TO REPORT EXPENDITURES
TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS FOUR TIMES A
YEAR.
ALTHOUGH THE INFORMATION IN
THESE EXPENDITURE REPORTS
BECOMES PUBLICLY AVAILABLE OF
EVENTUALLY IT TYPICALLY TAKES
WEEKS EVEN LONGER THAN A MONTH.
FOR INSTANCE AT PEAK LOBBY
ACTIVITY DURING THE MONTH OF
AUGUST TOWARD THE END OF SESSION.
IT COULD BE AS LATE AS OCTOBER
BEFORE LOBBYING EXPENDITURE
REPORTS FOR THAT PERIOD BECOME
AVAILABLE FOR THE PUBLIC TO
REVIEW FAR AFTER VOTES ARE CAST
IN THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION HAS
CONCLUDED.
THIS LAG AVAILABILITY OF
INFORMATION IS NOT ACHIEVING
FULL TRANSPARENCY THE PUBLIC
DESERVES TO KNOW WHO IS SEEKING
TO INFLUENCE THE LEGISLATURE IN
A TIMELY MANNER.
WHILE THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT
FORM WOULD REQUIRE MONTHLY
REPORTS THROUGHOUT THE CALENDAR
YEAR MY FOCUS IS TIMELY
REPORTING DURING SESSION AT
THOSE PEAK TIMES AND I AM
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. TO COME UP WITH AN
APPROACH AS BOTH REASONABLE FOR
THOSE RESPONSIBLE FOR DOING THIS
REPORTING YET MUCH MORE
TRANSPARENT AND TIMELY THAN THE
STATUS QUO.
I THANK THE POLITICAL TREASURES
ASSOCIATION FOR THEIR INPUT THUS
FAR IN THE FOR DEVELOPING
AMENDMENTS WITH THE HELP OF
THEIR FEEDBACK.
WE ARE AWAITING RESPONSE FROM
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
TO ENSURE THAT THE BILL IN ITS
FINAL FORM IS CONDUCIVE AND NOT
IN CONFLICT WITH THE REVAMP.
AND RELAUNCH OF CAL ACCESS IN
TWENTY TWENTY SO WE'LL SEE WE
WILL WORK THROUGH THOSE ISSUES
IT IS INTERESTING TO NOTE AND I
THANK.
EATEN THE COMMITTEE STAFFER FOR
WORKING THROUGH THESE ISSUES OF
THE ORIGINAL P. R. A. REQUIRED
MONTHLY REPORTING DURING SESSION
YET WAS AMENDED BACK TO
QUARTERLY IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE I DON'T
KNOW THE HISTORY ON THAT
PARTICULAR ADJUSTMENT TO
QUARTERLY HOWEVER BUT IN THIS
AGE OF ONLINE DISCLOSURE WE
SHOULD GO BACK TO THE FUTURE AND
REQUIRE MORE TIMELY REPORTING.
WHEN LOBBYING IS AT ITS PEAK
DURING SESSION AND I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND JUST TO CONFIRM -- WILL YOU
BE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS IN
COMMON WITH EVERY ANALYSIS THANK
YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WINNERS -- FOR SUPPORT AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA TRAINERS AND
SUPPORT.
YES KEVIN WOLF -- CABINET THE
MANY CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WINNERS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TERRY
THE TWEENER FROM MY S. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA AFTER CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR.
I BELIEVE WE CAN WORK THIS OUT I
THINK THERE'S SOME --
ALTERNATIVES THAT REDUCE THE
WORKLOAD BUT STILL PROVIDE
TIMELY INFORMATION FOR THAT
REASON WE REMOVE OUR POSITION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUT MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER
BRUNCH MEMBERS BROWN J. JONES A
MAP THE CALIFORNIA POLITICAL
TREASURES ASSOCIATION.
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS AWAY THE
BILL'S A JUST.
INITIALLY DRAFTED WE'VE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE
AND WE STAY COMMITTED TO TRYING
TO WORK IT WORK IT OUT WITH THEM
WE UNDERSTAND THE GOALS YOU
STRIVE TO REACH WE AGREE WITH
THOSE GOALS.
BRIDGET THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO CALLS
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WE'VE GOT A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SEEING NONE.
MS MULLIN WE LIKE TO CLOSE AS
FOR NAY VOTE AWESOME I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
AMENDMENT TO ENSURE THAT THIS
BILL GOES DOES NOT INTERFERE
WITH THE ORDERLY IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE CAL ACCESS REPLACEMENT
SYSTEM.
THIS BILL WILL HELP IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY OF LOBBYING
EXPENDITURES DURING KEY POINTS
IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND I
KNOW THE AUTHORS OPEN CONTINUE
TO REFINE THIS BILL. TO MINIMIZE
ANY ADDITIONAL BURDEN TO
ACHIEVING THAT IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY SO WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO RECOMMEND SUPPORT OF
THE BILL OF SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOST IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BERMAN
HI BERMAN AYE GALLAGHER.
CALDERON CALDERON AYE LOW.
NO I MAYES MAYES AYE MULLIN AYE
MULLIN AYE WEBER.
WHATEVER I THAT IS OUT ON A SIX
OH VOTE WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER MULLIN.
MISTER LOLO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE MY
FRIEND.
ITEM SEVENTEEN A. B..
FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISCHIEF BEAR AND THE
OTHER MOTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
THIS AGAIN -- THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE HAVE VOTED ON
THIS -- INTEGRATION BEFORE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
GREAT AND HE WOULD ADD IS AND
WHAT ISN'T SUPPORT MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHRISTY
VELMA BE HAVE A CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
IN THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SIGNATURE
GATHERING IS BECOME A COMMERCIAL
ENTERPRISE RATHER THAN A
GRASSROOTS MOVEMENT SO WE THINK
OF VOLUNTEER THRESHOLD
APPROPRIATE WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
FOURTEENERS LEAGUE OF WOMEN.
GO AHEAD LEGAL VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SOMEONE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON NOW DAVID WILL FOR THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL ALSO WANT TO STRESS THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND CAL TAXES ALSO OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL.
AND SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THEM
ALSO TODAY IN THEIR ABSENCE --
CUT JUST A COUPLE OF THINGS ON
THIS BILL AND WE'VE OPPOSE BOTH
PIECES OF THIS BILL IN PRIOR
YEARS -- WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE THE MANDATED 10% NON PAID
SIGNATURE THRESHOLD -- WE DO
BELIEVE ESPECIALLY WITH THE
LOOPHOLE IN THERE THAT ALLOWS --
FOR UNIONS AND OTHERS -- TO BE
EXEMPTED FROM THE REQUIREMENT
INCLUDING NON PROFITS YOU KNOW
THAT THAT'S NOT APPROPRIATE AND
NOT FAIR FOR GOING TO HAVE A 10%
SIGNATURE GATHERING THRESHOLD
ALL ORGANIZATIONS SHOULD BE
SUBJECT TO IT.
AND THEN ALSO THE PAID SIGNATURE
GATT.
YEAH THE PIT SIGNATURE GATHERS
IN BEING PAID ON A PER SIGNATURE
BASIS AND BANNING THAT WE ARE
POSTED THAT IS WE'VE OPPOSE THE
BILL IN PREVIOUS YEARS.
YOU KNOW WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
PAYING ON AN HOURLY RATE WHICH
OBVIOUSLY THIS BILL WOULD LEAD
TO HAVE PAID SIGNATURE IF BEING
PAID PER SIGNATURE IS -- GOTTEN
RIGHT OF YOU KNOW COULD ACTUALLY
LEAD TO MORE MONEY IN POLITICS
AND I KNOW THIS IS AN ARGUMENT
THAT'S BEEN MADE BEFORE IN THIS
COMMITTEE WE THINK THAT HOLDS
WATER.
THERE'S REALLY NO COMPELLING
EVIDENCE THAT WE CAN FIND A
SIGNATURE GATHERING FRAUD EITHER
AND SO FOR ALL THOSE REASONS AND
WITH RESPECT TO THE CHAIRMAN'S
UPCOMING WEDDING AND WANTING HIM
TO LEAVE I'M GONNA GET OUT OF
HERE I SUPERNOVA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN OPPOSITE
I THINK I'LL MAKE THE THE
WEDDING IT LOOKS LIKE YEAH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE WE'VE GOT A MOTION
AND A SECOND -- MISTER LOADS
THAT CLOSE VERY MUCH THANK YOU --
I AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR THERE
AND IS YOUR PROCESS THESE
REFORMS TO BETTER REFLECT ITS
ORIGINAL INTENT TO PROVIDE THE
PUBLIC A VOICE AND NOT TO SERVE
AS ANOTHER VEHICLE FOR POWERFUL
SPECIAL INTERESTS.
SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS
MEASURE TODAY AND I'M
RECOMMENDING SUPPORT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOST IS TO PASS AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CALDERON.
CALDERON I'D LOW NO I MAYES.
MAYES NO MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER.
WEBER ON THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
FIVE TO TO VOTE.
AND NOW CAN WE OPEN -- WITH A
COUPLE BILLS ON CALL -- ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE IS ON CALL AB.
EIGHT FORTY NINE IS THAT IT.
WAS A THREE TWO VOTE.
YEAH.
MY CURRENT NO NO WE ONE THREE IT
CURRENTLY IS A THREE ONE VOTE
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
OPEN.
THE ROLLER THE MOST IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
CALDERON I MULLIN.
MULLIN THE BILL IS OUT ON A FIVE
TO TO VOTE NEXT IT WAS ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB FIFTY NINE BY
KALRA.
IT'S A THREE TO ITS KILEY THREE
ZERO VOTE WITH THE I.
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER KNOWS LOW.
WOOD LOGO MAYES NOBODY MAYES NOT
VOTING MULLIN.
ITEM TWO AB FIFTY NINE CAL KALRA.
I AM MULLIN IS I LOW'S AND I LOW
AYE THAT BILLS OUT ON A FIVE TO
ONE VOTE.
GOING TO ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A.
B. SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN GIPSON
THAT CURRENTLY IS A THREE ZERO
VOTE THE CHAIR RECOGNIZES AND I
MOTIONS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
GALLAGHER.
ARE YOU STILL NOT VOTING.
NOT VOTING LOW.
LOW AYE MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING MULLIN.
MULLIN ON THE BILL'S OUT ON A
FIVE OH VOTES FRIENDS -- MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE.
OPEN THE ROLE ON GAR CALL ANY
ITEMS WERE MEMBERS WERE ABSENT.
I'M ITEM ONE EIGHTY FORTY NINE
VERY CERVANTES THE MOTION IS TO
PROCESS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
ABSTAINED NUMBER NOT VOTING.
CALDERON.
CALDERON IS NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
SO.
ITEM THREE AB TWO OH ONE BY
CERVANTES MOTION IS TO PROCESS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
GALLAGHER -- GALLAGHER I
CALDERON.
CALDERON NOT VOTING.
ITEM SIX AB FIVE SEVENTY ONE BY
MULLIN TO PASS IS THE MOTION TO
A PROBST GALLAGHER.
LIMON LOW.
AB FIVE SEVENTY ONE ITEM.
SIX ETCETERA JUST FOR THIS.
THE SUSPENSE IS KILLING YOU KNOW
I CAN'T.
GALLAGHER NO YEAH [inaudible]
NOW CALDERON [inaudible]
NOT [inaudible]
VOTING.
ON ITEMS SEVEN AB SIX TWENTY SIX
BY QUIRK SILVA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROACH MULLIN.
MULLIN THIS AYE [inaudible]
YEAH -- ITEM EIGHT EIGHTY SIX
FORTY SIX BY MR MCCARTY THE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CALDERON
[inaudible]
NOT FLOATING MAYES.
AND CAL THE PHONE I MAYES.
MAYES IS NOT VOTING -- ITEM.
NINE SB SIX EIGHTY ONE GONZALEZ
MOTIONS TO PASS REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON A PROBES GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER IS NO MULLIN.
ITEM.
NINE EIGHT MULLIN IS I ITEM TEN
AB SEVEN SEVEN THREE GONZALEZ
THE MOTIONS TO PASS IS AMENDED
TO RE REFER TO CLEAN
APPROPRIATIONS MULLIN
[inaudible]
MULLIN I ITEM.
THIRTEEN AB EIGHT SIXTY FOUR
MALL AND THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROACH.
GALLAGHER.
GEN.
IT'S ITEM THIRTEEN AB EIGHT
SIXTY FOUR MULLIN YES.
CALPERS I KNEW IT GET.
OKAY I DON'T FOURTEEN ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN FIFTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA THE
MOTIONS TO PASS REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MULLIN [inaudible]
MULLIN I ITEM FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN OH SIX BY CRISTINA
GARCIA THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GALLAGHER --
THIRTEEN MISTAKES YES.
GALLAGHER AYE CALDERON CALDERON
I ITEM SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE BY BONTA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND THEM.
AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GALLAGHER. FIVE GALLAGHER I
MULLIN [inaudible]
MULLIN I ON ITEM EIGHTEEN
ASSEMBLY WILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY
ONE BY MR MULLIN THE MOTIONS TO
PROCESS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GALLAGHER.
I GALLAGHER I ON ITEM ONE
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY NINE VERY
CERVANTES.
CALDERON.
CALDERON I ON ITEM THREE EIGHTY
TWO OH ONCE CERVANTES CALDERON.
CALDERON IS.
I ITEM SIX AB FIVE SEVENTY ONE
BY MULLIN.
THE MOTIONS TO PASTOR PROBES
CALDERON [inaudible]
CALDERON.
AB FIVE SEVENTY ONE MULLIN. TWO
SIX TO MISTER MASON -- ON THE
THIRTEEN OH SIX YES YES
[inaudible]
WHAT?
IT IS A ONE MORE.
WE WE GOT EVERYTHING.
I THINK I HAVE EVERYBODY ON
EVERYTHING.
ON CRISTINA GARCIA I HAVE YOU AS
AYE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE HOUSE WAS OURS.
SALAS WAS PULLED.
AND KILEY WAS PULLED
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
I WILL
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT IS THE
END OF TODAY'S ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE HEARING
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S PATIENCE